then warming oceans fueled Ida before it
made landfall as a category for
Hurricane but how many more Gulf storms
can cities like New Orleans actually
handle and what about taxpayers the
question of which cities and regions
will be able to adapt to new extreme
weather is part of the hard math of
climate change for our Focus today we'll
explore ways global warming is altering
the cost-benefit analysis for
infrastructure and finally today is the
last day of August and also the last day
for soccer clubs to trade players from
Messi to Ronaldo it's been a summer of
huge deals we're going to analyze the
billions of dollars at stake as players
make moves I'm Jennifer zabassaja and
this is quick take charge let's get
going
foreign
[Music]
we start here the war in Afghanistan is
officially over Major General Chris
Donahue was the last U.S service member
to leave the country as you can see in
that picture there and step aboard a
C-17 cargo plane in the early hours of
August 31st local time as the U.S has
left a new Force has taken control of
Hamid Karzai airport in Kabul the
Taliban Taliban special forces units
stormed the airport and celebrated the
U.S withdrawal here you can see them
right there decked out in American
military outfits and weaponry speaking
to the media a Taliban spokesman said
that quote America was defeated and
Afghanistan is now a quote free and
Sovereign Nation overall a hundred and
twenty three thousand people were
evacuated to the U.S and 15 000 to the
UK also tens of thousands of refugees
fled to other countries across the globe
and today August 30 first the final U.S
flight as part of the evacuation effort
departed Kabul Airport heralding an end
to the 20-year Coalition conflict the
war has cost trillions in dollars and
almost a quarter of a million of lives
that have been lost the world now turns
its attention to the Taliban hoping that
the social and developmental gains made
in the past 20 years are not erased
overnight last night also the U.N
security Council met to adopt a
resolution requiring the Taliban to do a
few things one of them being Safeguard
gains for women and children's rights
also ensure the country doesn't become a
safe haven for terrorists and also allow
foreign humanitarian organizations to
care out work unimpeded and as we
mentioned in the intro China and Russia
abstain from the vote on this resolution
so a lot to get to this morning and with
us to discuss is Bloomberg opinions
Bobby gauche in London as well as eltaf
najavizada who has handled Bloomberg's
Afghanistan coverage extensively and he
is joining us from New Delhi Elsa let's
just start with you what exactly does
the Taliban want now from America now
that we have officially left the country
yeah the Taliban they are seeking
International recognition from
International Community especially from
the United Nations and that's why they
are they have sought assistance of the
United States to help them seek
International recognition that's one
thing and the second thing is the
talibans
the facing uh worst economy situation in
the country especially the financial
issue and they want money to run the
government that's accounting challenges
for the for the Taliban because the U.S
fed they have cut off uh 9.5 billion
dollars in reserves for Afghanistan's
Central Bank and that's why the Taliban
want them to to be released to the
Taliban governments in the future so
that's the reason that they want
International recognitions they want to
see go to relationship with the United
States with all the countries around the
world even with the with the close
neighbors with immediate neighbors China
Pakistan around those countries
Bobby I also want to get your take on
this we we mentioned a few things that
we heard the Taliban spokesman said uh
also we heard them say at the airport
the Islamic Emirate once a good and
diplomatic relationship with the
Americans I wonder what you make of sort
of what we heard from the Taliban as the
Americans uh were finally exiting the
country
well I'm I'm much more skeptical I'd
like to see them act rather than speak
the actions so far have been cautious in
parts of the country that they have been
running for several years now their
behavior has not been very conciliatory
they've been very much Taliban 1.0
they're promising upon arrival in Kabul
that they will be a different kind of
Taliban but I am very skeptical about
that I think they certainly want
International recognition but they want
it on their terms they wanted
International recognition the last time
around two when they had power but they
refused to do the things that the
International Community required them to
do this time around the International
Community once again is making very
clear what the terms are for recognition
we'll see if the Taliban first and
foremost agree to those terms and then
we'll have to monitor very carefully to
make sure that they keep up their end of
the bargain they do have a history of
giving their word and then taking it
back
and but we did hear jensaki at the White
House say that the U.S has leveraged to
hold the Taliban accountable for for
what they believe do you believe that
that the international Powers
um do have some leverage as eltaf
mentioned about
um some of the money that the Taliban
wants Bobby I'm curious do you think
International powers do have leverage to
hold the Taliban accountable
well they have some they have some
limited powers it it all boils down to
whether or not the Taliban how badly the
Taliban wants that money and whether or
not they're willing to make those
compromises it is not an uh entirely
unlikely that the Taliban might just
decide at the end of the day that
they're not willing to make those
concessions and and decide that they
will return Afghanistan to where it was
20 years ago when they were still
running the country at that time they
were essentially cut out from the
International Community it's a more
complex country now it's a more complex
economy now hopefully the Taliban
realizes that but we can't really be
sure the the understanding of
international finances not very
particularly sophisticated they have
announced a central bank governor who
has very little actual experience
um in finance and and seems mainly to
have been in charge of extortion rackets
in parts of the country where they were
in charge this does not fill me with
with a great deal of optimism them and I
think the other thing to look out for is
what ordinary Afghans are saying and
doing the fact that so many people
particularly the kinds of people at the
Taliban would have needed to run their
country to run their economy so many of
those people are fleeing or want to flee
suggest to me that they don't trust the
Taliban if they don't then I can't see
why the International Community should
and eltaf just speaking of the ordinary
afghanis who are there what have you
heard about daily life now that the
Americans have exited for the most part
I mean has has it changed at all
well the normalcy
is a
getting back to Kabul City actually
because after the withdrawal of the
American forces there has not been any
any attacks any suicide bombing at a
couple uh a Kabul City and people at
restaurants are opening shops are open
reopening uh economy is slowly opening
in Kabul City well people are not
worried now about these security
situations they are worried about their
economic situation because the economy
is getting its worst [ __ ] in Afghanistan
the prices are increasing that you know
the medicines prices are increasing the
foods are increasing because the Imports
have been halted for a while by the
Taliban at the Customs or in Afghanistan
causing prices to go higher so that's
that's the issue daunting issue to where
the people are facing to
I have not seen the Afghan people in
Kabul that they have celebrated the
withdrawal of the American forces those
some there are some Afghans that who are
still fearful of their life of their
future because of the talibans take over
of the country and those who are fearful
or the previous government officials are
the Civil Rights activates or the
journalists because those peoples were
told by the Taliban to to to come for
kind of for some kind of Investigations
they were their their houses their homes
were not by the Taliban to search them
to grab them you know to take them for
into their Castries for some sort of
Investigation so that that has created
Fierce among those kind of people but
there are some other people that I had
spoken to they are not worried of the
Taliban because they have not seen uh
any uh any any any good thing in the
previous government if if they compare
the previous government with the current
government of the Taliban so those
peoples are kind of impartial I mean say
that they are the careless people what
they want is just
job good economy in the country and
that's it
and we we also heard I mean we mentioned
that China and Russia abstain from that
U.N um resolution but we did hear China
say that they're hoping the
International Community actually helps
with some of those things that you
mentioned eltap what is it that China
and Russia are potentially seeing uh in
in potentially a relationship that they
could have with Afghanistan I want to
get your taken then Bobby I'd like to
ask you as well
um I think uh China is is trying to
expand its influence in Afghanistan
after the U.S left the country so that
vacuum the power vacuum has been left
now in Afghanistan and some someone from
outside the country is trying to fill in
that vacuum that power vacuum I mean
also we could say that influence in the
country Afghanistan has Rich mineral
resources does something could benefit
China and China has already got uh
several contracts of mineral resources
from the previous governments and they
try to expand you know its business
environment its business opportunities
in Afghanistan as well through the
cultural government it's not only the
Taliban the Afghanistan's mineral
resources there are other original uh
projects in millions of dollars like the
Taki gas pipeline also going through
Afghanistan also that that the China's
uh build and Road initiative in order to
influence uh expanded influence across
the region Russia uh Russia well of
course Russia didn't want to see
American forces station or a base in
Afghanistan for the past 20 years for
the past two decades they have always
opposed their presence in Afghanistan
and we have had reports saying that
Russia were also helping funding the
title and providing weapons of Taliban
to fight against American forces in
order to push them out of Afghanistan
finally and that happened
yesterday all the American forces left
the country and Russia China they have
had some some kind of positive good
relationship with the Taliban in the
past two decades and now they're trying
to build on of that in order to expand
its influence across the country through
uh friendship with the Taliban which was
being called a terrorist group now they
are being called by Russians and Chinese
people as reasonable people to deal with
and Bobby is that how you read it as
well I mean I think it's interesting
that China and Russia abstain from this
resolution curious to get your take
well they clearly want to be in the
taliban's good books they don't want to
be seen as putting too much pressure on
the Taliban by abstaining they can have
their cake and eat it too they did not
veto the resolution which they could
have done so by abstaining they are
basically nodding to the International
Community and winking at the Taliban I
think altaf is exactly right both Russia
and China do not want a vacuum in
Afghanistan their interests in the
country are primarily to do with
security and geopolitics they don't want
Afghanistan to become another once again
a hotbed of terrorist activities because
some of those terrorist activities would
be directed at Russia and China just as
much as it is directed to the West the
Chinese do have an interest in in Afghan
mineral resources but I personally am
skeptical about just how far they will
go to get those resources because the
Investments required to get those
minerals out of the ground and then
transport them out of the country in a
country that has so little
infrastructure will be huge amounts of
money we're talking about tens uh of
billions of dollars that's a very high
risk for Chinese companies to take and
they tend not to want to take those
kinds of risks they may have a bigger
appetite for for risk-taking than
Western companies or Western Banks
but at the same time they they're
they're not so reckless as to barge into
a country with uncertain political
future uncertain security environment as
Alda pointed out they did have some
investments in China before with the
previous government they had a they had
a 30-year concession on a very large
copper mine not far from Kabul but they
couldn't make that project work they
couldn't make it work despite the
presence of international forces
guaranteeing security despite having a
deal with the Taliban in which the
talban promised they wouldn't attack
that mine if China couldn't make it work
then I think we should be skeptical
about whether it can sort of invest the
tens of billions of dollars that
Afghanistan will need going into the
future and Bobby just in the last minute
or so we're going to hear from President
Biden in a few hours do you see this
potentially making a state putting a
stain on his legacy at all or do do you
think it will be a combination of the
former presidents who sort of started
this whole process and and the changes
made during the presidents I'm curious
sort of what you think that will be
written in the history books now that
the 20-year War has officially ended
well the war hasn't really ended the
United States might the the White House
might want us to think it has if our
enemies haven't stopped fighting it
hasn't ended uh has the U.S now wants to
fight a different kind of war the Over
the Horizon kind of war from a distance
from a safe distance using drones
an aircraft but whether that will work
we'll have to see it didn't work in the
past when we tried to get Al Qaeda out
of uh Afghanistan without sending in
ground troops I'm skeptical that it will
work going into the future whether or
not it stains Biden's Legacy I suppose
will depend to a substantial degree
about what happens in Afghanistan now
that the United States has left and
whether there is any blowback whether
whether terrorist groups like the
Islamic States like Al Qaeda are able to
re-establish themselves there and then
begin to attack the west and attack the
United States that will be that'll
decide whether or not it'll stain
Biden's Legacy but it's important to
remember that unlike let's say in
Vietnam uh when the when the United
States left the country
this is a very different news
environment and very different
information environment this is taking
place live on Twitter people are seeing
every step of the American withdrawal
and they're seeing every step of how the
Taliban reacts afterwards this is rather
different from one still picture of a
helicopter taking off from the roof of
the embassy in Saigon this is this is a
much more powerful series of image
images not even and I'm not even getting
into the disinformation campaign that
America's enemies will use in order to
remind people over and over again about
the humiliation in Afghanistan so yeah I
think this will live longer in memory
than the Biden Administration is
counting on absolutely we're going to
leave it there Bloomberg opinions Bobby
gosh in London as always for us thank
you so much and also Bloomberg News is
eltaf nadra visada in New Delhi thank
you both for starting us off this
morning all right coming up we're diving
into today's focus of the day extreme
weather we'll be back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
so this is the difference
[Music]
and it's time now for by the Numbers
where we live the data tell us the story
today's number is three dollars and
eighteen cents the national average
price for regular unleaded gas is
expected to rise to three dollars and
eighteen cents a gallon this weekend
hurricane Ida is probably making this
Labor Day the most expensive for U.S
drivers since 2014. the storm left parts
of the golf course the Gulf Coast oil
refining Hub in the dark and for a day
it halted flows on the main pipeline
that ships the gasoline made there to
East Coast markets more than 2 million
people in Ida's path still don't have
power it could take weeks to restore
meanwhile the system of levees
floodgates and pumps installed after
Hurricane Katrina devastated the city in
2005 passed their biggest test yet and
chanali basic is here joining me now for
our quick take focus of the day on
Extreme Weather Channel hurricane Ida is
wiping out power bringing intense rain
and people and its path are really being
affected it and really the effects of
the storm are still remain to be seen
yeah and on top of Ida we have tens of
thousands of people who are being
evacuated from their homes in different
regions in California we talk about the
caldorf fire but there's actually been
more than 6 000 incidents of fire this
year alone 600
000 Acres almost burned a lot of people
to worry about and a lot of structures
that may not make it through so joining
us now to dive deeper into this extreme
weather is Bloomberg's climate reporter
Eric Roston thank you for joining us
from a science perspective how did we
get to this place of what scientists are
calling rapid intensification when it
comes to Ida in particular
the short answer is greenhouse gas
pollution but there's a chain of
causality that uh that comes between our
spoke stacks and tailpipes to Rapid
intensification of hurricanes the key
factor in uh immediate sense is warm
water uh all of the heat we have been
trapping in the Earth has turned the
oceans warmer and that is gasoline for
hurricanes and we've seen it
increasingly over the last few years we
have hurricanes that that are not
hurricanes like uh Ida started as a as a
tropical depression in the middle of
last week and within uh less time than
it takes a major city to evacuate went
from tropical depression to almost a
category 5 hurricane so this is
something that was projected to happen
more with climate change uh and
unfortunately it may be a part of the
hurricane system in the gulf and the uh
the Atlantic Ocean as we go forward and
uh Eric I mean our Focus today is
extreme weather there's so many
different weather events that we've seen
happen over the past month um chaneli
mentioned a few of those you have an
article out today that that is titled
killer heat forces cities to adapt now
or suffer and you really get into some
of the challenges that cities are facing
right now can you just walk us through
this pivotal Point uh that a lot of
cities are are at right now when it
comes to climate change
sure thank you uh this is an article
that is it's actually a sequel to uh
feature we did last summer that looks at
economic analysis of heat and income
growth sort of over the course of the
next few decades it was done by a
research group called climate impact lab
and what they do is they look at how
income change and climate change
together create conditions where some
cities will be able to protect
themselves because they can they can
afford to they have a sufficient income
growth they can buy adaptation uh and
other cities will not be able to and
they'll suffer unfortunately as
temperatures rise uh it's a it's very
detailed uh very novel analysis with
implications for what cities can and
should do to protect themselves Eric can
you give us a sense of how this is
playing out across the world examples of
cities that might be suffering more
because they don't have the money to
protect themselves and on top of that is
it just the cities that can't protect
themselves or is this really about lower
income individuals not being able to
protect themselves against climate
change
it's a really important question because
fundamental to the analysis is that
income and adaptation save lives and
that is true globally uh cities than in
more developed richer countries will uh
have fewer heat deaths as temperatures
rise and consequently developing uh
cities in developing countries will will
suffer more and see more heat deaths
within cities you see the same Dynamic
on a smaller scale which is vulnerable
populations which is a underserved
communities and older people will
disproportionately feel the heat the
good news is that cities are
increasingly aware of this Seattle which
until mid-june had been thought of as a
temperate Pacific coast city is now in
the throes of of heat planning to try to
protect their vulnerable populations
from when extreme heat comes again
I'm obviously also true of everyone else
in the region Vancouver Portland and and
all the towns between them
but we're uh I I think the late June
heat wave in the U.S and Canada uh
similar events around the world in
Northern Africa southern Europe Tokyo
and Northern Japan
um everyone is waking up to the threats
and the very practical uh in many cases
affordable steps they can take to
protect their people and uh can you talk
can you walk us through a little bit of
that Eric I mean what sort of local
level policy could we we see cities take
in the near future to to prevent some of
the future tragedies that we could see
there's really a gamut and in our
reporting one of the uh more useful and
and interesting documents uh we turned
up was a 2017
almost catalog of things cities can do
to protect themselves from uh from heat
and these run the gamut from very
inexpensive
things that everyone can do which are
taking advantage of community
communication networks and making sure
that uh Community groups know when heat
is coming know what to tell uh people
who live in their Community how to
protect themselves
I'm not sending alerts uh making sure
emergency services are trained and
funded to take care of people uh those
are on the Emergency Management end but
there's also uh the way we build cities
in some cases uh can protect us from
heat when it comes there's a well-known
uh phenomenon called the urban heat
island effect which is because of all
the concrete and glass and buildings you
know the city has kind of soak in Sun uh
sun solar energy and it makes them
hotter than rural areas around them well
many cities around the world are
learning how by planting trees by
setting up ponds by having white roofs
or green roofs
they can actually mitigate some of that
heat and prevent heat illness and heat
related mortality right I saw you
mention Maricopa County and they're
planting trees I grew up there so so
that really stuck out to me Eric rossen
we have to leave it there though he is a
climate reporter for Bloomberg news
thank you so much for your time all
right coming up what are these extreme
weather events doing to the cost-benefit
analysis of infrastructure like power
grids we'll discuss in two minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the latest report from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change made it clear that extreme
weather events left unchecked will
become more frequent and more intense
those extreme events wreak havoc on
power grids and so what does that mean
for electricity users moving forward the
cost is bound to be shared by
governments and individuals so here now
is Bloomberg opinion columnist Liam
Denning thank you for being here Liam
how is climate change altering the
cost-benefit analysis of power grids
well it's forcing us to internalize
costs that in the past we might have
ignored to some degree you know as long
as there have been power networks there
have been natural disasters that cause
damage to them and the way that's
usually been dealt with is that uh you
know the cost of cleaning up and
repairing things gets put into our
utility bills the the difference with
climate change is uh what we think of as
extreme weather is becoming more
commonplace and more intense and so the
question we face is can can the utility
model whereby we share all these costs
really cope with the higher costs we're
going to face not just from future
disasters but but the investment that's
required to to mitigate those disasters
and Liam can you talk about sort of the
real life examples that we're seeing
right now I mean we just mentioned
hurricane Ida in Louisiana also
wildfires in California I mean what is
it that that users there are paying and
sort of
um how do you analyze the situation
based on what we're seeing right now
so one way I look at it is to see how
much people are paying out of the
disposable income for their utility
bills uh one of the uh quirks of
Louisiana is that actually that their
power costs are among the lowest in the
nation per Mega per kilowatt hour uh the
problem being that um because of all
that air conditioning they use a lot of
kilowatt hours so actually
louisianans are among the top 15 states
in the country in terms of how much
they're paying out of their income for
utility bills it's about three and a
half percent right now
we're also seeing this in California
where actually although rates are higher
people use less electricity and they
tend to earn more so right now it might
not seem like a problem the problem is
though is that you have vast differences
of income in a state like California not
everyone lives in Silicon Valley and so
the burden is actually already pretty
heavy on on poorer communities and we're
starting to see The Strain already after
the wildfires of a few years ago the
state felt compelled to set up an
insurance fund because one of its
largest utilities PG e went bankrupt
Under The Strain we've also seen cities
like San Francisco threatened to leave
PG E's grid because they think they'd be
better off on their own rather than
bearing the cost of you know burying
power lines out near the Sierra Nevada
so Liam what does this all mean what's
the direction of travel I'm glad you
brought up the wildfires as well because
of the cost it's putting on Californians
and so what can they expect next as
these fires escalate and that tension
you describe between the more wealthy
cities and more wealthy populations and
the the populations that need the help a
little more continue to diverge well I
think the way to think about this is
pressure on the utility model you know
if you think about it you know the whole
point of a utility is to share these
sometimes very uneven costs of getting
us all on the grid for a universal
service and you know by and large uh we
we don't mind shouldering those costs in
a in an equalized way the question I
think that's being brought up by events
like California's wildfires like Texas
is freeze like Louisiana's hurricanes is
can that continue as we internalize
these bigger costs and as people begin
to wonder well if someone chooses to
live in a place where those risks are
higher
do people who don't live there want to
bear the cost of that up to this point
we we have borne that cost the question
is whether that will continue Liam do
people have have a choice I mean who
who's going to be the one having these
arguments that you mentioned or these um
you know discussions about the cost
benefit analysis is it is it going to be
companies like PG e is it going to be
residents who live in these cities our
local officials I'm curious sort of what
you think how you think this plays out
well it's a question that's already
being asked and it should be stress a
lot of people don't have a choice as to
where they're living I mean you only
have to look at the cost of housing in
in California to know that not everyone
is choosing to live in these more remote
places uh just purely out of choice but
the the conversation is already
happening you know when I was reporting
on the wildfires in California a few
years ago the the phrase climate change
gentrification had already entered the
conversation and what that referred to
was the need for people who say choose
to live in a riskier area to suddenly
have to for example self-insure because
insurance companies would no longer
cover them for Wildfire risk and you can
certainly imagine that happening in
other places where you know cities or
towns have been built on on marginal
ground that that needs to be engineered
in some way to to cope with the risk of
floods or high winds or wildfires well
it begs the question right because it's
not the only risk that is uh privatized
right in terms of self-insuring you see
wealthier individuals paying for private
firefighters for example to keep their
possession safer in these environments
at the end of the day Liam at what point
are taxpayers brought in to bear the
cost of the damages these coastal cities
are facing well taxpayers are already
brought in
um you know we talked about the the
Wildfire Insurance Fund in California
there's the uh the 14 and a half billion
or so I think I've got that figure right
that was spent Shoring up the the levees
and flood defenses for New Orleans now
that in itself is an interesting
question you know people might say well
why does the federal government pick up
that tab well we all rely on the
Mississippi
uh functioning properly so it is a
legitimate Federal investment but these
questions are going to multiply uh in
coastal areas in uh Wildlife Urban
interface areas the question of who
picks up the tab to keep those places
viable is is going to come back to the
foreign
really fascinating column Liam thank you
so much for joining us this morning that
is Liam Denning he is a Bloomberg
opinion columnist thank you for your
time all right up next the Cannabis
industry has been legalized in a number
of countries so our psychedelics next
we're talking to the CEO of Silo Simon
about the future of the industry in two
minutes we'll be back this is quick take
charge
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
pharmaceutical is the first South
African company to win the right to grow
process and package cannabis products
and now it's considering an IPO so
joining us now is psilocybin CEO and
president Gabrielle tharone joining us
live Gabriel thanks so much for being
here so how significant is a full
cannabis license to your business
especially considering the fact that you
are looking at an IPO on the horizon
well good morning Jennifer so maybe to
start off with I think firstly we need
to understand what these two licenses
mean so in South Africa you get two
different licenses the one would be a
cultivation license and you must think
of it like an export license for bulk
flower and that's basically your raw
material of cannabis
the the second license that we now
obtained is a manufacturing license and
they call it a GMP license so that now
enables us to not only export bulk but
we can now go from a B2B Model A
business to business model down to a
business to Consumer model so we're now
allowed to create a brand that we can
take to to end user and I think that is
the biggest significance of having both
these licenses so it opens up the global
playing field for us to now build a
brand
and so let's talk about uh these
licenses as we mentioned uh you are
obviously work in the Cannabis space but
also uh sealocybin you have your site
set on that talk to us about why that's
next and sort of what you think uh the
industry looks like and the
opportunities look like for psilocybin
in the near future
the assignment is definitely going to be
much bigger than cannabis I think
cannabis cannabis has paved the way for
psilocybin to to enter into the global
playing field it is going to take I
think quicker for psilocybin to to to
move through all the various legislative
processes even if you look at cannabis
cannabis is still struggling to to get
through all the legislative issues if I
can call it that so globally it's still
very difficult to get into all the
various markets but I think from a
psilocybin point of view it is going to
be the future it is going to be massive
you you already know that there's
companies that that has gone public on
the the NASDAQ so in terms of research
psilocybin is going to be massive so
what us as a company we've already
applied for a research permit
um from our regulator and we're setting
our sights on doing a research in that
field and then hopefully apply for
commercial license to service the global
community and what makes you so so
cannabis has received Global attention
so if you ask me that a week ago I would
have probably
gave you a thumbs up answer if I with
that answer today the amount of people
that reached out to us in the last week
since Bloomberg broke the story
I I cannot tell you the how people are
getting excited how the community is
pulling together and asking us how they
can invest as the one question the other
question is how they can assist us to to
speed up our marketing it's been
phenomenal I think the support globally
to be honest with you I think what
covet's done to to the global Community
it's forced everybody to look inward
into their own health I think from a
psychedelic point of view and and the
amount of depression has risen and
people are turning to other forms of of
medicines if I can call it that and and
psychedelics has been playing a massive
role I I had a discussion with a doctor
yesterday and he said to me if it wasn't
for microdosing on psilocybin he would
have lost his mind in this past through
a year with covet and he said it's
really pulled him through and he wants
to do more research and he wants he
wants to continue research on on
psychedelics and do you see investors
having that same enthusiasm uh you know
the fact that you're planning on ipoing
and expanding across the world I mean
what do you think investors need to know
about this
so from an investor point of view we've
been bombarded
um our website literally exploded from
people who want to get involved on an
investor level and not just in South
Africa it's been Global
um as far as Cambodia America literally
everywhere so the I think the excitement
is there I think investors understand
that there's a new way of psychedelics
and all of these plant-based medicines
coming
the the Biotech Industry is going to be
much bigger than the I.T industry
um that's what some of the researchers
are saying so I think investors are
ready to to get into something different
um and plants based medicines
where do you see some of the challenges
though I mean you mentioned how um you
know it's different depending on the
country that you're speaking about but
you're planning on signing deals in you
know Australia Brazil the UK what sort
of challenges lie ahead in in the short
term for you as you continue to convince
people that that this is the future
so if you talk cannabis the the biggest
challenge basically is getting past all
the regulatory uh challenges so one
being for example we're talking about a
plant that gets extracted into a
medicine and cannabis is one of the only
plants where the plant needs to be grown
almost at a pharmaceutical level for it
to to get through the process to go into
a further processing of Medicine
if you look at anything else where a
plant is used the plant itself doesn't
need to be compliant to a GMP a good
manufacturing practices
standard whereas cannabis is and it's
been extremely difficult to get organic
product across borders
um where it's it's
allowed according to legislation so
you're looking at a a schedule or in
South Africa they call it a schedule six
narcotic I believe in America it's a
schedule one
narcotic that you want to try and move
across borders and it it is treated so
difficult the process is so difficult to
get it across and it takes very very
long to move product so that is the
biggest challenges
um but in terms of the markets the
markets are there but the challenges is
moving the product and and yeah that's
been the hardest to date
really interesting stuff especially
about the co7 Gabriel their own
Simon CEO and president thanks so much
for staying up and talking to us about
the company all right we'll be back in
two minutes this is quick take charge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now here are a few stories we don't
want you to miss this morning inflation
in the Euro area has jumped to its
highest level in a decade consumer
Prices rose this month at a rate of 3
percent that was higher than the
predictions of all 37 economists in a
Bloomberg survey that's testing
policymakers insistence that a
post-crisis spike in cost pressures
should prove to be temporary also health
insurance coverage in the U.S improved
last year according to the CDC more than
90 percent of Americans are on a plan
the number of uninsured has fallen to
31.6 million down slightly from 2019
among adults 18 to 64 almost 14 percent
were uninsured and finally apple is
looking to outer space for an iPhone
upgrade yes you did hear that right
Bloomberg has learned the company will
add satellite features to iPhones for
emergencies that will allow users to
send text messages to First Responders
and Report crashes in areas without
cellular coverage the saddle light
features are unlikely to be ready until
next year pretty Spacey stuff all right
you can learn more about these stories
and stay up to date on the day's news at
bloomberg.com now coming up today is the
final day of the summer transfer window
for European soccer leagues and it's
already been a historic transfer season
we're going to discuss in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so today is the last day of the summer
transfer window across the major
European football leagues leaving clubs
scrambling to seal some final deals
before tonight's deadline to buy and
sell players it's already been a major
transfer season with Premier League
clubs spending almost a billion pounds
so far but the main attraction has been
the moves from the world's two biggest
stars Lionel Messi and Cristiano Ronaldo
so here now to break it down for us is
Joe Easton he is a UK markets reporter
for Bloomberg joining us from London Joe
thanks so much for being here so let's
talk about the financial impact of Messi
and Ronaldo's transfers I mean how
significant was it for these clubs
well it should be pretty significant and
particularly from man united given that
he's an ex-player coming back and we've
seen a really good um reception to that
across the fan base and you should get
um some impact potentially coming
through maybe even on sponsorships but
we really need to see um the on pitch
um impact of these signings it's quite
interesting if you look at the revenues
of of the big clubs at the moment it's
really the ones that have performed on
the pitch and that have boosted their
revenues most
um Liverpool is a good example a club
that doesn't spend that much money
comparatively compared to man united Man
City parachute German but they managed
to get their revenues up really high and
that's really a reflection of how
important it is not only to get the big
name players but also for them to
perform and you get the bigger
broadcasting rights uh the biggest
sponsorships as I mentioned and get your
financial impact of those players up
it's not just about bringing those big
names in unfortunately right and I mean
we're looking at Juventus right there
um down right now
um but how significant is it for a team
like Juventus because this also opens up
the door for them to potentially bring
in other players right
yeah well the big thing with Ronaldo was
his wages and was so High um estimated
somewhere between 20 and 25 million
euros
um a year which is quite a lot of money
just
um in terms of one player and also the
fact that with Ronaldo on such high
wages
um other players and their agents were
able to demand higher as well so this
will be not only are they getting a
small fee from Manchester United
reported to be about 15 million euros
they'll also remove him from their wages
and that will help them
um in spending more money on new players
and potentially
um improving on the pitch because the
the commercial impact of Ronaldo after
three years it had started to decline
naturally the excitement had sort of
worn off so it's kind of a good move for
them to get him off their wages really
and Joe when we talk about um you know
of course today is the the deadline for
the transfer window I mean how has the
pandemic affected these clubs we knew we
know they took a financial it but you
know how has what we saw from the
pandemic affected what they're able to
do during this transfer window
so it's been really noticeable
um among the lower levels of the clubs
so particularly in the UK where you have
some really dominant teams as I
mentioned like man city which really
weren't that impacted by um the pandemic
because although they lost that ticket
sales income they have very wealthy
owners they also get Champions League
income the biggest competition in terms
of Club football in Europe but the lower
teams were so dependent on their tickets
sales revenue that they've really had to
cut back on players so we've seen
massive um declines in the quantity and
size of transfers at the mid and lower
levels across the UK in England and also
across the big European leagues as well
it's really been about the big teams
consolidating their power Manchester
City man united PSG those teams that
I've mentioned they've really weathered
the storm haven't been too impacted and
really have actually come out of the
pandemic in probably a strong position
and than they were and a few years ago
which is quite an interesting Dynamic
finally Joe just in the last 30 seconds
or so we we heard about the deal that
Amazon struck to air some of the French
league uh games is this significant for
Amazon is this significant for the
French league uh how do you read it
I think it's probably a bit of a trial
um for Amazon so they're actually coming
in they're undercutting the predecessor
in terms of the subscription fee they
probably see it as a test model how big
can we make this league among Amazon and
subscribers and Amazon users that are
willing to pay that extra money and then
later you might see them go into other
countries where they previously only
bought specific matches they've had you
know packages of around 10 games that
they would sell onto Amazon Prime
members in the Premier League rather
than doing a full season so it'll be
quite an interesting project but it
seems like something that they're
looking to try out and see where they go
in terms of other countries later on
definitely really interesting stuff Joe
Easton UK stocks reporter for Bloomberg
for us in London thank you so much for
your time and finally we're ending the
hour with some good news on this Tuesday
defending Champion Naomi Osaka got her
U.S open campaign up and running
smoothly with a win over Marie buscaba
in Street sets last night she's said it
feels kind of crazy to play in front of
everyone again she said that on court
afterwards Naomi Osaka went on to say
last year when we didn't have a crowd it
felt quite lonely for me the energy here
is unmatched Osaka is a four-time grand
slam Champion she abruptly withdrew from
the French Open and Wimbledon creating
awareness about the mental health
challenges athletes are facing worldwide
great stuff all right that'll do it for
quick take this hour but there's more
quick taken coming up in just a minute
I'm Jennifer zapasaja thanks for
watching
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to Bloomberg
quick take where we explore how the
day's top news is changing the future of
business coming up what's next for
Afghanistan the country is without a
government and faces headwinds to gain
Global recognition the UN has drawn up a
list of goals for the region to avoid it
becoming a safe haven of terrorism but
notably China and Russia abstained from
the vote we're going to discuss what
interests Moscow and Beijing have in the
Middle East and what will happen to the
thousands of unsettled refugees then
warming oceans fueled Ida before it made
landfall as a category for Hurricane but
how many more Gulf storms can cities
like New Orleans actually handle and
what about taxpayers the question of
which cities and regions will be able to
adapt to new extreme weather is part of
the hard math of climate change for our
Focus today we'll explore ways global
warming is altering the cost-benefit
analysis for infrastructure and finally
today is the last day of August and also
the last day for soccer clubs to trade
players from Messi to Ronaldo it's been
a summer of huge deals we're going to
analyze the billions of dollars at stake
as players make moves I'm Jennifer
zabassanja and this is quick take charge
let's get going
we start here the war in Afghanistan is
officially over Major General Chris
Donahue was the last U.S service member
to leave the country as you can see in
that picture there and step aboard a
C-17 cargo plane in the early hours of
August 31st local time as the U.S has
left a new Force has taken control of
Hamid Karzai airport in Kabul the
Taliban Taliban special forces units
stormed the airport and celebrated the
U.S withdrawal here you can see them
right there decked out in American
military outfits and weaponry speaking
to the media a Taliban spokesman said
that quote America was defeated and
Afghanistan is now a quote free and
Sovereign Nation overall a hundred and
twenty three thousand people were
evacuated to the U.S and fifteen
thousand to the UK also tens of
thousands of refugees fled to other
countries across the globe and today
August 31st the final U.S flight as part
of the evacuation effort departed Kabul
Airport heralding an end to the 20-year
Coalition conflict the war has cost
trillions in dollars and almost a
quarter of a million of lives that have
been lost the world now turns its
attention to the Taliban hoping that the
social and developmental gains made in
the past 20 years are not erased
overnight last night also the U.N
security Council met to adopt a
resolution requiring the Taliban to do a
few things one of them being Safeguard
gains for women and children's rights
also ensure the country doesn't become a
safe haven for terrorists and also allow
foreign humanitarian organizations to
care out work unimpeded and as we
mentioned in the intro China and Russia
abstain from the vote on this resolution
so a lot to get to this morning and with
us to discuss is Bloomberg opinions
Bobby Ghosh in London as well as eltaf
najavizada who has handled Bloomberg's
Afghanistan coverage extensively and he
is joining us from New Delhi Alto let's
just start with you um what exactly does
the Taliban want now from America now
that we have officially left the country
they are seeking International
recognition from International Community
especially from the United Nations and
that's why they are they have sought
assistance of the United States to help
them seek International recognition
that's one thing and the second thing is
the talibans
the facing uh worst economy situation in
the country especially the financial
issue and they want money to run the
government that's accounting challenges
for the for the Taliban because the U.S
fed they have cut off
9.5 billion dollars in reserves for
Afghanistan's Central Bank and that's
why the Taliban want them to to be
released to the Taliban governments in
the future so that's the reason that
they want International recognitions
they want to see good relationship with
the United States with all the countries
around the world even with the with the
close neighbors with the immediate
neighbors China Pakistan around those
countries
Bobby I also want to get your take on
this we we mentioned a few things that
we heard the Taliban spokesman said also
we heard them say at the airport the
Islamic Emirate once a good and
diplomatic relationship with the
Americans I wonder what you make of sort
of what we heard from the Taliban as the
Americans uh were finally exiting the
country
well I'm I'm much more skeptical I'm I'd
like to see them act rather than speak
the actions so far have been cautious in
parts of the country that they have been
running for several years now their
behavior has not been very conciliatory
they've been very much Taliban 1.0
they're promising upon arrival in Kabul
that there will be a different kind of
Taliban but I am very skeptical about
that I think they certainly want
International recognition but they want
it on their terms they wanted
International recognition the last time
around two when they had power but they
refused to do the things that the
International Community required them to
do this time around the International
Community once again is making very
clear what the terms are for recognition
we'll see if the Taliban first and
foremost agree to those terms and then
we'll have to monitor very carefully to
make sure that they keep up their end of
the bargain they do have a history of
giving their word and then taking it
back
and but we did hear jensaki at the White
House say that the U.S has leveraged to
hold the Taliban accountable for for
what they believe do you believe that
that the international Powers
um do have some leverage as eltaf
mentioned about
um some of the money that the Taliban
wants Bobby I'm curious do you think
International powers do have leverage to
hold the Taliban accountable
well they have some they have some
limited powers it it all boils down to
whether or not the Taliban how badly the
Taliban wants that money and whether or
not they're willing to make those
compromises it is not an uh entirely
unlikely that the Taliban might just
decide at the end of the day that they
are not willing to make those
concessions and and decide that they
will return Afghanistan to where it was
20 years ago when they were still
running the country at that time they
were essentially cut out from the
International Community it's a more
complex country now it's a more complex
economy now hopefully the Taliban
realizes that but we can't really be
sure the the understanding of
international finances not very
particularly sophisticated they have
announced a central bank governor who
has very little actual experience
um in finance and and seems mainly to
have been in charge of extortion rackets
in parts of the country where they were
in charge this does not fill me with
with a great deal of optimism them and I
think the other thing to look out for is
what ordinary Afghans are saying and
doing the fact that so many people
particularly the kinds of people that
the Taliban would have needed to run
their country to run their economy so
many of those people are fleeing or want
to flee suggest to me that they don't
trust the Taliban if they don't then I
can't see why the International
Community should and eltaf just speaking
of the ordinary afghanis who are there
what have you heard about daily life now
that the Americans have exited for the
most part I mean has has it changed at
all
well the normalcy
is a
getting back to Kabul City actually
because after the withdrawal of the
American forces there has not been any
any attacks any suicide bombing at a
couple uh a Kabul City and people and
restaurants are opening shops are open
reopening uh economy is slowly opening
in Kabul City well people are not
worried now about these security
situations they are worried about their
economic situation because the economy
is getting its worst [ __ ] in Afghanistan
the prices are increasing that you know
the medicines prices are increasing the
foods are increasing because the Imports
have been halted for a while by the
Taliban at the Customs for in
Afghanistan causing prices to go higher
so that's that's the issue daunting
issue you there the people are facing to
I have not seen the Afghan people in
Kabul that they have celebrated the
withdrawal of the American forces those
some there are some Afghans that who are
still fearful of their life of their
future because of the talibans Takeover
of the country and those who are fearful
or the previous government officials are
the Civil Rights activates or the
journalists because those peoples were
told by the Taliban to uh to to come for
kind of for some kind of Investigations
they were their their houses their homes
were not by the Taliban to search them
to grab them you know to take them for
into their Castries for some sort of
Investigation so that that has created
Fierce among those kind of people but
there are some other people that I had
spoken to they are not worried of the
Taliban because they have not seen uh
any uh any any good thing in the
previous government if if they compare
the previous government with the current
government of the Taliban so those
peoples are kind of impartial I mean see
that they are they're careless people
what they want is just job good economy
in the country and that's it
and we we also heard I mean we mentioned
that China and Russia abstain from that
U.N um resolution but we did hear China
say that they're hoping the
International Community actually helps
with some of those things that you
mentioned eltaf what is it that China
and Russia are potentially seeing uh in
in potentially a relationship that they
could have with Afghanistan I want to
get your taken then Bobby I'd like to
ask you as well
uh I think uh China is is trying to
expand its influence in Afghanistan
after the U.S left the country so that
vacuum the power vacuum has been left
now in Afghanistan and some someone from
outside the country is trying to fill in
that vacuum that power vacuum I mean
also we could say that influence in the
country Afghanistan has Rich mineral
resources does something could benefit
China and China has already got uh
several contracts of mineral resources
from the previous governments and they
try to expand you know its business
environment its business opportunities
in Afghanistan as well through the
cultural government it's not only the
Taliban the Afghanistan's mineral
resources there are other Regional uh
projects in billions of dollars like the
Taki dos pipeline also going through
Afghanistan also that that the China's
build and Road initiative in order to
influence expand its influence across
the region Russia Russia well of course
Russia didn't want to see American
forces station or based in Afghanistan
for the past 20 years for the past two
decades they have always opposed their
presence in Afghanistan and we have had
reports saying that Russia were also
helping funding entitlement providing
weapons at Taliban to to fight against
American forces in order to push them
out of Afghanistan finally and that
happened
yesterday all the American forces left
the country and Russia China they have
had some some kind of positive good
relationship with the Taliban in the
past two decades and now they're trying
to build on of that in order to expand
its influence across the country through
uh friendship with the Taliban which was
being called a terrorist group now they
are being called by Russians and Chinese
people as reasonable people to deal with
and Bobby is that how you read it as
well I mean I think it's interesting
that China and Russia abstain from this
resolution curious to get your take
well they clearly want to be in the
taliban's good books they don't want to
be seen as putting too much pressure on
the Taliban by abstaining they can have
their cake and eat it too they did not
veto the resolution which they could
have done so by abstaining they are
basically nodding to the International
Community and winking at the Taliban I
think altaf is exactly right both Russia
and China do not want a vacuum in
Afghanistan their interests in the
country are primarily to do with
security and geopolitics they don't want
Afghanistan to become another once again
a hotbed of terrorist activities because
some of those terrorist activities would
be directed at Russia and China just as
much as it is directed to the West the
Chinese do have an interest in in Afghan
mineral resources but I personally am
skeptical about just how far they will
go to get those resources because the
Investments required to get those
minerals out of the ground and then
transport them out of the country in a
country that has so little
infrastructure will be huge amounts of
money we're talking about tens uh of
billions of dollars that's a very high
risk for Chinese companies to take and
they tend not to want to take those
kinds of risks they may have a bigger
appetite for for risk-taking than
Western companies or Western Banks
but at the same time they they're
they're not so reckless as to barge into
a country with uncertain political
future uncertain security environment as
Alda pointed out they did have some
investments in China before with the
previous government they had a they had
a 30-year concession on a very large
copper mine not far from Kabul but they
couldn't make that project work they
couldn't make it work despite the
presence of international forces
guaranteeing security despite having a
deal with the Taliban in which the
darbhan promised they wouldn't attack
that mine if China couldn't make it work
then I think we should be skeptical
about whether it can sort of invest the
tens of billions of dollars that
Afghanistan will need going into the
future and Bobby just in the last minute
or so we're going to hear from President
Biden in a few hours do you see this
potentially making a state putting a
stain on his legacy at all or do do you
think it will be a combination of the
former presidents who sort of started
this whole process and and that the
changes made during the different of
presidents I'm curious sort of what you
think that will be written in the
history books now that the 20-year War
has officially ended
well the war hasn't really ended the
United States might the the White House
might want us to think it has if our
enemies haven't stopped fighting it
hasn't ended uh has the U.S now wants to
fight a different kind of war the Over
the Horizon kind of war from a distance
from a safe distance using drones
an aircraft but whether that will work
we'll have to see it didn't work in the
past when we tried to get Al Qaeda out
of uh Afghanistan without sending in
ground troops I'm skeptical that it will
work going into the future whether or
not it stains Biden's Legacy I suppose
will depend to a substantial degree
about what happens in Afghanistan now
that the United States has left and
whether there is any blowback whether
whether terrorist groups like the
Islamic States like Al Qaeda are able to
re-establish themselves there and then
begin to attack the west and attack the
United States that will be that will
decide whether or not it'll stain
Biden's Legacy but it's important to
remember that unlike let's say in
Vietnam uh when the when the United
States left the country
this is a very different news
environment and very different
information environment this is taking
place live on Twitter people are seeing
every step of the American withdrawal
and they're seeing every step of how the
Taliban reacts afterwards this is rather
different from one still picture of a
helicopter taking off from the roof of
the embassy in Saigon this is this is a
much more powerful series of image
images not even and I'm not even getting
into the disinformation campaign that
America's enemies will use in order to
remind people over and over again about
the humiliation in Afghanistan so yeah I
think this will live longer in memory
than the Biden Administration is
counting on absolutely we're going to
leave it there Bloomberg opinions Bobby
gosh in London as always for us thank
you so much and also Bloomberg News is
eltaf Naja visada in New Delhi thank you
both for starting us off this morning
all right coming up we're diving into
today's focus of the day extreme weather
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
tell us the story today's number is
three dollars and 18 cents the national
average price for regular unleaded gas
is expected to rise to three dollars and
eighteen cents a gallon this weekend
hurricane Ida is probably making this
Labor Day the most expensive for U.S
drivers since 2014. the storm left parts
of the golf course the Gulf Coast oil
refining Hub in the dark and for a day
it halted flows on the main pipeline
that ships the gasoline made there to
East Coast markets more than 2 million
people in Ida's path still don't have
power it could take weeks to restore
meanwhile the system of levees
floodgates and pumps installed after
Hurricane Katrina devastated the city in
2005 passed their biggest test yet and
chanali basic is here joining me now for
our quick take focus of the day on
Extreme Weather Channel hurricane Ida is
wiping out power bringing intense rain
and people in its path are really being
affected and really the effects of the
storm are still remain to be seen yeah
and on top of Ida we have tens of
thousands of people who are being
evacuated from their homes in different
regions in California we talk about the
caldorf fire but there's actually been
more than 6 000 incidents of fire this
year alone 600
000 Acres almost burned a lot of people
to worry about and a lot of structures
that may not make it through so joining
us now to dive deeper into this extreme
weather is Bloomberg's climate reporter
Eric Roston thank you for joining us
from a science perspective how did we
get to this place of what scientists are
calling rapid intensification when it
comes to Ida in particular
the short answer is greenhouse gas
pollution but there's a chain of
causality that uh that comes between our
spoke stacks and tailpipes to Rapid
intensification of hurricanes the key
factor in uh immediate sense is warm
water uh all of the heat we have been
trapping in the Earth has turned the
oceans warmer and that is gasoline for
hurricanes and we've seen it
increasingly over the last few years we
have hurricanes that that are not
hurricanes like uh Ida started as a as a
tropical depression in the middle of
last week and within uh less time than
it takes a major city to evacuate went
from tropical depression to almost a
category 5 hurricane so this is
something that was projected to happen
more with climate change uh and
unfortunately it may be a part of the
hurricane system in the gulf and the uh
the Atlantic Ocean as we go forward and
uh Eric I mean our Focus today is
extreme weather there's so many
different weather events that we've seen
happen over the past month um chaneli
mentioned a few of those you have an
article out today that that is titled
killer heat forces cities to adapt now
or suffer and you really get into some
of the challenges that cities are facing
right now can you just walk us through
this pivotal Point uh that a lot of
cities are are at right now when it
comes to climate change
sure thank you uh this is an article
that is it's actually a sequel to a
feature we did last summer that looks at
economic analysis of heat and income
growth sort of over the course of the
next few decades it was done by a
research group called climate impact lab
and what they do is they look at how
income change and climate change
together create conditions where some
cities will be able to protect
themselves because they can they can
afford to they have a sufficient income
growth they can buy adaptation uh and
other cities will not be able to and
they'll suffer unfortunately as
temperatures rise uh it's a it's very
detailed uh very novel analysis with
implications for what cities can and
should do to protect themselves Eric can
you give us a sense of how this is
playing out across the world examples of
cities that might be suffering more
because they don't have the money to
protect themselves and on top of that is
it just the cities that can't protect
themselves or is this really about lower
income individuals not being able to
protect themselves against climate
change
it's a really important question because
fundamental to the analysis is that
income and adaptation save lives and
that is true globally uh cities than in
more developed richer countries will uh
have fewer heat deaths as temperatures
rise and consequently developing uh
cities in developing countries will will
suffer more and see more heat deaths
within cities you see the same Dynamic
on a smaller scale which is vulnerable
populations which is uh underserved
communities and older people will
disproportionately feel the heat the
good news is that cities are
increasingly aware of this Seattle which
until mid-june had been thought of as a
temperate Pacific coast city is now in
the throes of of heat planning to try to
protect their vulnerable populations
from when extreme heat comes again
um there's obviously also true of
everyone else in the region Vancouver uh
Portland and and all the towns between
them
but we're uh I I think the late June
heat wave in the U.S and Canada uh
similar events around the world in
Northern Africa southern Europe Tokyo
and Northern Japan
um everyone is waking up to the threats
and the very practical uh in many cases
affordable steps they can take to
protect their people and uh can you talk
can you walk us through a little bit of
that Eric I mean what sort of local
level policy could we we see cities take
in the near future to to prevent some of
the future tragedies that we could see
there's really a gamut and in our
reporting one of the uh more useful and
and interesting documents uh we turned
up was a 2017
almost catalog of things cities can do
to protect themselves from uh from heat
and these run the gamut from very
inexpensive
things that everyone can do which are
taking advantage of community
communication networks and making sure
that uh Community groups know when heat
is coming know what to tell uh people
who live in their Community how to
protect themselves
I'm not sending alerts uh making sure
emergency services are trained and
funded to take care of people uh those
are on the Emergency Management end but
there's also uh the way we build cities
in some cases uh can protect us from
heat when it comes there's a well-known
uh phenomenon called the urban heat
island effect which is about the
concrete and glass and buildings cities
kind of soak in Sun uh sun solar energy
and it makes them hotter than rural
areas around them well many cities
around the world are learning how by
planting trees by setting up ponds by
having white roofs or green roofs
they can actually mitigate some of that
heat and prevent heat illness and heat
related mortality right I saw you
mention Maricopa County and they're
planting trees I grew up there so so
that really stuck out to me Eric rossen
we have to leave it there though he is a
climate reporter for Bloomberg news
thank you so much for your time all
right coming up what are these extreme
weather events doing to the cost-benefit
analysis of infrastructure like power
grids we'll discuss in two minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so this is the difference between
[Music]
the latest report from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change made it clear that extreme
weather events left unchecked will
become more frequent and more intense
those extreme events wreak havoc on
power grids and so what does that mean
for electricity users moving forward the
cost is bound to be shared by
governments and individuals so here now
is Bloomberg opinion columnist Liam
Denning thank you for being here Liam
how is climate change altering the
cost-benefit analysis of power grids
well it's forcing us to internalize
costs that in the past we might have
ignored to some degree you know as long
as there have been power networks there
have been natural disasters that cause
damage to them and the way that's
usually been dealt with is that uh you
know the cost of cleaning up and
repairing things gets put into our
utility bills the the difference with
climate change is uh what we think of as
extreme weather is becoming more
commonplace and more intense and so the
question we face is can can the utility
model whereby we share all these costs
really cope with the higher costs we're
going to face not just from future
disasters but but the investment that's
required to to mitigate those disasters
and Liam can you talk about sort of the
real life examples that we're seeing
right now I mean we just mentioned
hurricane Ida in Louisiana also
wildfires in California I mean what is
it that that users there are paying and
sort of
um how do you analyze the situation
based on what we're seeing right now
so one way I look at it is to see how
much people are paying out of the
disposable income for their utility
bills uh one of the uh quirks of
Louisiana is that actually that their
power costs are among the lowest in the
nation per Mega per kilowatt hour uh the
problem being that
um because of all that air conditioning
they use a lot of kilowatt hours so
actually
louisianans are among the top 15 states
in the country in terms of how much
they're paying out of their income for
utility bills it's about three and a
half percent right now
we're also seeing this in California
where actually although rates are higher
people use less electricity and they
tend to earn more so right now it might
not seem like a problem the problem is
though is that you have vast differences
of income in a state like California not
everyone lives in Silicon Valley and so
the burden is actually already pretty
heavy on on poorer communities and we're
starting to see The Strain already after
the wildfires of a few years ago the
state felt compelled to set up an
insurance fund because one of its
largest utilities PG e went bankrupt
Under The Strain we've also seen cities
like San Francisco threatened to leave
PG E's grid because they think they'd be
better off on their own rather than
bearing the cost of you know burying
power lines out near the Sierra Nevada
so Liam what does the psalm mean what's
the direction of travel I'm glad you
brought up the wildfires as well because
of the cost it's putting on Californians
and so what can they expect next as
these fires escalate and that tension
you describe between the more wealthy
cities and more wealthy populations and
the the populations that need the help a
little more continue to diverge well I
think the way to think about this is
pressure on the utility model you know
if you think about it the whole point of
a utility is to share these sometimes
very uneven costs of getting us all on
the grid for a universal service and you
know by and large we we don't mind
shouldering those costs in a in an in an
equalized way the question I think
that's being brought up by events like
California's wildfires like Texas is
freeze like Louisiana's hurricanes is
can that continue as we internalize
these bigger costs and as people begin
to wonder well if someone chooses to
live in a place where those risks are
higher
do people who don't live there want to
bear the cost of that up to this point
we we have borne that cost the question
is whether that will continue Liam do
people have have a choice I mean who
who's going to be the one having these
arguments that you mentioned or these um
you know discussions about the cost
benefit analysis is it is it going to be
companies like PG e is a going to be
residents who live in these cities our
local officials I'm curious sort of what
you think how you think this plays out
well it's a question that's already
being asked and it should be stress a
lot of people don't have a choice as to
where they're living I mean you only
have to look at the cost of housing in
in California to know that not everyone
is choosing to live in these more remote
places uh just purely out of choice but
the the conversation is already
happening you know when I was reporting
on the wildfires in California a few
years ago the the phrase climate change
gentrification had already entered the
conversation and what that referred to
was the need for people who say choose
to live in a riskier area to suddenly
have to for example self-insure because
insurance companies would no longer
cover them for Wildfire risk and you can
certainly imagine that happening in
other places where you know cities or
towns have been built on on marginal
ground that that needs to be engineered
in some way to to cope with the risk of
floods or high winds or wildfires well
it begs the question right because it's
not the only risk that is uh privatized
right in terms of self-insuring you see
wealthier individuals paying for private
Fighters for example to keep their
possession safer in these environments
at the end of the day Liam at what point
are taxpayers brought in to bear the
cost of the damages these coastal cities
are facing well taxpayers are already
brought in
um you know we talked about the the
Wildfire Insurance Fund in California
there's the uh the 14 and a half billion
or so I think I've got that figure right
that was spent Shoring up the the levees
and flood defenses for New Orleans now
that in itself is an interesting
question you know people might say well
why does the federal government pick up
that tab well we all rely on the
Mississippi
uh functioning properly so it is a
legitimate Federal investment but these
questions are going to multiply uh in
coastal areas in uh Wildlife Urban
interface areas the question of who
picks up the tab to keep those places
viable is is going to come back to the
fore
really fascinating column Liam thank you
so much for joining us this morning that
is Liam Denning he is a Bloomberg
opinion columnist thank you for your
time all right up next the Cannabis
industry has been legalized in a number
of countries so our psychedelics next
we're talking to the CEO of Silo Simon
about the future of the industry in two
minutes we'll be back this is quick take
charge
foreign
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
psilocybin pharmaceutical is the first
South African company to win the right
to grow process and package cannabis
products and now it's considering an IPO
so joining us now is Silas I've been CEO
and president Gabriel Throne joining us
live Gabriel thanks so much for being
here so how significant is a full
cannabis license to your business
especially considering the fact that you
are looking at an IPO on the horizon
well good morning Jennifer so maybe to
start off with I think firstly we need
to understand what these two licenses
mean so in South Africa you get two
different licenses the one would be a
cultivation license and you must think
of it like an export license for bulk
flower and that's basically your raw
material of cannabis
the the second license that we now
obtained is a manufacturing license and
they call it a GMP license so that now
enables us to not only export bulk but
we can now go from a B2B Model A
business to business model down to a
business to Consumer model so we're now
allowed to create a brand that we can
take to to end user and I think that is
the biggest significance of having both
these licenses so it opens up the global
playing field for us to now build a
brand
and so let's talk about uh these
licenses as we mentioned uh you are
obviously work in the Cannabis space but
also uh coocybin you have your site set
on that talk to us about why that's next
and sort of what you think uh the
industry looks like and the
opportunities look like for psilocybin
in the near future
the assignment is definitely going to be
much bigger than cannabis I think
cannabis cannabis has paved the way for
psilocybin to to enter into the global
playing field it is going to take I
think quicker for psilocybin to to to
move through all the various legislative
processes even if you look at cannabis
cannabis is still struggling to to get
through all the legislative issues if I
can call it that so globally it's still
very difficult to get into all the
various markets but I think from a
psilocybin point of view it is going to
be the future it is going to be massive
you you already know that there's
companies that that has gone public on
the the NASDAQ so in terms of research
psilocybin is going to be massive so
what us as a company we've already
applied for a research permit
um from our regulator and we're setting
our sites on doing a research in that
field and then hopefully apply for
commercial license to service the global
community and what makes you so
cannabis has received Global attention
so if you ask me that a week ago I would
have probably
gave you a thumbstack answer if I with
that answer today the amount of people
that reached out to us in the last week
since Bloomberg broke the story
I I cannot tell you the how people are
getting excited how the community is
pulling together and asking us how they
can invest as the one question the other
question is how they can assist us to to
speed up our marketing it's been
phenomenal I think the support globally
to be honest with you I think what
kovitz done to to the global Community
it's forced everybody to look inward
into their own health I think from a
psychedelic point of view and and the
amount of depression has risen and
people are turning to other forms of of
medicines if I can call it that and and
psychedelics has been playing a massive
role I I had a discussion with a doctor
yesterday and he said to me if it wasn't
for micro dosing on psilocybin he would
have lost his mind in this past through
a year with covet and he said it's
really pulled him through and he wants
to do more research and he wants he
wants to continue research on on
psychedelics and do you see investors
having that same enthusiasm uh you know
the fact that you're planning on ipoing
and expanding across the world I mean
what do you think investors need to know
about this
so from an investor point of view we've
been bombarded
um our website literally exploded from
people who want to get involved on an
investor level and not just in South
Africa it's been Global
um as far as Cambodia America literally
everywhere so the I think the excitement
is there I think investors understand
that there's a new way of psychedelics
and all of these plant-based medicines
coming
the the Biotech Industry is going to be
much bigger than the I.T industry
um that's what some of the researchers
are saying so I think investors are
ready to to get into something different
um and plants based medicines
where do you see some of the challenges
though I mean you mentioned how um you
know it's different depending on the
country that you're speaking about but
you're planning on signing deals in you
know Australia Brazil the UK what sort
of challenges lie ahead in in the short
term for you as you continue to convince
people that that this is the future
so if you talk cannabis the the biggest
challenge basically is getting past all
the regulatory uh challenges so one
being for example we're talking about a
plant that gets extracted into a
medicine and cannabis is one of the only
plants where the plant needs to be grown
almost at a pharmaceutical level for it
to to get through the process to go into
a further processing of Medicine
if you look at anything else where a
plant is used the plant itself doesn't
need to be compliant to a GMP a good
manufacturing practices
standard whereas cannabis is and it's
been extremely difficult to get organic
product across borders
um where it's it's
allowed according to legislation so
you're looking at a a schedule or in
South Africa they call it a schedule six
narcotic I believe in America it's a
schedule one
narcotic that you want to try and move
across borders and it it is treated so
difficult the process is so difficult to
get it across and it takes very very
long to move product so that is the
biggest challenges
um but in terms of the markets the
markets are there but the challenges is
moving the product and and yeah that's
been the hardest to date
really interesting stuff
about the co7 Gabriel throne
Simon CEO and president thanks so much
for staying up and talking to us about
the company all right we'll be back in
two minutes this is quick take charge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and now here are a few stories we don't
want you to miss this morning inflation
in the Euro area has jumped to its
highest level in a decade consumer
Prices rose this month at a rate of 3
percent that was higher than the
predictions of all 37 economists in a
Bloomberg survey that's testing
policymakers insistence that a
post-crisis spike in cost pressures
should prove to be temporary also health
insurance coverage in the U.S improved
last year according to the CDC more than
90 percent of Americans are on a plan
the number of uninsured has fallen to
31.6 million down slightly from 2019
among adults 18 to 64 almost 14 percent
were uninsured and finally apple is
looking to outer space for an iPhone
upgrade yes you did hear that right
Bloomberg has learned the company will
add satellite features to iPhones for
emergencies that will allow users to
send text messages to First Responders
and Report crashes in areas without
cellular coverage the saddle light
features are unlikely to be ready until
next year pretty Spacey stuff all right
you can learn more about these stories
and stay up to date on the day's news at
bloomberg.com now coming up today is the
final day of the summer transfer window
for European soccer leagues and it's
already been a historic transfer season
we're going to discuss in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial World On Demand
thank you hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so today is the last day of the summer
transfer window across the major
European football leagues leaving clubs
scrambling to seal some final deals
before tonight's deadline to buy and
sell players it's already been a major
transfer season with Premier League
clubs spending almost a billion pounds
so far but the main attraction has been
the moves from the world's two biggest
stars Lionel Messi and Cristiano Ronaldo
so here now to break it down for us is
Joe Easton he is a UK markets reporter
for Bloomberg joining us from London Joe
thanks so much for being here so let's
talk about the financial impact of Messi
and Ronaldo's transfers I mean how
significant was it for these clubs
well it should be pretty significant and
particularly from man united given that
he's an ex-player coming back and we've
seen a really good um reception to that
across the fan base and you should get
um some impact potentially coming
through maybe even on sponsorships but
we really need to see um the on pitch
um impact of these signings it's quite
interesting if you look at the revenues
of of the big clubs at the moment it's
really the ones that have performed on
the pitch and that have boosted their
revenues most
um Liverpool is a good example a club
that doesn't spend that much money
comparatively compared to man united Man
City parachute German but they managed
to get their revenues up really high and
that's really a reflection of how
important it is not only to get the big
name players but also for them to
perform and you get the bigger
broadcasting rights uh the biggest
sponsorships as I mentioned and get your
financial impact of those players up
it's not just about bringing those big
names in unfortunately right and I mean
we're looking at Juventus right there
um down right now
um but how significant is it for a team
like Juventus because this also opens up
the door for them to potentially bring
in other players right
yeah well the big thing with Ronaldo was
his wages and was so High um estimated
somewhere between 20 and 25 million
euros a year which is quite a lot of
money just
um in terms of one player and also the
fact that with Ronaldo on such high
wages
um other players and their agents were
able to demand higher as well so this
will be not only are they getting a
small fee from Manchester United
reported to be about 15 million euros
they'll also remove him from their wages
and that will help them
um in spending more money on new players
and potentially
um improving on the pitch because the
the commercial impact of Ronaldo after
three years it had started to decline
naturally the excitement had sort of
worn off so it's kind of a good move for
them to get him out of their wages
really and Joe when we talk about um you
know of course today is the the deadline
for the transfer window I mean how has
the pandemic affected these clubs we
knew we know they took a financial it
but you know how has what we saw from
the pandemic affected what they're able
to do during this transfer window
so it's been really noticeable
um among the lower levels of the clubs
so particularly in the UK where you have
some really dominant teams as I
mentioned like man city which really
weren't that impacted by um the pandemic
because although they lost that ticket
sales income they have very wealthy
owners they also get Champions League
income the biggest competition in terms
of Club football in Europe but the lower
teams were so dependent on their tickets
sales revenue that they've really had to
cut back on players so we've seen
massive um declines in the quantity and
size of transfers at the mid and lower
levels across the UK in England and also
across the big European leagues as well
it's really been about the big teams
consolidating their power Manchester
City man united PSG those teams that
I've mentioned they've really weathered
the storm haven't been too impacted and
really have actually come out of the
pandemic in probably a strong position
and than they were and a few years ago
which is quite an interesting Dynamic
finally Joe just in the last 30 seconds
or so we we heard about the deal that
Amazon struck to air some of the French
league uh games is this significant for
Amazon is this significant for the
French league uh how do you read it
I think it's probably a bit of a trial
um for Amazon so they're actually coming
in they're undercutting the predecessor
in terms of the subscription fee they
probably see it as a test model how big
can we make this league among Amazon and
subscribers and Amazon users that are
willing to pay that extra money and then
later you might see them go into other
countries where they previously only
bought specific matches they had you
know packages of around 10 games that
they would sell onto Amazon Prime
members in the Premier League rather
than doing a full season so it'll be
quite an interesting project but it
seems like something that they're
looking to try out and see where they go
in terms of other countries later on
definitely really interesting stuff Joe
Easton UK stocks reporter for Bloomberg
for us in London thank you so much for
your time and finally we're ending the
hour with some good news on this Tuesday
defending Champion Naomi Osaka got her
U.S open campaign up and running
smoothly with a win over Marie buscaba
in Street sets last night she's said it
feels kind of crazy to play in front of
everyone again she said that on court
afterwards Naomi Osaka went on to say
last year when we didn't have a crowd it
felt quite lonely for me the energy here
is unmatched Osaka is a four-time grand
slam Champion she abruptly withdrew from
the French Open and Wimbledon creating
awareness about the mental health
challenges athletes are facing worldwide
great stuff all right that'll do it for
a quick take
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning and welcome to Bloomberg
quick take where we explore how the
day's top news is changing the future of
business coming up what's next for
Afghanistan the country is without a
government and faces headwinds to gain
Global recognition the UN has drawn up a
list of goals for the region to avoid it
becoming a safe haven of terrorism but
notably China and Russia abstained from
the vote we're going to discuss what
interests Moscow and Beijing have in the
Middle East and what will happen to the
thousands of unsettled refugees then
warming oceans fueled Ida before it made
landfall as a category for Hurricane but
how many more Gulf storms can cities
like New Orleans actually handle and
what about taxpayers the question of
which cities and regions will be able to
adapt to new extreme weather is part of
the hard math of climate change for our
Focus today we'll explore ways global
warming is altering the cost-benefit
analysis for infrastructure and finally
today is the last day of August and also
the last day of for soccer clubs to
trade players from Messi to Ronaldo it's
been a summer of huge deals we're going
to analyze the billions of dollars at
stake as players make moves I'm Jennifer
zabassanja and this is quick take charge
let's get going
we start here the war in Afghanistan is
officially over Major General Chris
Donahue was the last U.S service member
to leave the country as you can see in
that picture there and step aboard a
C-17 cargo plane in the early hours of
August 31st local time as the U.S has
left a new Force has taken control of
Hamid Karzai airport in Kabul the
Taliban Taliban special forces units
stormed the airport and celebrated the
U.S withdrawal here you can see them
right there decked out in American
military outfits and weaponry speaking
to the media a Taliban spokesman said
that quote America was defeated and
Afghanistan is now a quote free and
Sovereign Nation overall a hundred and
twenty three thousand people were
evacuated to the U.S and 15 000 to the
UK also tens of thousands of refugees
fled to other countries across the globe
and today August 31st the final U.S
flight as part of the evacuation effort
departed Kabul Airport heralding an end
to the 20-year Coalition conflict the
war has cost trillions in dollars and
almost a quarter of a million of lives
that have been lost the world now turns
its attention to the Taliban hoping that
the social and developmental gains made
in the past 20 years are not erased
overnight last night also the U.N
security Council met to adopt a
resolution requiring the Taliban to do a
few things one of them being Safeguard
gains for women and children's rights
also ensure the country doesn't become a
safe haven for terrorists and also allow
foreign humanitarian organizations to
care out work unimpeded and as we
mentioned in the intro China and Russia
abstain from the vote on this resolution
so a lot to get to this morning and with
us to discuss is Bloomberg opinions
Bobby Ghosh in London as well as eltaf
najavizada who has handled Bloomberg's
Afghanistan coverage extensively and he
is joining us from New Delhi El Tiff
let's just start with you um what
exactly does the Taliban want now from
America now that we have officially left
the country
Taliban they are seeking International
recognition from International Community
especially from the United Nations and
that's why they are they have sought
assistance of the United States to help
them seek International recognition
that's one thing and the second thing is
the talibans
the facing uh worst economy situation in
the country especially the financial
issue and they want money to run the
government that's accounting challenges
for the for the Taliban because the U.S
fed they have cut off uh 9.5 billion
dollars in reserves for Afghanistan's
Central Bank and that's why the Taliban
want them to to be released to the
Taliban governments in the future so
that's the reason that they want
International recognitions they want to
see go to relationship with the United
States with all the countries around the
world even with the with the close
neighbors with immediate neighbors China
Pakistan around those countries
Bobby I also want to get your take on
this we we mentioned a few things that
we heard the Taliban spokesman said also
we heard them say at the airport the
Islamic Emirate once a good and
diplomatic relationship with the
Americans I wonder what you make of sort
of what we heard from the Taliban as the
Americans uh were finally exiting the
country
well I'm I'm much more skeptical I I'm
I'd like to see them act rather than
speak the actions so far have been
cautious in parts of the country that
they have been running for several years
now their behavior has not been very
conciliatory they've been very much
Taliban 1.0 they're promising upon
arrival in Kabul that they will be a
different kind of Taliban but I am very
skeptical about that I think they
certainly want International recognition
but they want it on their terms they
wanted International recognition the
last time around two when they had power
but they refused to do the things that
the International Community required
them to do this time around the
International Community once again is
making very clear what the terms are for
recognition we'll see if the Taliban
first and foremost agree to those terms
and then we'll have to monitor very
carefully to make sure that they keep up
their end of the bargain they do have a
history of giving their word and then
taking it back and but we did hear
jensaki at the White House say that the
U.S has leveraged to hold the Taliban
accountable for for what they believe do
you believe that that the international
Powers
um do have some leverage as eltaf
mentioned about
um some of the money that the Taliban
wants Bobby I'm curious do you think
International powers do have leverage to
hold the Taliban accountable
well they have some they have some
limited powers it it all boils down to
whether or not the Taliban how badly the
Taliban wants that money and whether or
not they're willing to make those
compromises it is not an uh entirely
unlikely that the Taliban might just
decide at the end of the day that
they're not willing to make those
concessions and and decide that they
will return Afghanistan to where it was
20 years ago when they were still
running the country at that time they
were essentially cut out from the
International Community it's a more
complex country now it's a more complex
economy now hopefully the Taliban
realizes that but we can't really be
sure the the understanding of
international finances not very
particularly sophisticated they have
announced a central bank governor who
has very little actual experience
um in finance and and seems mainly to
have been in charge of extortion rackets
in parts of the country where they were
in charge this does not fill me with
with a great deal of optimism them and I
think the other thing to look out for is
what ordinary Afghans are saying and
doing the fact that so many people
particularly the kinds of people that
the Taliban would have needed to run
their country to run their economy so
many of those people are fleeing or want
to flee suggest to me that they don't
trust the Taliban if they don't then I
can't see why the International
Community should and eltaf just speaking
of the ordinary afghanis who are there
what have you heard about daily life now
that the Americans have exited for the
most part I mean has has it changed at
all
well the normalcy
is a
getting back to Kabul City actually
because after the withdrawal of the
American forces there has not been any
any attacks any suicide bombing at a
couple uh a couple City and people and
restaurants are opening shops are open
reopening uh economy is slowly opening
in Kabul City well people are not
worried now about these security
situations they are worried about their
economic situation because the economy
is getting its worst [ __ ] in Afghanistan
the prices are increasing that you know
the medicines prices are increasing the
foods are increasing because the Imports
have been halted for a while by the
Taliban the Customs or in Afghanistan
causing prices to go higher so that's
that's the issue daunting issue to where
the people are facing to
I have not seen the Afghan people in
Kabul that they have celebrated the
withdrawal of the American forces those
some there are some Afghans that who are
still fearful of their life of their
future because of the talibans take over
of the country and those who are fearful
or the previous government officials are
the Civil Rights activates or the
journalists because those peoples were
told by the Taliban
to to to come for kind of for some kind
of Investigations they were their their
houses their homes were knocked by the
Taliban to search them to grab them you
know to take them for into their
Castries for some sort of Investigation
so that that has created Fierce among
those kind of people but there are some
other people that I have spoken to they
are not worried of the Taliban because
they have not seen uh any uh any any
good thing in the previous government if
if they compare the previous government
with the current government of the
Taliban so those peoples are kind of
impartial I mean say that they are
they're careless people what they want
is just
job good economy in the country and
that's it
and we we also heard I mean we mentioned
that China and Russia abstain from that
U.N um resolution but we did hear China
say that they're hoping the
International Community actually helps
with some of those things that you
mentioned eltap what is it that China
and Russia are potentially seeing uh in
in potentially a relationship that they
could have with Afghanistan I want to
get your taken that Bobby I'd like to
ask you as well
um I think uh China is is trying to
expand its influence in Afghanistan
after the U.S left the country so that
vacuum the power vacuum has been left
now in Afghanistan and some someone from
outside the country is trying to fill in
that vacuum that power vacuum I mean
also we could say that influence in the
country Afghanistan has Rich mineral
resources does something could benefit
China and China has already got uh
several contracts of mineral resources
from the previous governments and they
try to expand you know its business
environment its business opportunities
in Afghanistan as well through the
current Taliban government it's not only
the Taliban the Afghanistan's mineral
resources there are other Regional uh
projects in billions of dollars like the
Taki dos pipeline also going through
Afghanistan also that that the China's
build and Road initiative in order to
influence expand its influence across
the region Russia Russia well of course
Russia didn't want to see American
forces station or based in Afghanistan
for the past 20 years for the past two
decades they have always opposed their
presence in Afghanistan and we have had
reports saying that Russia were also
helping funding entitlement providing
weapons at Taliban to to fight against
American forces in order to push them
out of Afghanistan finally and that
happened
yesterday all the American forces left
the country and Russia China may have
had some some kind of positive good
relationship with the Taliban in the
past two decades and now they're trying
to build on of that in order to expand
its influence across the country through
uh friendship with the Taliban which was
being called a terrorist group now they
are being called by Russians and Chinese
people as reasonable people to deal with
and Bobby is that how you read it as
well I mean I think it's interesting
that China and Russia abstain from this
resolution curious to get your take
well they clearly want to be in the
taliban's good books they don't want to
be seen as putting too much pressure on
the Taliban by abstaining they can have
their cake and eat it too they did not
veto the resolution which they could
have done so by abstaining they are
basically nodding to the International
Community and winking at the Taliban I
think altaf is exactly right both Russia
and China do not want a vacuum in
Afghanistan their interests in the
country are primarily to do with
security and geopolitics they don't want
Afghanistan to become another once again
a hotbed of terrorist activities because
some of those terrorist activities would
be directed at Russia and China just as
much as it is directed to the West the
Chinese do have an interest in in Afghan
mineral resources but I personally am
skeptical about just how far they will
go to get those resources because the
Investments required to get those
minerals out of the ground and then
transport them out of the country in a
country that has so little
infrastructure will be huge amounts of
money we're talking about tens uh of
billions of dollars that's a very high
risk for Chinese companies to take and
they tend not to want to take those
kinds of risks they may have a bigger
appetite for for risk taking than
Western companies or Western Banks but
at the same time they they're they're
not so reckless as to barge into a
country with uncertain political future
uncertain security environment as altaf
pointed out they did have some
investments in China before with the
previous government they had a they had
a 30-year concession on a very large
copper mine not far from Kabul but they
couldn't make that project work they
couldn't make it work despite the
presence of international forces
guaranteeing security despite having a
deal with the Taliban in which the
talban promised they wouldn't attack
that mine if China couldn't make it work
then I think we should be skeptical
about whether it can sort of invest the
tens of billions of dollars that
Afghanistan will need going into the
future and Bobby just in the last minute
or so we're going to hear from President
Biden in a few hours do you see this
potentially making a state putting a
stain on his legacy at all or do do you
think it will be a combination of the
former presidents who sort of started
this whole process and and the changes
made during the for presidents I'm
curious sort of what you think that will
be written in the history books now that
the 20-year War has officially ended
well the war hasn't really ended the
United States might the the White House
might want us to think it has if our
enemies haven't stopped fighting it
hasn't ended uh has the U.S now wants to
fight a different kind of war the Over
the Horizon kind of war from a distance
from a safe distance using drones
an aircraft but whether that will work
we'll have to see it didn't work in the
past when we tried to get Al Qaeda out
of uh Afghanistan without sending in
ground troops I'm skeptical that it'll
work going into the future whether or
not it stains Biden's Legacy I suppose
will depend to a substantial degree
about what happens in Afghanistan now
that the United States has left and
whether there is any blowback whether
whether terrorist groups like the
Islamic States like Al-Qaeda are able to
re-establish themselves there and then
begin to attack the west and attack the
United States that will be that will
decide whether or not it'll stain
Biden's Legacy but it's important to
remember that unlike let's say in
Vietnam uh when the when the United
States left the country
this is a very different news
environment and very different
information environment this is taking
place live on Twitter people are seeing
every step of the American withdrawal
and they're seeing every step of how the
Taliban reacts afterwards this is rather
different from one still picture of a
helicopter taking off from the roof of
the embassy in Saigon this is this is a
much more powerful series of image
images not even and I'm not even getting
into the disinformation campaign that
America's enemies will use in order to
remind people over and over again about
the humiliation in Afghanistan so yeah I
think this will live longer in memory
than the Biden Administration is
counting on absolutely we're going to
leave it there Bloomberg opinions Bobby
gosh in London as always for us thank
you so much and also Bloomberg News is
eltaf Naja visada in New Delhi thank you
both for starting us off this morning
all right coming up we're diving into
today's focus of the day extreme weather
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
and it's time now for by the Numbers
where we look the data tell us the story
today's number is three dollars and 18
cents the national average price for
regular unleaded gas is expected to rise
to three dollars and eighteen cents a
gallon this weekend hurricane Ida is
probably making this Labor Day the most
expensive for U.S drivers since 2014.
the storm left parts of the golf course
the Gulf Coast oil refining Hub in the
dark and for a day it halted flows on
the main pipeline that ships the
gasoline made there to East Coast
markets more than 2 million people in
Ida's path still don't have power it
could take weeks to restore meanwhile
the system of levees floodgates and
pumps installed after Hurricane Katrina
devastated the city in 2005 passed their
biggest test yet and chanali basic is
here joining me now for our quick take
focus of the day on Extreme Weather
Channel hurricane Ida is wiping out
power bringing intense rain and people
in its path are really being affected it
and really the effects of the storm are
still remain to be seen yeah and on top
of Ida we have tens of thousands of
people who are being evacuated from
their homes in different regions in
California we talk about the caldorfire
but there's actually been more than 6
000 incidents of fire this year alone
600
000 Acres almost burned a lot of people
to worry about and a lot of structures
that may not make it through so joining
us now to dive deeper into this extreme
weather is Bloomberg's climate reporter
Eric Roston thank you for joining us
from a science perspective how did we
get to this place of what scientists are
calling rapid intensification when it
comes to Ida in particular
the short answer is greenhouse gas
pollution but there's a chain of
causality that uh that comes between our
spoke stacks and tailpipes to Rapid
intensification of hurricanes the key
factor in uh immediate sense is warm
water uh all of the heat we have been
trapping in the Earth has turned the
oceans warmer and that is gasoline for
hurricanes and we've seen it
increasingly over the last few years we
have hurricanes that that are not
hurricanes like uh Ida started as a as a
tropical depression in the middle of
last week and within uh less time than
it takes a major city to evacuate went
from tropical depression to almost a
category 5 hurricane so this is
something that was projected to happen
more with climate change uh and
unfortunately it may be a part of the
hurricane system in the gulf and the uh
the Atlantic Ocean as we go forward and
uh Eric I mean our Focus today is
extreme weather there's so many
different weather events that we've seen
happen over the past month um chaneli
mentioned a few of those you have an
article out today that that is titled
killer heat forces cities to adapt now
or suffer and you really get into some
of the challenges that cities are facing
right now can you just walk us through
this pivotal Point uh that a lot of
cities are are at right now when it
comes to climate change
sure thank you uh this is an article
that is it's actually a sequel to a
feature we did last summer that looks at
economic analysis of heat and income
growth sort of over the course of the
next few decades it was done by a
research group called climate impact lab
and what they do is they look at how
income change and climate change
together create conditions where some
cities will be able to protect
themselves because they can they can
afford to they have a sufficient income
growth they can buy adaptation uh and
other cities will not be able to and
they'll suffer unfortunately as
temperatures rise uh it's a it's very
detailed uh very novel analysis with
implications for what cities can and
should do to protect themselves Eric can
you give us a sense of how this is
playing out across the world examples of
cities that might be suffering more
because they don't have the money to
protect themselves and on top of that is
it just the cities that can't protect
themselves or is this really about lower
income individuals not being able to
protect themselves against climate
change
a really important question because
fundamental to the analysis is that
income and adaptation save lives and
that is true globally uh cities than in
more developed richer countries will uh
have fewer heat deaths as temperatures
rise and consequently developing uh
cities in developing countries will will
suffer more and see uh more heat deaths
within cities you see the same Dynamic
on a smaller scale which is vulnerable
populations which is uh underserved
communities and older people will
disproportionately feel the heat the
good news is that cities are
increasingly aware of this Seattle which
until mid-june had been thought of as a
temperate Pacific coast city is now in
the throes of of heat planning to try to
protect their vulnerable populations
from when extreme heat comes again
and there's obviously also true of
everyone else in the region Vancouver uh
Portland and and all the towns between
them
but we're uh I I think the late June
heat wave in the U.S and Canada uh
similar events around the world in
Northern Africa southern Europe Tokyo
and Northern Japan
um everyone is waking up to the threats
and the very practical uh in many cases
affordable steps they can take to
protect their people and uh can you talk
can you walk us through a little bit of
that Eric I mean what sort of local
level policy could we we see cities take
in the near future to to prevent some of
the future tragedies that we could see
there's really a gamut and in our
reporting one of the uh more useful and
and interesting documents uh we turned
up was a 2017
almost catalog of things cities can do
to protect themselves from uh from heat
and these run the gamut from very
inexpensive
things that everyone can do which are
taking advantage of community
communication networks and making sure
that uh Community groups know when heat
is coming know what to tell uh people
who live in their Community how to
protect themselves
I'm not sending alerts uh making sure
emergency services are trained and
funded to take care of people uh those
are on the Emergency Management end but
there's also uh the way we build cities
in some cases uh can protect us from
heat when it comes there's a well-known
uh phenomenon called the urban heat
island effect which is all the concrete
and glass and buildings cities kind of
soak in Sun uh sun solar energy and it
makes them hotter than rural areas
around them well many cities around the
world are learning how by planting trees
by setting up ponds by having white
roofs or green roofs
they can actually mitigate some of that
heat and prevent heat illness and heat
related mortality right I saw you
mention Maricopa County and they're
planting trees I grew up there so so
that really stuck out to me Eric rossen
we have to leave it there though he is a
climate reporter for Bloomberg news
thank you so much for your time all
right coming up what are these extreme
weather events doing to the cost-benefit
analysis of infrastructure like power
grids we'll discuss in two minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the latest report from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change made it clear that extreme
weather events left unchecked will
become more frequent and more intense
those extreme events wreak havoc on
power grids and so what does that mean
for electricity users moving forward the
cost is bound to be shared by
governments and individuals so here now
is Bloomberg opinion columnist Liam
Denning thank you for being here Liam
how is climate change altering the
cost-benefit analysis of power grids
well it's forcing us to internalize
costs that in the past we might have
ignored to some degree you know as long
as there have been power networks there
have been natural disasters that cause
damage to them and the way that's
usually been dealt with is that uh you
know the cost of cleaning up and
repairing things gets put into our
utility bills the the difference with
climate change is uh what we think of as
extreme weather is becoming more
commonplace and more intense and so the
question we face is can can the utility
model whereby we share all these costs
really cope with the higher costs we're
going to face not just from future
disasters but but the investment that's
required to to mitigate those disasters
and Liam can you talk about sort of the
real life examples that we're seeing
right now I mean we just mentioned
hurricane Ida in Louisiana also
wildfires in California I mean what is
it that that users there are paying and
sort of
um how do you analyze the situation
based on what we're seeing right now
so one way I look at it is to see how
much people are paying out of the
disposable income for their utility
bills uh one of the uh quirks of
Louisiana is that actually that their
power costs are among the lowest in the
nation per Mega per kilowatt hour uh the
problem being that um because of all
that air conditioning they use a lot of
kilowatt hours so actually
louisianans are among the top 15 states
in the country in terms of how much
they're paying out of their income for
utility bills it's about three and a
half percent right now
we're also seeing this in California
where actually although rates are higher
people use less electricity and they
tend to earn more so right now it might
not seem like a problem the problem is
though is that you have vast differences
of income in a state like California not
everyone lives in Silicon Valley and so
the burden is actually already pretty
heavy on on poorer communities and we're
starting to see The Strain already after
the wildfires of a few years ago the
state felt compelled to set up an
insurance fund because one of its
largest utilities PG e went bankrupt
Under The Strain we've also seen cities
like San Francisco threatened to leave
PG E's grid because they think they'd be
better off on their own rather than
bearing the cost of you know burying
power lines out near the Sierra Nevada
so we what does this all mean what's the
direction of travel I'm glad you brought
up the wildfires as well because of the
cost it's putting on Californians and so
what can they expect next as these fires
escalate and that tension you describe
between the more wealthy cities and more
wealthy populations and the the
populations that need the help a little
more continue to diverge well I think
the way to think about this is pressure
on the utility model you know if you
think about it you know the whole point
of a utility is to share these sometimes
very uneven costs of getting us all on
the grid for a universal service and you
know by and large uh we we don't mind
shouldering those costs in a in an in an
equalized way the question I think
that's being brought up by events like
California's wildfires like Texas is
freeze like Louisiana's hurricanes is
can that continue as we internalize
these bigger costs and as people begin
to wonder well if someone chooses to
live in a place where those risks are
higher uh do people who don't live there
want to bear the cost of that up to this
point we we have borne that cost the
question is whether that will continue
Liam do people have have a choice I mean
who who's going to be the one having
these arguments that you mentioned or
these um you know discussions about the
cost benefit analysis is it is it going
to be companies like PG e is it going to
be uh residents who who live in these
cities or local officials I'm curious
sort of what you think uh how you think
this plays out well it's a question
that's already being asked and it should
be stress a lot of people don't have a
choice as to where they're living I mean
you only have to look at the cost of
housing in in California to know that
not everyone is choosing to live in
these more remote places uh just purely
out of choice
um but the the conversation is already
happening you know when I was reporting
on the wildfires in California a few
years ago uh the the phrase climate
change gentrification had already
entered the conversation and what that
referred to was the need for people who
say choose to live in a riskier area to
suddenly have to for example self-insure
because insurance companies would no
longer cover them for Wildfire risk and
you can certainly imagine that happening
in other places where you know cities or
towns have been built on on marginal
ground that needs to be engineered in
some way to to cope with the risk of
floods or high winds or wildfires well
it begs the question right because it's
not the only risk that is privatized
right in terms of self-insuring you see
wealthier individuals paying for private
firefighters for example to keep their
possession safer in these environments
at the end of the day Liam at what point
are taxpayers brought in to bear the
cost of the damages these coastal cities
are facing well taxpayers are already
brought in
um you know we talked about the the
wildfire Insurance Fund in California
there's the the 14 and a half billion or
so I think I've got that figure right
that was spent Shoring up the the levees
and flood defenses for uh New Orleans
now
that in itself is an interesting
question you know people might say well
why does the federal government pick up
that tab well we all rely on the
Mississippi uh functioning properly so
it is a legitimate Federal investment
but these questions are going to
multiply uh in coastal areas in uh
Wildlife Urban interface areas the
question of who picks up the tab to keep
those places viable is is going to come
back to the fore
really fascinating column Liam thank you
so much for joining us this morning that
is Liam Denning he is a Bloomberg
opinion columnist thank you for your
time all right up next the Cannabis
industry has been legalized in a number
of countries so our psychedelics next
we're talking to the CEO of Silo Simon
about the future of the industry in two
minutes we'll be back this is quick take
charge
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
pharmaceutical is the first South
African company to win the right to grow
process and package cannabis products
and now it's considering an IPO so
joining us now is Silas I've been CEO
and president Gabrielle tharone joining
us live Gabriel thanks so much for being
here so how significant is a full
cannabis license to your business
especially considering the fact that you
are looking at an IPO on the horizon
well good morning Jennifer so maybe to
start off with I think firstly we need
to understand what these two licenses
mean so in South Africa you get two
different licenses the one would be a
cultivation license and you must think
of it like an export license for bulk
flower and that's basically your raw
material of cannabis
the the second license that we now
obtained is a manufacturing license and
they call it a GMP license so that now
enables us to not only export bulk but
we can now go from a B2B Model A
business to business model down to a
business to Consumer model so we're now
allowed to create a brand that we can
take to to end user and I think that is
the biggest significance of having both
these licenses so it opens up the global
playing field for us to now build a
brand and so let's talk about uh these
licenses as we mentioned uh you are
obviously work in the Cannabis space but
also uh psilocybin you have your site
set on that talk to us about why that's
next and sort of what you think uh the
industry looks like and the
opportunities look like for psilocybin
in the near future
the assignment is definitely going to be
much bigger than cannabis I think
cannabis cannabis has paved the way for
psilocybin to to enter into the global
playing field it is going to take I
think quicker for psilocybin to to to
move through all the various legislative
processes even if you look at cannabis
cannabis is still struggling to to get
through all the legislative issues if I
can call it that so globally it's still
very difficult to get into all the
various markets but I think from a
psilocybin point of view it is going to
be the future it is going to be massive
you you already know that there's
companies that that has gone public on
the the NASDAQ so in terms of research
psilocybin is going to be massive so
what us as a company we've already
applied for a research permit
um from our regulator and we're setting
our sites on doing a research in that
field and then hopefully apply for
commercial license to service the global
community and what makes you so so
sanibus has received Global attention
so if you ask me that a week ago I would
have probably
gave you a thumbs up answer if I with
that answer today the amount of people
that reached out to us in the last week
since Bloomberg broke the story
I I cannot tell you the how people are
getting excited how the community is
pulling together and asking us how they
can invest is the one question the other
question is how they can assist us to to
speed up our marketing it's been
phenomenal I think the support globally
to be honest with you I think what
covet's done to to the global Community
it's forced everybody to look inward
into their own health I think from a
psychedelic point of view and and the
amount of depression has risen and
people are turning to other forms of of
medicines if I can call it that and and
psychedelics has been playing a massive
role I I had a discussion with a doctor
yesterday and he said to me if it wasn't
for micro dosing on psilocybin he would
have lost his mind in this past through
a year with covet and he said it's
really pulled him through and he wants
to do more research and he wants he
wants to continue research on on
psychedelics and do you see investors
having that same enthusiasm uh you know
the fact that you're planning on ipoing
and expanding across the world I mean
what do you think investors need to know
about this
so from an investor point of view we've
been bombarded
um our website literally exploded from
people who want to get involved on an
investor level and not just in South
Africa it's been Global
um as far as Cambodia America literally
everywhere so the I think the excitement
is there I think investors understand
that there's a new way of psychedelics
and all of these plant-based medicines
coming
the the Biotech Industry is going to be
much bigger than the I.T industry
um that's what some of the researchers
are saying so I think investors are
ready to to get into something different
um and plants based medicines
and where do you see some of the
challenges though I mean you mentioned
how um you know it's different depending
on the country that you're speaking
about but you're planning on signing
deals in you know Australia Brazil the
UK what sort of challenges lie ahead in
in the short term for you as you
continue to convince people that that
this is the future
so if you talk cannabis the the biggest
challenge basically is getting past all
the regulatory uh challenges so one
being for example we're talking about a
plant that gets extracted into a
medicine and cannabis is one of the only
plants where the plant needs to be grown
almost at a pharmaceutical level for it
to to get through the process to go into
a further processing of Medicine
if you look at anything else where a
plant is used the plant itself doesn't
need to be compliant to a GMP a good
manufacturing practices
standard whereas cannabis is and it's
been extremely difficult to get organic
product across borders
um where it's it's
allowed according to legislation so
you're looking at a a schedule or in
South Africa they call it a schedule six
narcotic I believe in America it's a
schedule one
narcotic that you want to try and move
across borders and it it is treated so
difficult the process is so difficult to
get it across and it takes very very
long to move product so that is the
biggest challenges
um but in terms of the markets the
markets are there but the challenges is
moving the product and and yeah that's
been the hardest to date
really interesting stuff especially
about the psilocybin Gabriel Throne the
Simon CEO and president thanks so much
for staying up and talking to us about
the company all right we'll be back in
two minutes this is quick take charge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and now here are a few stories we don't
want you to miss this morning inflation
in the Euro area has jumped to its
highest level in a decade consumer
Prices rose this month at a rate of
three percent that was higher than the
predictions of all 37 economists in a
Bloomberg survey that's testing
policymakers insistence that a
post-crisis spike in cost pressures
should prove to be temporary also health
insurance coverage in the U.S improved
last year according to the CDC more than
90 percent of Americans are on a plan
the number of uninsured has fallen to
31.6 million down slightly from 2019
among adults 18 to 64 almost 14 percent
were uninsured and finally apple is
looking to outer space for an iPhone
upgrade yes you did hear that right
Bloomberg has learned the company will
add satellite features to iPhones for
emergencies that will allow users to
send text messages to First Responders
and Report crashes in areas without
cellular coverage the satellite features
are unlikely to be ready until next year
pretty Spacey stuff all right you can
learn more about these stories and save
to date on the day's news at
bloomberg.com now coming up today's the
final day of the summer transfer window
for European soccer leagues and it's
already been a historic transfer season
we're going to discuss in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access to financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so today is the last day of the summer
transfer window across the major
European football leagues leaving clubs
scrambling to seal some final deals
before tonight's deadline to buy and
sell players it's already been a major
transfer season with Premier League
clubs spending almost a billion pounds
so far but the main attraction has been
the moves from the world's two biggest
stars Lionel Messi and Cristiano Ronaldo
so here now to break it down for us is
Joe Easton he is a UK markets reporter
for Bloomberg joining us from London Joe
thanks so much for being here so let's
talk about the financial impact of Messi
and Ronaldo's transfers I mean how
significant was it for these clubs
well it should be pretty significant and
particularly from man united given that
he's an ex-player coming back and we've
seen a really good um reception to that
across the fan base and you should get
um some impact potentially coming
through maybe even on sponsorships but
we really need to see um the on pitch
um impact of these signings it's quite
interesting if you look at the revenues
of of the big clubs at the moment it's
really the ones that have performed on
the pitch and that have boosted their
revenues most
um Liverpool is a good example a club
that doesn't spend that much money
comparatively compared to man united Man
City parachute German but they managed
to get their revenues up really high and
that's really a reflection of how
important it is not only to get the big
name players but also for them to
perform and you get the bigger
broadcasting rights uh the biggest
sponsorships as I mentioned and get your
financial impact of those players up
it's not just about bringing those big
names in unfortunately right and I mean
we're looking at Juventus right there
um down right now
um but how significant is it for a team
like Juventus because this also opens up
the door for them to potentially bring
in other players right
yeah well the big thing with Ronaldo was
his wages and was so High um estimated
somewhere between 20 and 25 million
euros um a year which is quite a lot of
money just
um in terms of one player and also the
fact that with Ronaldo on such high
wages
um other players and their agents were
able to demand higher as well so this
will be not only are they getting a
small fee from Manchester United
reported to be about 15 million euros
they'll also remove him from their wages
and that will help them
um in spending more money on new players
and potentially
um improving on the pitch because the
the commercial impact of Ronaldo after
three years it had started to decline
naturally the excitement had sort of
worn off so it's kind of a good move for
them to get him off their wages really
and Joe when we talk about um you know
of course today is the the deadline for
the transfer window I mean how has the
pandemic affected these clubs we knew we
know they took a financial it but you
know how has what we saw from the
pandemic affected what they're able to
do during this transfer window
so it's been really noticeable
um among the lower levels of um the
clubs so particularly in the UK where
you have some really dominant teams as I
mentioned like man city which really
weren't that impacted by um the pandemic
because although they lost that ticket
sales income they have very wealthy
owners they also get Champions League
income the biggest competition in terms
of Club football in Europe but the lower
teams were so dependent on their tickets
sales revenue that they've really had to
cut back on players so we've seen
massive um declines in the quantity and
size of transfers at the mid and lower
levels across the UK in England and also
across the big European leagues as well
it's really been about the big teams
consolidating their power Manchester
City man united PSG those teams that
I've mentioned they've really weathered
the storm haven't been too impacted and
really have actually come out of the
pandemic in probably a stronger position
and than they were and a few years ago
which is quite an interesting Dynamic
finally Joe just in the last 30 seconds
or so we we heard about the deal that
Amazon struck to air some of the French
league uh games is this significant for
Amazon is this significant for the
French league uh how do you read it
I think it's probably a bit of a trial
um for Amazon so they're actually coming
in they're undercutting the predecessor
in terms of the subscription fee they
probably see it as a test model how big
can we make this league among Amazon and
subscribers and Amazon users that are
willing to pay that extra money and then
later you might see them go into other
countries where they previously only
bought specific matches they had you
know packages of around 10 games
um that they would sell on to Amazon
Prime members in the Premier League
rather than doing a full season so it'll
be quite an interesting project but it
seems like something that they're
looking to try out and see where they go
in terms of other countries later on
definitely really interesting stuff Joe
Easton UK stocks reporter for Bloomberg
for us in London thank you so much for
your time and finally we're ending the
hour with some good news on this Tuesday
defending Champion Naomi Osaka got her
U.S open campaign up and running
smoothly with a win over Marie buscaba
in straight sets last night she's said
it feels kind of crazy to play in front
of everyone again she said that on court
afterwards Naomi Osaka went on to say
last year when we didn't have a crowd it
felt quite lonely for me the energy here
is unmatched Osaka is a four-time grand
slam Champion she abruptly withdrew from
the French Open and Wimbledon creating
awareness about the mental health
challenges athletes are facing worldwide
great stuff all right that'll do it for
quick take
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to Quick take
stock it's the show for retail Traders
eager to get smarter I'm Katie greifeld
Tim stenovic is off today and let's get
right to our movers starting with zoom
because it is the biggest decliner in
the NASDAQ 100 right now down about 16
already today you can really see how
ugly that looks on the two-day chart and
that's because Zoom reported earnings
say that only slightly beat expectations
and what's worse is that the Outlook
they gave pointed to slowing growth
ahead and you can see that that is just
punishing shares today absolutely
ruthless and let's move on to Global
star because it's stored 64 yesterday
that was just on speculations that
Apple's new iPhone is going to use
satellite Communications and that Global
star would be the most likely partner
that was yesterday's move then Bloomberg
News reported that actually Apple's plan
will initially be more limited in scope
and you are seeing the stock fall today
but also as you can see it's still up
about over 30 percent for this week
alone and finally I want to hit on
PayPal because this is a really
interesting story it closed 3.6 percent
higher yesterday after we learned that
PayPal is going to push ahead with its
efforts to launch stock trading that
they already had hired someone to lead
that effort falling a little bit today
but still up over the past week which is
only two days but speaking of trading
platforms Robin Hood tanking this week
having a really rough go of it and for
more of that we have Bloomberg's Annie
Masa and Bloomberg intelligences Julie
chiarell Annie let's start with you
what's driving this sell-off
so what's driving the sell-off in Robin
Hood shares is the fact that uh the SEC
chair Gary Gensler signaled yesterday
that he might be open to a ban on
payment for order flow which is a key
source of revenue for Robin Hood so the
the way that payment for order flow
works is it's a process by which Robin
Hood and other brokerages make trades
happen for their customers basically
what they do is they take in those
orders from customers and they send them
out to high frequency Traders so Citadel
Securities virtue Susquehanna who
actually fill the orders and and
crucially those trading firms pay Robin
Hood for the ability to do that now this
practice has been in place for a long
time it is regulated and it's legal
however there is controversy around it
and questions are over whether it's in
the best interests of investors so when
Gensler said that he might consider uh
the the when he said that he wouldn't
necessarily rule out the possibility of
a ban on payment for order flow that
sent Robin Hood's stock uh tanking and
I'd be interested to hear what Julie has
to say about the likelihood of such a
ban ever going into place
yeah thanks Annie at Bloomberg
intelligence we are not too concerned
that there will be a band in outright
band on payment for order flow we expect
The Regulators to take a look we expect
perhaps Revelations you know
requirements for additional transparency
but we doubt that there would be any
kind of ban I think genzer ginzer wants
to start with the firm you know hand as
he goes into these discussions and
negotiation and the research around this
and so I think he wants to leave all
things on the table so it's taken
seriously but ultimately payment for
order flow is what allows Brokers like
Robin Hood to offer zero commissions
right so taking that away you know might
indeed cause a bit of an uproar among
the retail investor Community well Julie
that's exactly what I want to get into
so yourself and Bloomberg intelligence
don't think it's too lightly that we
will see an outright ban but if we did
what would that mean for zero fee
trading how would Robinhood or other
platforms too make up the difference
well for Robin Hood payment for order
flow is about 38 percent of their
revenue as of the second quarter a year
ago it was well over 70 percent it's
come down a lot because their crypto
trading has gone up to to to to take a
larger portion of their revenue but
still forty percent seventy percent it's
a big chunk of revenue for Robin Hood if
that payment Revenue flow went away they
would need to reconsider zero
commissions and begin to Institute some
kinds of commissions in order to to have
a to have a revenue stream
and so Annie we're talking about Robin
Hood here obviously it's a very hot
topic for Robin Hood but it's not just
Robin Hood right what other platforms
should we be talking about here and
thinking about
this would affect other major Brokers
that sell order flow so I mean Charles
Schwab is an example of another large
publicly traded brokerage
um it's TD Ameritrade platform for
example uses payment for order flow
um so but the difference between Robin
Hood and some of those other big
platforms is that being much larger they
have a lot of different revenue streams
that Robin Hood might not have entered
into yet so any ban on payment for order
flow if it were to come to pass could
affect Robin Hood more dramatically in
the beginning here where it's where it
does have more of a dependence on that
Revenue stream than some of its
competitors
and so Julie I want to switch gears a
little bit and talk about PayPal because
again we did learn yesterday that they
would like to offer stock trading to
their nearly 400 million customer base
what's your take on that is that a smart
move for PayPal
um I think it's absolutely something
that PayPal should be doing if their eye
is on becoming a super app right and
that's what they've stated they wanted
to do back in February when they had a
big investor meeting they have been
talking about being a super app to be a
super app to be a financial home to
Consumers at this point it's getting to
be table Stakes that you have all these
various types of financial services that
includes trading it includes bill
payment it includes lending and and so
having Stock Investing as a part of that
is just going to get more eyeballs on
the platform more usage and eventually
more Revenue so it's interesting to see
PayPal take this route because if we
think back to Robinhood earnings we
heard a lot about their Ambitions to be
that sort of one money super app so
Julie who's in a better position here to
actually achieve that Robin Hood or
PayPal you know it's so interesting
Katie because I mean the race really is
on to be a super super app it's not even
just PayPal and Robinhood you have
square in the mix you have Neo Banks
like chime and Sofi in the mix almost
everyone who has a financial app is now
talking about becoming a super app so
the the race really is on we'll see who
the winners are but you have to like
PayPal's positioning here being that
they are the most established player 400
million consumers on their app platform
30 million Merchants who accept Paypal
it's a two-sided Network that really
just no one can match right now well
these super app arms race definitely is
something that we're going to keep an
eye on but Bloomberg's Annie mass and
Bloomberg intelligences Julie chavriel
thank you both so much for your time
well coming up we're talking about the
Boom in property Tech and how the supply
chain bottlenecks could impact your
holiday shopping plans we'll be right
back you're streaming quick takes off
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk Emerging Markets because with
me now is fifth wall co-founder and
managing partner Brendan Wallace Brendan
great to have you on the show your firm
has invested in a number of companies
that went public this year is that a
result of the pandemic or is 2021 just a
great year for fifth wall
uh I think 2021 is a great year for
proptech I think what's happened this
year about five fifth wall portfolio
companies have gone public so we had
smart rent which actually went public
through a merger with a fifth wall spec
um we had open door which also went
public through merger with us back we
had hippo which went public through
merger with a SPAC Doma which formerly
was known as State's title that went
public thrifts back and then blend
um in the mortgage space went public
regular way so I think what's happened
is 2021 has become this kind of Boom
slash validation year for proptech that
no one really anticipated you know the
it's been building for a while but it's
great to have it kind of memorialized
like this in such a a grand fashion in
the public markets
and so Brendan let's rewind a little bit
and what is proptech could you break
that down for us and why has it been so
hot this year especially
so proptech is just property technology
right it is technology or technology
systems that sell into the real estate
industry and the fact that so much value
has been created in proptech really
shouldn't be that surprising and the
reason is that real estate is actually
the largest industry in the United
States so real estate is 13 of US GDP
it's the largest asset class it's the
largest lending category it's the
largest store of consumer wealth and I
think anyone that has interacted with
the real estate industry either
professionally or even as a consumer
recognizes that it's pretty archaic
meaning real estate is probably one of
the slowest and latest adopting
Industries with respect to technology
now about five years ago all of that
started to change right and large real
estate companies mortgage companies
financial service companies recognize
that Tac needed to collide with this
massive part of our economy and as it
has it's created all these enormous
outcomes the companies I just mentioned
the open doors the Blends the hippos the
world that I think are creating a lot of
value because it's like the real estate
industry had to play catch-up on missing
like two decades worth of innovation and
that's been really exciting to see
so we know real estate is really hot
right now we know Tech is really hot
right now are you at all worried about
valuations are you still finding
companies that you can invest in at a
reasonable price at this point
I mean look it's been you know kind of
almost like five years of Boom time for
for Tech I'd say you know every venture
capitalist should you know be somewhat
circumspect about valuations right now
the reason I think real estate
technology is probably a bit safer than
other spaces that this is as I mentioned
it's the largest industry in the US
right the real estate industry is 13 of
US GDP it's historically been one of the
lowest Spenders on it and that is stub
that is suddenly starting to inflect
actually right now real estate is
probably one of the fastest spending
Industries on it and it's like the real
estate industry is kind of catching up
as I said on like these two decades of
innovation at mist
so while that means you should obviously
be thoughtful about like look am I
getting in at too high a price you have
this secular Mega Trend right of the
real estate industry for the first time
adopting Tech which bails you out of a
lot of holes now I think what that means
is real estate Tech is a category will
continue to attract more dollars
there'll be more companies created
there'll be more you know IPOs that
happen it doesn't mean that every single
company will be successful and I think
that is ultimately what's going to
separate you know the kind of the The
Venture funds that really understand the
space and understand the domain and
those that are kind of just you know
dabbling in it and I think that's also
starting to happen in in proptech as
well and so Brendan this is a show
Mostly for retail investors and while
you mentioned that five of your
portfolio companies have gone public
recently a lot of the companies that
you're probably evaluating and have
invested in are in the private market so
if I'm a retail Trader wanting to get
involved in the prop Tech opportunities
how would I invest along that theme
I mean there's been a lot of companies
in proptech that have gone public I
mentioned a bunch of them but there's
even Compass right which also went
public earlier this year so you know
there's a large number of now publicly
traded real estate technology businesses
and I think you'll just continue to see
more in terms of you know doing that in
the private markets obviously that's
that's much harder because that is
ultimately what Venture capitalists do
so it is hard for retail investors to
play in kind of private series a series
B series C rounds but with that said the
companies that have gone public like I
said the open doors hippos domas lens
and smart rents the world I mean these
are category leading kind of iconic prop
Tech businesses obviously we're we're
biased as an investor but I think they
represent a really attractive portfolio
of companies to kind of make a secular
bet around this collision between real
estate and Tech
Brandon Wallace fifth fault Walt
co-founder and managing partner thank
you so much for your time great to talk
with you well some of the world's
largest economies are starting to feel
the squeeze from struggling Supply
chains everything from Lumber to memory
chips to sneakers has been impacted at
this point so what does the supply chain
crisis mean for consumers here now to
talk to us about it is Laura Baron's woo
she's the co-founder and CEO of shipping
startup shippo Laura great to have you
with us let's start big talk to me a
little bit about what shippo does and
what the past 18 months has looked like
for your business is the whole world
really tries to deal with these supply
chain issues
yeah thanks for having me uh so the
company is called shippo we power
shipping for e-commerce uh what that
means is that our customers do
e-commerce businesses and you can
imagine if you're an online store you
always have to ship out you have to ship
your product to the consumers for the
consumer to to like receive the item
consumers are no longer walking to your
store to pick up the product so you
shipping to make that happen and um our
customers they're small mid-sized
businesses they're independent retailers
they're all struggling to figure out how
to ship like Amazon and Amazon Prime so
um what we're doing is we we give them
access to a shipping platform that
connects them to all different shipping
providers here in the US and
increasingly also internationally we
make sure that they have access to
really good shipping rates that they
have access to all the belts and
whistles that they need to offer really
competitive shipping to to Consumers who
shop on the internet
oh sorry continue oh sorry you were
asking about the last 18 months um so I
I just wanted to add there that the last
18 months have been like insane for for
e-commerce in general like every
business that was previously an offline
business just started selling on the
internet and then all new businesses
getting started got started as online
businesses as well we've seen a ton of
entrepreneurial activity uh people
starting people like becoming SMB store
owners people starting businesses even
people shipping like PPE on the uh on
the internet so um that's all led to
just an increase in in online shopping
and then also in shipping
and so I would imagine that's been a
boon for shippo as well working with
those e-commerce Merchants I gotta ask
is there an IPO on the horizon or where
what is the current state of the
business as a private company
yeah so in the last uh 12 months we
raised two additional rounds of
financing so the last round of financing
was uh done at a billion plus dollar
valuation and that was a great milestone
for us
um like at this point in time like we're
just there trying to figure out how to
create as much customer value as
possible like all of our e-commerce
Merchants are preparing for Christmas
for Holiday shipping right now so that
is a pretty stressful time for them and
and we're just here to make sure that
they're able to keep up and that they're
able to reach our consumers
um as as shipping increases
well Laura I would imagine you're going
to stay busy at shippo for a while
because it's amazing to me that again 18
months in we're still dealing with these
Supply chains issues and there's some
signs that it could get worse I mean if
you look at shipping costs from the US
to China they're picking up again what's
the light at the end of the tunnel how
does the global economy work its way out
of these supply chain crunches
yeah even as we're looking at U.S
domestic shipping this holiday season I
think we're starting to see that some of
the smaller shipping providers they stop
taking on new clients because they can
anticipate capacity issues now we're
ready
um so we're seeing people prepare for
holiday season significantly earlier
than before and I I think one of the
interesting trends that we are observing
is that the shipping industry is
becoming more fragmented so we've got
more shipping providers that are
emerging because the existing shipping
providers can't really keep up with all
of the demand coming from e-commerce
shipping so in the in the US even in the
venture-backed industry we're seeing a
lot of like Regional shipping providers
same day delivery options uh like
on-demand delivery options just more and
different kinds of delivery companies
emerging getting funded and growing
pretty rapidly because of all that
increased demand
well Laura Baron's woo co-founder and
CEO of shippo thank you so much for your
time it's great to chat with you well
looking to invest in Bitcoin without
actually investing in Bitcoin an ETF
might be for you but the SEC has yet to
bless any crypto ETF we're diving into
the race for approval next we'll be back
in two minutes you're streaming quick
take stock
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Bitcoin ETF is on and this tiny issuer
from Nashville Tennessee thinks its
small size could be its Competitive Edge
Valkyrie investment sought regulatory
permission from the SEC two months ago
for a futures-based fund it was able to
do it confidentially because it's a
small issuer a perk that likely made it
first in line for approval here to
discuss is valkyrie's Chief investment
officer Stephen McClurg Stephen great to
have you on the show walk us through the
strategy here what's the benefit of
having this application hidden for the
past two months
hi Katie thanks for having me um yeah we
were thinking about uh putting forward a
Bitcoin Futures ETF for a while now uh
after our Bitcoin spot ETF was filed so
we we decided to issue it uh
confidentially so that uh no one else
saw what we were doing and and copied
the ETF so that we would have the same
situation as having you know 13
different issuers for a Bitcoin spot ETF
so we wanted to get a little bit ahead
of the game and spend some time really
thinking through and working on the
strategy of uh of how it would be listed
on Exchange during that period of time
and so it feels like you were ahead of
the curve and the fact that it's a
futures-based filing we know that SEC
chair Gary Gensler is a little bit more
open to those and for our audience that
means that the Bitcoin ETF wouldn't
actually hold physical Bitcoin it would
track the price of Futures but Stephen
I'm curious why you want that route two
months ago before we knew that Gensler
would be a little bit more open to that
type of product
you know we were we were anticipating uh
that that type of uh of view and for us
it was almost a hedge uh for that uh but
of course one of the things that we were
really focused on was the fact that
Futures are already a regulated product
on the CME and spot Bitcoin is not so uh
you know given that fact uh we decided
that we would go ahead and put forward
that product as well
and so talk to me about the benefits
that you see for owning shares of an ETF
investing in a futures-based Bitcoin ETF
versus just buying Bitcoin outright
because if I were to go on coinbase on
PayPal right now I could get exposure to
bitcoin so what's the benefit for you
know for a retail investor for going the
Bitcoin route once they are available
yeah and you know there's there's a lot
of people that do go the route of buying
Bitcoin directly or going to an exchange
like gemini or coinbase in order to
purchase a Bitcoin directly but a lot of
people also have uh brokerage accounts
already set up and they don't want to
sign up for yet another one so they
might want to buy something through
their Schwab or their Fidelity accounts
or or whatever accounts they might have
so for a lot of people it makes it
easier to keep everything in one place
so to have an ETF available that uh that
people can access does make it a little
bit easier also institutional clients uh
do seem to prefer Futures and through a
wrapper like an ETF as opposed to buying
Bitcoin directly
and so I'm curious to hear your thought
on what kind of timeline we're talking
about because coming into 2021 everyone
I talked to on the crypto on the ETF
side all expected that this would
finally be the year for Bitcoin ETF
approval clearly hasn't happened yet do
you think that's going to come in 2021
or is this now a next year conversation
yeah the the quick and the truth is we
don't know
um you know we we think that the SEC is
being very prudent and making sure that
they're protecting investors before
approving any type of ETF whether it's
Bitcoin Bitcoin futures or or other
types of of crypto related ETFs that may
have been out there in the past so so we
think that you know they're they're
definitely spending a lot of time and
making sure that all the protections are
in place before uh before they approve
something like this and you know of
course we welcome the opportunity to
collaborate with Regulators to address
any concerns that they may have and
hopefully have a positive outcome
sometime this year maybe and so Stephen
while I have you I have to ask you about
nft's non-fungible tokens I follow it
you follow it it's been a really hot
Market uh over the past few weeks past
few months boom or bust what's the
outlook here
you know it I think it really depends on
the nft itself I'm a really big fan of
creating nfts for things like physical
art or other physical assets that aren't
easily tradable
um whether it's a where there's a
painting or something that somebody
creates I'm not sure yet on this uh this
nft boom that's happening right now you
know I've got kids that play fortnite
and uh they're always spinning their V
bucks on new skins which essentially is
an nft but they can't trade them and
after about a month they do get bored
with them and decide that they want to
buy another one so uh so so some of the
older skins uh do have a little bit less
value right and less usability as the
newer ones but that being said we've got
a lot of people that are that are
they're making big purchases in this
space you've got uh Steph Curry one of
my favorite NBA players just spent 180
000 on a board ape Yacht Club nft uh
Justin's son who's a friend of mine uh
just spent a 10 million dollars on a
crypto Punk yeah nft and uh even we have
to leave it there we're running out of
time but we have to get you back to talk
about nfts and everything else that is
Valkyrie Investments Chief investment
officer Stephen McClurg thanks for your
time we'll be back tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in 1964 a series of race riots between
Chinese and malays broke out in
Singapore leaving dozens dead and
hundreds injured when he came to Ritual
riots it was just Madness I experienced
myself firsthand and that was when I
felt so threatened and where I was
almost killed communal tensions that led
to the 1964 race riots contributed to
Singapore's separation from Malaysia the
next year
to avoid the mistakes of the past
Singapore's founding prime minister Lee
Kuan Yew and his team aimed to create a
society where different races religions
and cultures could live peacefully
here's how Singapore built a fairly
harmonious Society
Singapore has a population of 5.7
million people among the 3.5 million who
are citizens 76 are Chinese and 15 are
Malay malays are the native people of
the island during British colonialism
immigrants from China India and other
parts of the world came to Singapore as
the island was being developed into a
trading Port by the 1870s Chinese had
become the majority population in
Singapore in 1959 Singapore obtained
self-governance from the British to
completely break away from Colonial rule
in 1963 Singapore joined the Federation
of Malaya part of Malaysia today but it
was a difficult Union plagued with
differences in political approaches
economic conditions and sharp exchanges
between leaders from both sides the
relationships then were just not getting
on within the majority warranty
Singapore Chinese 75 Chinese from
Singapore in a merger with Malaysia
which are predominantly Malay 55 60
malays the community in Singapore the
majority Chinese have been doing very
well economically the Malaysians feel
that they will be undermined uh should
the Chinese and Singapore continue to
gain uh you know economic Supremacy over
the peninsula and in Singapore the idea
was that all research should be treated
equal but in Malaysia there was a
different Outlook because Malay leaders
and Malay politicians felt they were
sons of the soil there was a sense that
malays should always have the political
dominant position
in 1964 increasing racial tensions
between malays and Chinese led to a
series of riots Singaporean malays are
predominantly Muslims on July 21st a
Muslim holiday to celebrate the prophet
Muhammad's birthday clashes broke out
between Malay participants and Chinese
bystanders during a procession violence
spread across the Island ravaging
Singapore for weeks leaving 23 dead and
454 injured in September another series
of riots triggered by the killing of a
Malay Rickshaw Rider broke out xinal and
a few friends were on their way back
home from Friday prayers and the curfew
was imposed on September 2nd buses were
full so they jumped on a lorry for a
ride but the Lorry broke down in a
Chinese area a lot of Chinese youngsters
were standing by the roadside watching
and suddenly when they saw this group of
about 20 Malay
rising from the glory to come down to
get alternative transport they must have
thought that we were there to attack
them
and the next second he came out with
bicycle chains iron rods acid Bobs and
pandemonium broke loose they just
randomly were hammering killing people
on the streets but fortunately for me I
was able to grab a moving taxi and fled
to safety but that was not the end of
the story because when I took the taxi
ride and reached the other side where
where I live which is geylang area which
is the Malay area it was the reverse
malaise were beating up innocent Chinese
try show coolers fruit sellers who used
to be friends at one time
the September riots resulted in 13
deaths and left another 106 injured
about a year later Singapore separated
from Malaysia and became an independent
state
we are going to have a multi-racial
nation
in Singapore we will set the example
this is not a Malay Nation this is not a
Chinese Nation this is not an Indian
Nation
everybody will have his place equal
language culture religion the
Singaporean government enshrined
multi-racialism in its Constitution and
implemented major policies and
initiatives based on these principles
for Education housing politics and
Community Development
one of the first things that Singapore's
leaders did was to break down the
language barrier between ethnic groups
four official languages English Chinese
Malay and Tamil were established but
English was designated as a Common
Language if it was in Singapore are
required to take English as a first
language right as well as a mother
tongue language so so that enables them
to not just hold on to their Heritage
their ethnic culture but at the same
time be able to interact with people of
A different race at first there was
resistance from Chinese parents but
enrollment to Chinese schools gradually
dwindled and those to English schools
grew English
is the language of the Civil Service of
government parents saw the writing on
the wall if English is the language of
the Civil Service you go to an English
school so that your child can get a job
in the Civil Service which is an iron
Rice Bowl English became you know in a
way a unifying language for Singapore
and it was a very important decision
because that made Singapore so relevant
in the world and gave us our position
racial segregation dating back to
British colonial rule was thought to be
one of the reasons for the race riots so
in the 1960s and 70s the Singaporean
government forcibly removed people from
racial enclaves and relocated all Races
to new public housing Estates where
about 80 percent of Singaporean
households live today well over 400 000
people a quarter of Singapore's
population has been re-housed in the
last five years in these bright modern
Airy Flats nowhere in the world except
in Russia despite the government's early
efforts by the 1980s racial enclaves
were forming within public housing
Estates in 1989 the ethnic integration
policy was introduced to ensure a mix of
Chinese Indian and malays in each public
housing Block it's not just having
different race groups on the same
Corridor and they walk down the corridor
and say hello to each other or they you
know meet in the Town Square and they
see different race groups their children
go to the same neighborhood school and
that is a value
but critics see mixing ethnic groups in
public housing as a way of social
control
on a political level Singapore has
policies to ensure multi-racial
representation
in 1988 an amendment to the
Parliamentary elections Act was passed
this introduced the group representation
constituency or the GRC which required
political parties to field at least one
minority candidate in each GRC team
composed of three to six members
currently there are 17 grcs which mean
there are at least 17 minority members
among the total 93 members of the
parliament previously you could have a
party putting up a Chinese candidate
just hoping to get the majority Chinese
to work for them without having to worry
about the Malay voters but now no party
no candidate can behave in that way
anymore but detractors said the group
representation constituency was
introduced to make it harder for the
opposition to win elections
in 2016 the constitution of Singapore
was revised to include reserved
elections this meant that a presidential
election would be reserved for a
particular racial group if no one from
that Community had been president for
the past 30 years
the 2017 election was the first reserved
election and it was reserved for the
Malay community
but compared with the prime minister of
Singapore the president plays a largely
ceremonial role and doesn't hold much
power
the government also initiated
ethnicity-based self-help groups to
uplift the socio-economic status of the
poor employees in Singapore are expected
to contribute a small percentage of
their monthly income to one of the four
ethnic self-help group funds according
to their ethnicity the SE funds are
mainly used to subsidize tuition and
help upgrade skills for low-income
groups but ethnicity-based self-help
groups were criticized for emphasizing
the issue of race in recent years four
different self-help groups started to
run joint programs
foreign
so I wouldn't say that Singapore's
racial relation is perfect but
definitely we have come a long way since
1960s for multiculturalism
multi-racialism to succeed there has to
be a visible hand in society I think
we've done quite well you know we've not
had interracial Riot since 1969.
Singapore is a stable society and it is
this stability that has helped us
develop economically
Singapore has strict anti-racism and
anti-rioting laws the absence of race
rights doesn't mean there are no racial
tensions and racial disparities today
Singapore faces challenges to shrink the
income gap between malays and other
ethnic groups among the minorities that
they feel that they are marginalized
they couldn't speak out of it because
the whole system is structured in such a
way that it should be legitimate the
reason why you are where you are is
because you haven't done well right
whereas if you dive further and look at
some of the structural issues you
realize that if the reason why they are
not doing well certain racial groups are
not doing well maybe because there are
certain structural issues and challenges
that we have not been able to address in
the last 50 years be there in the
education sector be there in the housing
market be that in the employment sector
all these concerns about income the lack
of Mobility will intersect with racial
identity and in the long run this could
generate a Perpetual cycle of
unhappiness of this contact
overt racism might have been reduced in
Singapore but covert discrimination
still exists researchers found that over
half of malays and Indians in Singapore
perceive discriminatory treatment at
work
recently coronavirus outbreaks in
cramped dorms where many South Asian
migrant workers live has also
highlighted the inequalities that still
exist in different parts of Singapore's
Society
[Music]
the maintenance of racial Harmony is a
work in progress the goal posts change
all the time and you've got to keep
catching up but what hasn't changed is
that racial Harmony day is celebrated on
July 21st each year in Singapore to
commemorate the 1964 race riots and
remind singaporeans that racial Harmony
shouldn't be taken for granted
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
s go the harbor Bosch process might be
the most important for human survival it
enabled mass production of nitrogen
fertilizers which help our Farms Produce
more than ever before
the object is to produce an early crop
maturity and consequently more grain
volume
food is more affordable and billions of
us have avoided starvation it's been so
instrumental to the existence of our
species it's estimated half the nitrogen
in our bodies is made synthetically
this is how we harness thin air to feed
billions
[Music]
around the beginning of the 19th century
population started to grow faster thanks
to the Industrial Revolution but it was
hard to grow enough food harvests are
unpredictable and could take months to
renew for the next planting it became
clear to scientists that nitrogen was a
key ingredient for growing crops
in nature when plants die the nitrogen
they contain returns to the soil and new
ones grow using it
but agriculture disrupts that cycle so
farmers started using manure and compost
which contain nitrogen but it was never
enough by the mid 19th century the
superpowers of the time went to
extraordinary lengths to get better
fertilizer hundreds of British German
and American ships traveled to islands
off the coast of Peru to load up on bird
droppings
guano has high nitrogen content so
thousands of tons of the stuff were
mined and shipped across the Atlantic
but it ran out luckily for the men
mining it something more plentiful and
nitrogen-rich would come along in 1909
German chemist Fritz Harbor managed
something that had eluded scientists for
decades he synthesized ammonia from
nitrogen gas even though 78 of air is
nitrogen turning it into useful ammonia
fertilizer is extremely difficult
nitrogen doesn't exist as a single atom
it exists in a largely unreactive form
as two atoms coupled together with
triple bonds the strongest in nature
simply put it's incredibly hard to break
down it happens naturally but it's rare
either by lightning pulse and through
the air or bacteria slowly eating away
at rotting vegetation in the Earth
Hopper initially tried to mimic a
thunderstorm to produce nitric acid but
he only got small amounts so he began to
work with high temperature and high
pressure Germany's largest Chemical
Company BASF had engineer Carl Bosch
help Harbor turn it from a lab
experiment into a commercial process the
team had to invent much of their
equipment to handle the extreme
conditions and worked in a concrete
chamber away from other workers due to
frequent explosions when completed the
harbor Bosch machine stood nearly eight
meters tall and produced 90 kilos of
ammonia per hour but it wasn't used to
create fertilizer not initially Anyway
by 1914 the world was at War Germany was
struggling to manufacture explosives due
to shortages of nitric acid a proud
Patriot Fritz Harbor became involved in
the war effort and began to produce
poison gas
in 1915 chlorine and mustard gas at the
Battle of epro would kill tens of
thousands of troops
Harbor reportedly watched the field of
battle as the gas was released on Allied
troops
Harbor's wife Clara imovar a prominent
chemist in her home right was sickened
by his involvement and would commit
suicide by shooting herself with
Harbor's Army pistol
despite effectively becoming the father
of chemical warfare Fritz Harbor's
achievements in synthesizing ammonia
would lead to the award of a Nobel Prize
together with advances in breeding
synthetic nitrogen fertilizers more than
tripled average U.S wheat yields during
the 20th century
the planet's human population exploded
from 1.6 billion in 1900 to nearly 8
billion today as it became easier for
people to secure food as fertilizer use
ramped up after the second world war
population growth accelerated it wasn't
just human life the harbor Bosch process
supported billions more animals were
farmed to satisfy human consumption
of course there is a price to pay a huge
strain is placed on the environment by
the number of mouths to feed
a lot of the nitrogen and fertilizer
fails to make it into the food chain and
pollutes our water so as our population
continues to grow and the more we rely
on the Harbor Bosch process the more
nitrogen will leach into the environment
that is unless we choose to reduce our
meat heavy diets it also takes a lot of
energy to make ammonia out of nitrogen
the process Burns three percent of
globally produced natural gas and
releases another three percent of carbon
emissions so it isn't a guilt-free
miracle
but with almost every meal that we eat
we benefit from the harbor Bosch process
providing the world with easy and
affordable access to nitrogen
crop yields remained at 1900 levels we
would need four times more land to farm
on that's nearly half of all ice-free
continents rather than the 15 it is
today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s will have you cruising along at 350
kilometers per hour the ticket is about
the same as a flight and the
door-to-door time on some of the world's
most popular routes is the same or less
than getting a plane but decades ago
rail travel was in Decline it faced
Fierce competition from the air and auto
Industries then came Japan's bullet
train
foreign
by the late 1950s Japan's economic
Miracle had transformed the war ravaged
Nation its economy was growing quickly
the area between Tokyo and Osaka was
booming with industry people were
flocking to the capital for work but the
rail line connecting the two major
cities couldn't take the stress in 1958
a government panel was set up to tackle
the problem and several potential
Solutions arose among them building the
world's first High-Speed Rail Line many
were skeptical but two men were True
Believers Shinji Sogo was the then
president of the state-run Japanese
National Railway the other sogo's
colleague veteran engineer hideyoshima
up against bureaucratic obstacles and
fierce opposition the two drove the
project forward
in 1959 the tokaido shinkansen line
started construction under sogo's
leadership Shima was appointed the
Project's chief engineer his team
designed the sleek and revolutionary
cone-shaped front from which the bullet
train got its name rather than being
pulled by an engine in front each
carriage of the bullet train was driven
by an individual electric motor which
has proven to be safer faster and more
efficient a apart from the train itself
the team also built wider tracks which
were more costly but allowed for greater
stability and higher speeds
three thousand Bridges and 67 tunnels
were built on the 515 kilometer line to
allow a clear and largely curveless path
older trains were banned from the new
line equipped with Advanced Technologies
the new trains were able to travel as
fast as 210 kilometers per hour a
breakthrough in the passenger rail
industry and the world's fastest at the
time the journey time between Tokyo and
hazaka was cut from over 6 hours to four
on October 1st 1964 the new line opened
just in time for the Tokyo Olympic games
but neither Sogo nor Shima were invited
for the inauguration
they both resigned in 1963 because the
Project's budget came in at Double what
was promised 400 billion yen the
equivalent of 3.6 billion US dollars
today but despite their premature
departure the tokaido shinkansen line
was an immediate success and quickly
turned a profit it transformed the
nation allowing more people to work in
metropolitan areas and became a symbol
of Japan's post-war reemergence as an
economic and tech power
now over 300 trains operate on the line
every day and the trip between Tokyo and
Osaka has shortened to two and a half
hours the number of passengers has also
soared reaching 165 million in 2016.
after the success of the takaido
shinkansen line Japan has continued
expanding its high-speed rail network
and plans to build more
following Japan's lead countries like
France Germany and China have also
developed high-speed Railways by the end
of 2018 the total length of high-speed
rail network in the world will be over
46 000 kilometers and over half of it is
in China
[Music]
is enough
anti-gun activists in the US have been
pushing for gun law reform Australia
having made substantial changes to its
gun laws is often held as an example the
country has a very low rate of
gun-related homicide when compared to
the US where people are at least 20
times more likely to be murdered by
firearms
stricter gun controls can't stop every
mass shooting but they have made
Australia significantly safer place
here's how
Australia used to have a serious problem
with gun violence researchers Define
mass shootings as five or more deaths
not including the perpetrator from 1979
to 1996 there were 13 mass shootings
resulting in over 100 deaths and more
than 50 injuries however due to the gun
lobby and politicians sympathetic to
their firearm moaning voters little was
stunned to stop gun deaths it's being a
politician and living in that Bloody
house is the most important thing to
them
in April 1996 that all changed
on the island of Tasmania the worst
massacre in Australian history is
finally over at least 34 people were
killed and four others critically
wounded armed with two rifles an AR-15
and a 308 FN Martin Bryant made his way
through Port Arthur Historic Site
killing 35 people and injuring a further
23. both guns were semi-automatic
rapid-fire weapons and both were legal
in the state of Tasmania of the time the
Port Arthur Massacre was the worst
single-person mass shooting in global
history it utterly shocked Australians
and reignited public outrage
just 12 Days Later the then prime
minister John Howard pushed through a
sweeping set of gun regulations despite
a lack of support from his rural
constituency
[Music]
within a month the government passed the
National Firearms agreement transforming
gun legislation in the country before
the Port Arthur Massacre gun laws varied
from state to state what the agreement
did was standardize the laws nationally
certain semi-automatics and self-loading
rifles and shotguns were banned new
licensing requirements were adopted and
a National Firearms registry was
established the law says Australians
need a genuine reason for having a
firearm such as Sports shooting or for
agricultural use it doesn't include
self-defense people must go through
background checks and wait 28 days
before they can buy a gun
the government also spent 375 million US
dollars to buy back 640 000
civilian-owned guns and then destroyed
them
after the gun law reform the total
number of homicides involving a firearm
decreased by half the total number of
gun-related deaths fell rapidly as well
dropping more than half in 2016 compared
with 1996. Australia didn't see a single
mass shooting from 1996 to 2018 more
than 22 years however anti-gun activists
warned that following years of lobbying
by pro-gun groups Australia's strict gun
laws have been eroded and gun numbers
are almost back to the same level as at
the time of the Port Arthur Massacre in
May 2018 a family of seven including
four children were shot dead in an
apparent murder-suicide in the state of
Western Australia it's brought back
painful memories and uncertainty about
the issue many thought had been resolved
Australia is not totally immune to mass
shootings but its response to the Port
Arthur Massacre demonstrated how strong
political leadership and strict gun
control policies can help curb violence
and save lives
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
coming up on quick take
[Music]
it wasn't there before
the release of cyberpunk 2077 in
December of 2020 will go down as one of
the most disastrous game launches in
history there was some degree of runaway
expectations I think there was also some
degree that they weren't extremely
forthcoming with the state of the game
then streamers YouTubers twitch Stars
how do they make money is it a lot is it
a lot of work I play a straight 18 hours
and I'll finish the game or get to about
the 40 hour mark and then I'll make my
first video because there's very little
payoff for a long time right like
multiple years generally before you
really start to see a payoff
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
some degree of runaway expectations I
think there was also some degree that
they weren't extremely forthcoming with
the state of the game
the cyberpunk 2077 story is very much
kind of a story of everything that can
and will go rock in game development
what is this bug Jack is AI flipped out
he wasn't there before where's my gun
I I can't shoot the release of cyberpunk
2077 in December of 2020 will go down as
one of the most disastrous game launches
in history and it instantly rewrote The
Narrative of its celebrated developer CD
projekt Red larger Studios with bigger
budgets weren't able to create the same
quality of open World Games The Inside
Story of the making of cyberpunk depicts
a process marred by unchecked ambition
unrealistic timelines and a focus on
marketing at the expense of development
open CD projekt stock was at its high it
was the largest stock in the Polish
stock market cyberpunk was supposed to
be the biggest game of 2020. this was a
game that was starring Keanu Reeves this
is a game that was from the makers of
The Witcher 3 this was supposed to be
the big Temple release of last year and
for it to become such a disaster for so
many people I think we'll have pretty
far-reaching consequences
[Music]
City Project's Origins are somewhat
unique in the games industry
in the west and Japan the late 80s and
90s were dominated by games for the Home
console market and characters like Mario
and Sonic the Hedgehog were becoming
household names the same was not true in
a post-soviet and economically depressed
Poland most gaming was done on PCS and
most games were copied and sold in small
markets around the country you could go
to the market down the street in
Northside and buy and sell CDs and these
two guys uh March in novinsky and Michal
Kaczynski decided they were going to
start selling CDs and they wound up
striking a deal with the people who made
a game called Baldur's Gate which was
kind of like the seminal role-playing
game in the late 90s it was never a
business it was kind of Lifestyle so
we're actually pretty bad with counting
money so you can kind of think of it
almost like Nike you know where Phil
Knight was selling shoes out of the
trunk of his car you know you can kind
of think about it the same way it was
you know just selling physical goods and
then evolving that into a a much broader
Enterprise CD project named for selling
CDs would move on from just reselling
games to localizing Western and Japanese
made games into the Polish language but
it wasn't until 2002 that the company
would make its own game The Witcher
The Witcher is a huge huge series huge
fantasy series in Poland and so it was a
pretty big deal that these guys got the
race to make the video games
The Witcher book series is a source of
national pride in Poland and a CD
project released The Witcher 2 the video
game series would become an important
economic symbol for Poland as well a
city project Grant had become this
Behemoth of an institution in Poland and
they were really big in the Polish
technology scene because they were
getting more worldwide attention than
most polish companies do and I'm making
a lot of money and in 2011 when Barack
Obama came to visit Poland the Prime
Minister actually gave him a copy of The
Witcher tooth I confess I'm not very
good at video games
but I've been told that
it is
a great example of Poland's place in the
new global economy but it would be the
launch of The Witcher 3 in 2015 that
would Elevate CD projekt Red from
representing the best of Poland to
representing the best of the games
industry
I mean really the thing people look for
first and foremost I think is that the
game is just good and Witcher 3 was just
a phenomenal game
[Music]
there's a level of just storytelling and
emphasis on on making every side quests
count on top of the atmosphere the
dialogue the character interactions the
different way stories can end they nail
that other open World Games felt empty
and enforced and the developers of them
gave excuses as to why there couldn't be
more Rich story or interactions and The
Witcher 3 blew them out of the water CD
projekt Red was beloved they were seen
as a studio that was willing to make
what the player wanted and to truly put
in the love and effort required to make
a high quality game that really connects
with the people playing with it and the
winner for Game of the Year 2015 is
The Witcher 3. The Witcher 3 would go on
to win over 250 Game of the Year Awards
but along with being a critical success
for CD projekt it was also a financial
success
put the sales of Witcher 3 at around 28
million copies in 2019. a huge step up
concerning by 2014 The Witcher and The
Witcher 2 had only combined to sell 8
million copies and with two large
expansions for The Witcher 3 CD project
also helped separate themselves from
other AAA Publishers at the time
and the game award goes oh man I have to
pay a micro transaction to unlock that's
[Applause]
psycho other games and the most
notorious
um you know one to do this was EA's Star
Wars Battlefront 2. they got really
aggressive on micro transactions in a
game that already cost at least 60
dollars you could have paid more if you
bought the premium editions But Not only
was it that they were being very
aggressive and trying to get you to
spend money but you could actually get
items that helped you win
well Gamers kind of draw the line in the
sand there and they don't like them
TD project had done this phenomenal job
of marketing themselves as a gamer
friendly company we've said this a
million times and I'll say it again
we're Gamers first of all and we all
like to be treated fairly so it only
makes sense that as developers we apply
the same principle to everything we do
here at city project red so giving
everyone a bunch of free DLC wasn't
absolutely no-brainer
they they said we're not going to sell
you DLC that's like horse armor packs
and other nonsense we're gonna just give
you free stuff and then we're gonna sell
big expansions as part of The Witcher 3.
and not only were they really good they
were offered at a fair price and this is
a company that was seen as just like a
company that really cared about quality
and cared about its customers and would
not do anything to kind of screw fans
over the way that that fans see that EA
and Activision and all the other big
Publishers do with a critically and
financially successful game as well as
the Goodwill from the gaming audience
all the focus would shift to CD
Project's next release cyberpunk 2077.
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's actually funny they first announced
it through like a press release and then
they showed off a trailer at the
beginning of 2013 that was like the CGI
trailer of like a woman and there was
all sorts of cool cyberpunk stuff flying
cars lots of stuff but uh it wasn't
really until after The Witcher 3 that
cyberbunk began really like building up
this feverish level of hype CD project
red though wouldn't put out another
trailer for cyberpunk until 2018 at the
E3 trade show and they showed off a it
was like a two-minute trailer of
cyberpunk looked pretty rad
foreign
behind the scenes for E3 attendees for
press and anyone else who could get uh
score an appointment in there they
showed this 45 minute demo and it blew
people away
and play demo walkthrough of CD projekt
Red's upcoming title cyberpunk 2077. the
gameplay you're about to see is from a
work in progress version of the game
everything you see is potentially
subject to change
holy
this if they can live up to what they
showed me
it's game over
it all looked incredibly impressive they
had enough action enough narrative beats
with just the right amount of tension
they touted how each of these NPCs there
are thousands of them each one with
their own daily routines and everything
we've greatly enhanced our crowd and
Community Systems to create the most
believable City in any open world game
to date so yeah so um people were
certainly blown away by this demo at One
E3 Awards and just people left the
theater just in in uh um what they
didn't know of course is that the demo
was completely fake fake demos are
common at E3 Studios put together builds
of games to show off what they intend
the game to be like rather than the
actual state of the game what was unique
about this demo was that it was
impressively long it kind of plays into
this idea that CD projects is very much
a marketing driven company and so demos
were really really important to them so
it was really important that they make
this demo blow people away which it did
um but that might have come at the cost
of like some time they could have been
spending on the game A year later at E3
2019 fans will get another big surprise
whoa
oh what
these welcome
of being there of walking the streets of
the future is really going to be
breathtaking
your breathtaking
[Applause]
the cyberpunk trailers showed gorgeous
cities beautiful lighting really cutting
edge technology when it comes to the
rendering of the game itself people were
very excited to be immersed in this
gorgeous cyberpunk World they saw over 8
million pre-orders which is a
ridiculously large amount for any title
to sell let alone pre-sell when you saw
the stock price start to go up and up
and up and to the right you know pretty
pretty much in a straight line if you
just look at like the Polish stock
market like the wig index when CD
projekt stock was at its high it was the
largest stock in the in in the in the
index and that was around the time that
they announced that the game would be
coming in April of 2020. behind the
scenes people were pretty shocked that
they were saying April I I don't think a
single person who worked on that game
actually thought they had a chance of
coming out in April of 2020.
foreign
so in April of 2019 I published an
article for Kotaku about the making of a
game called Anthem which was a game from
BioWare that was disastrous in many ways
and the article kind of ran through why
that was and afterwards I started
hearing from other developers who had
stories to share that they said sounded
a whole lot like anthems the deadline is
unrealistic the direction keeps changing
things are floundering we're going
through a lot of problems
um this sounds exactly like what you
wrote about Anthem around that same time
perhaps coincidentally I heard from the
CEO of CD project grad who wanted to
reach out to me specifically to talk
about crunch
CD project red had a reputation for
crunch especially during the development
of Witcher 3. their management wanted
them to have a reputation for treating
workers well and not forcing them to go
through grunge so martinavinsky who's
the co-founder and co-ceo of CD projekt
Red came to me and said hey I want to
make a vow right now that we're not
going to force anybody the crutch that
people will not have to work mandatory
over time on this project
so reporting Bloomberg has conducted
interviews with more than 20 current and
former CD project staff most of whom
requested anonymity so as not to risk
their careers city project declined to
comment on the process or provide
interviews for this story
the company would end up delaying the
game three different times first pushing
from an April 2020 release to September
then November and once again to December
2020. in order to meet the deadline the
studio would scale down the size of
cyberpunk's main city as well as
canceling some features and while those
measures helped developers still said
they were under significant crunch
including one former audio programmer
who claimed to work up to 13 hours a day
five days a week and stating he had seen
friends who had lost their families over
this this was not a big secret in the
office that the game was not going to be
ready but a similar sort of thing
happened with The Witcher 3 and a
similar sort of thing happens with a lot
of games where they don't seem ready
until suddenly everything just clicks
some of the best games ever made like
were created through this process I
don't know that it's the most efficient
or the wisest way to make video games
but it's what a lot of people do I think
that management there has genuinely
tried to change it or at least said they
wanted to change yet but it has proven
very difficult
to change that when you make games in
this one specific way game studios some
of them see crunch as part of their core
culture that all of their games that
they've made under crunch have been
successful so it must be a core element
to the magic recipe for creating good
games and that's really not the case
we've run studies and seen that at eight
weeks of working 60 hours plus the
output of a professional is the same as
if they were working 40 hours a week so
chronic overwork
degrades how effective someone is to the
point where then it becomes negative and
overworking them is just getting you
less and less productivity and so these
guys the people at CD project having
made The Witcher 3 were kind of riding
on that high you could call it arrogance
or confidence or whatever you want to
call it of having made The Witcher 3 and
I think that like having a certain level
confidence can certainly be a good thing
but in this case it could also be
dangerous because it kind of blinded
them to the reality
um which was that this game wasn't going
to call us
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
cyberpunk was an ambitious project by
any standard but for CD projekt Red it
was also a very large departure from The
Witcher
cyberpunk was a Sci-Fi World rather than
a medieval fantasy instead of a third
person game that revolved around combat
with swords and shields cyberpunk was a
first person shooter making cyberpunk
would require CD project to invest in
new technology including its game engine
games have to have a lot of logic behind
them
when someone talks about developing a
game particularly in their own engine
they're not just talking about creating
art assets and setting up quests they're
talking about building the rendering
systems figuring out these shaders and
graphic systems and physics systems it's
a lot of low level work and a lot of
that low-level work prevents some
testing and progressing of the game
forward which is sort of like if you
were driving a train while someone else
was in front of you like laying down
tracks as you went you're like trying to
make a movie while someone else is
building the camera at the same time
it's very very difficult and makes
things go super slowly and makes things
go very inefficiently and just hampers
everything and that's actually why game
development Studios prefer open offices
it's so that the team can see what
everyone else is working on and have a
passive sense of the state of the game
and how it's going but in the final
months of development developers and
cyberpunk were mostly doing this
development from their homes across
Poland all malls restaurants clubs and
bars closing down with the ban on
Gatherings of more than 50 people
I think because of kovid there was a lot
of issues not just in terms of
development and the timing but also the
communication side of it and QA is a
huge part quality assurance it's a huge
part of game development that a lot of
people don't talk about QA testers help
Run the game through its Paces to figure
out any issues it may have then they
write report tickets and send it back to
developers to fix it's easy to
underestimate the amount of time it'll
take to fix a few bugs that you find
there's a little song that I appreciate
there's 99 little bugs on the ball 99
little bugs take one down patch it
around 117 bugs in the code making that
even more difficult was just how many
different platforms the game was coming
out for
due to the delays the game was
simultaneously coming out for PCs and
Google's new streaming service stadia as
well as the console systems that would
now include the Next Generation PS5 and
Xbox series X as well as the previous
generation of consoles the PS4 and Xbox
One and while the hardware and these
systems were in some cases seven years
old they represented a large Market of
console Gamers particularly in the west
that is really really complicated and
poor dating and dealing with like
optimization across the platforms can be
really really challenging and when you
are a company as CD projekt Red is that
primarily develops on PCS and is used to
making games for PCs sometimes not
everybody in the studio will be like uh
even bothering playing the console
versions as is what happened here and
what we saw with cyberbunk was a case
where the console versions the last gen
console versions were just a complete
mess and when management announced in
October that the game had gone gold
meaning it was ready to be pressed into
discs there were still major bugs being
discovered exhaustive programmers would
scramble to fix as many of these
problems as they could via a day one
patch and CD projekt did their best to
control which versions of the game would
be seen before the release date
so with a video game review process you
are sent first some guidelines
here's what uh reveal and what not to
reveal when the game launches what
spoilers are important and what aren't
and they give you these guidelines
alongside an NDA or some kind of embargo
when I read through the Embargo and the
restrictions
I realized just how restrictive it was
so reviews came out a few days before
the game came out and they seemed pretty
good
um but reviewers all cautioned that they
said hey CD project only let us have the
PC version
um they didn't let us have access to the
PS4 and Xbox One versions of the game
the thinking at CD project was maybe
okay we have a patch plan that maybe
reviewers didn't have access to like a
day one patch so we don't want them to
show footage of the game before it's
ready to go and maybe they thought hey
the console versions they're going to
get a patch like the day before it comes
out so so we don't want to talk about
that we don't want to show those
versions just yet but no matter what the
rationale was behind CD projekt doing
this ultimately it turned into
the true scope of the game's problems
being hidden
foreign on December 10th of 2020 the
game was released and it didn't take
long for the problems to become public
post softy
yeah I mean obviously the t-posing stuff
uh can can be kind of funny but when it
keeps happening it really starts to
break your immersion my car would spawn
where another car was
already at and so they would like
Collide and then both cars would explode
or something
there are a lot of like people's quests
ending unexpectedly or like AIS
appearing one one common one was that
um someone who was supposed to be just
like uh with you on one Mission like a
buddy with you on one Mission would just
follow you for the entire game and just
inexplicably they would just be around
with like with you one hilarious bug
that I discovered when I first loaded up
the game
um on launch day was there were tiny
trees covering every single thing in the
game I was playing through the prologue
and there were just little trees
everywhere I did try cyberpunk 2077 on
PlayStation 4 and
for me it's as good as unplayable with
that level of performance
there are segments where it runs at like
25 to 30 frames but then
there are segments where it's clear the
frame rates aren't like your 15s and 20s
and aiming with an analog stick while
frame rates are rising and dipping it's
simply impossible
The Experience on those last gen
consoles will be so bad that Sony would
take the unprecedented action of
removing the game from its digital
stores I mean the stock started selling
off little by little and then a lot by a
lot
um you know it kind of cascaded to a
point and then once we saw Sony turn off
the ability to buy the game and offer
refunds that was kind of the the the the
drop that the bottom fell out
yeah so
um uh about a few weeks after the game
came out
um the city projects co-founder and
co-ceo Martin novinsky came on a video
and he spoke for about five minutes and
tried to address Point by Point like
some of the things that people have been
talking about Please don't fault any of
our teams for what happened they all are
incredibly talented and hardworking
myself and the board are the final
decision makers and it was our call to
release the game it's just kind of
justifying their actions and apologizing
and and vowing that they would fix this
game and they wanted to regain people's
trusts etc etc
city project Redwood released three hot
fixes in December and two more patches
in the coming months in their apology
video CD projekt Red would also release
a road map for their future plans for
both their DLC content and future
patches although exactly when these
things would come was a little vague
it's to be seen what they do I mean I
think to save face they have to do what
they can to fix cyberpunk but how much
resources they dedicate to premium DLC
expansions to the online mode is still
kind of up in the air we have to see
what they say about that or do you kind
of just
do what you can stop the bleeding and
just move on to what you're for you know
at what point do you have to just say
we're going to nip this in the bud and
move on
um is is going to be a lot of focus for
a lot of investors in the next few
months
there's a lot of precedent in the video
game industry for Redemption stories for
video games coming out in a pretty bad
shape and then getting fixed patched
updated added to over time we've seen it
with no man's Sky we've seen it with
Destiny we've seen it with Final Fantasy
14 a lot of these online games one thing
that they could do is say anyone who
bought the game will get like the DLC
for free as an apology from us there are
a lot of things they could do I think to
win back the fans I think it's apparent
looking at the release of cyberpunk 2077
and the reception of it that Gamers
overall are much more tolerant about
pushback release deadlines and
understand that a game that is rushed or
built under crunch is less likely to
come out in the state that they would
like it to I make videos about these
companies and it's not because I want
them to fail it's because I want them to
get better I hope CD projekt looks at
everything that's happening and just
actually make some changes I'm gonna
quote Shigeru Miyamoto from Nintendo
he's like the father of Super Mario a
delayed game is eventually good a rush
game is never good and this is a company
that was not lacking for money they have
plenty of cash and so the decision to
not do so
um will go down in history is a very
poor one
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
jobs are scarce it's risky to be outside
and around others seems like there's
very few ways to make extra money during
a pandemic
so I guess I'll just hunker down and
binge social media until this all blows
over
wait
don't these people make money
how do these people make money
[Music]
streamers YouTubers twitch Stars how do
they make money is it a lot is it a lot
of work
I know I gotta ask somebody in the biz
and I got just the guy Austin John plays
is this is your full-time job now right
as of November of last year yes this was
always just kind of like a side thing
like any money that I made from doing my
videos and whatever else I never touched
that because I didn't really think of
that as being like real money and then
it started coming in more and more and
then it was like I hit my first day that
I broke a grand and I was like
this is actually gonna be money how did
the YouTube channel come to be when the
game Pokemon Sun and Moon came out for
the 3DS there was like things that I
learned about the game and then I I
wanted to just share that information
with people and at the time I didn't
have any way to capture a screen or
anything so I found like generic footage
and I kind of put it all together with
so much editing and that video got six
views and then two days later I made
another one and that one got 12 views
and then
I just started pumping out more and more
content and people were like this guy
knows what he's talking about it really
just started building on top of itself
and then it was like
my channel really focuses on tips and
tricks so I play a straight 18 hours and
I'll finish the game or get to about the
40 hour mark and then I'll make my first
video while I'm going through I have a
giant notepad and just scribbles
everywhere and I make these notes of
like the things that stumped me so I
know the things that may stump other
people uh what do you need to think
about if you're building your YouTube
channel one you need to do something
that you're passionate about not that
you like not that you think you're gonna
make money on something you're
passionate about the other thing is
something that other people are
passionate about it holds a special
place to them
and third is it needs to be something
that people are going to seek out
information on in order to enter into
the marketplace you either need to be
better than everyone else
you either need to be faster than
everyone else or you need to be more
accessible than everyone else
and you can't be more accessible because
it's already on the platform granted if
you understand how the algorithm Works
which is very similar to Google
analytics then yeah you can have a
little bit of a head start but if you're
not doing it faster if you're not doing
it better than everyone else then why
should anyone watch your Channel
so my income as a YouTuber kind of
breaks down to three different ways one
which is the bulk of it which is AD
Revenue whenever you go and you watch a
video and then there's an ad and then
you wait five seconds and you hit the
bottom right corner and then you go on
to the next video or a non-skippable ad
or
the video starts immediately you get the
little banner ads at the bottom or uh if
you scroll down from the video the first
thing that shows there is an ad those
are the four different types of ads that
can appear on every single YouTube video
and all of them pay a certain amount it
varies on lots of things like the
country of the person who posted the
country of the person who watches it the
time of year where you are in the
quarter if there's anything going on
with uh a reduction in ad Revenue like
great example covid-19 companies weren't
just spending as much on Advertising so
because of that CPM went down
uh CPM stands for click per thousand I'm
using the Roman numeral for a thousand
and that means that for every one
thousand views you get a certain amount
of money now on low ads when I first
started off my CPM was 30 cents so every
thousand views I made 30 cents but then
once I signed with an MCN and I started
making more quality content and more
engaging content some of my better
videos and certain times of the year I
can see cpms as high as 12 to 14 dollars
and there's a big fluctuation between
you know if I post a video when there's
no ads being spent like January and
February that's a reason a lot of your
favorite YouTubers and also TV shows
don't post new videos uh in that time of
year because ad rates are down why are
they going to make content then instead
you're recording and you're bulking up
for when ad revenue is higher the second
way that a YouTuber makes uh income is
support crowdfunding things like that
when I first started off patreon was
really the only option but then they
started rolling out supporters and
members for YouTube channels so whenever
I have a live stream you can click a
button and then you can become a member
and then you get a special icons next to
your name I believe they're called
badges or on any video you can hit the
join button and that helps support the
channel and then the third aspect to
that would be merch and for me my merch
has been somewhat basic in fact I'm
wearing one of my t-shirts from last
year right now you have to endure the
times that your first video gets six
views that you posted on Reddit and they
say shut up and then on Auto mod bans
you you have to go through that because
until you go through that and you
discover why you're doing it you're not
doing it for other people you're doing
it for yourself if you're not loving
what you do then it's not worth it
huh so make a Channel about something
that I'm passionate about oh sweet
I guess I can make the channel about
that
[Music]
now how do I grow an audience
how do I get popular
it's all about diversification right you
have to have a massive Twitter following
you have to have a massive Instagram
following you have to have a massive
YouTube following of course you have to
be on Twitch which is the key platform
but basically any way you can get in
front of your audience you can engage
with your audience
um is going to drive those clicks which
ultimately drives the advertiser Revenue
that you get back from all of these
platforms it's me and them playing video
games and talking in a funny manner over
them they're not just people who are
good at games they're actually people
who are good at online Engagement online
entertainment first and foremost yeah
right to remain stylish anything you
wear can and will be used against you in
the court of fashion the streamer is
either very very talented at the game
the best player in the game is generally
going to draw a crowd because people
like watching people who are very good
on the other hand they're either very
very good or funny
charismatic whatever it is on that side
oh no
you know it becomes more of a show where
they talk about other things outside of
the gaming world and gaming becomes
really just a backdrop and an excuse to
engage with that audience there were
those weird like Ronald McDonald like
straight to VHS movies you remember
those I'm personable I'm chatty I would
kind of you know when boring things were
happening in the game I would ramble on
about you know movies I'd watched or
books I'd read on you know or
conversations I'd had and stuff like
that and so I think being personable was
a big part of that it's not just getting
on and playing games it's getting on and
being an Entertainer you are putting on
a show all right now let me go ahead and
grab the samurai sword that every gym
has okay he's dead I have a larger
audience and and to have that audience I
think stay with you you have to bring
something extra you know you have to
find your Niche you have to find what
works and what connects with the
audience and what makes them laugh and
what makes them keep coming back that
you gotta make it a little more exciting
all right throwing a hanging Bishop have
everybody in suspense for a moment
I think the real most important thing is
is to just get used to being on camera
like in any sort of performance thing is
get used to talking on camera
um you know I was my first few videos
were terrible but because I sat down and
did it for six to eight hours a day I
just got used to talking and I got over
that uncomfortable hump if you go into
twitch purely with the expectation that
you're going to make money make a job
out of it have all this growth and it's
going to be great
you're probably going to burn out prior
to getting to that point because there's
very little payoff for a long time right
like multiple years generally before you
really start to see a payoff and so you
know those first few times you're
streaming nobody is there one person
shows up every 30 minutes says hi maybe
and leaves right like it's very uh
discouraging I think for a lot of people
and so you have to be there just loving
it you have to love talking to yourself
when nobody is around you have to love
just the game that you're playing all of
that stuff because it takes a while and
I think a majority of people burn out
prior to getting to the like profitable
point of it
foreign
there you have it my very own YouTube
twitch Discord and streaming channels
all ready to go live it's a veritable
social media ecosystem just on the verge
of thriving
so don't forget to smash like And
subscribe and visit my patreon for perks
also go to my merch page and one last
thing stay cool my friends
thank you
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
is a strategically important point on
the map of Pakistan it sits very close
to Iran actually on the very southern
coast it's about a 10 hour drive west of
Karachi but it's only about an hour
drive to Iran the area is extremely poor
it's very arid it doesn't have enough
water electricity has been very spotty
one of the most surprising things about
visiting guadar is the high degree of
security that is absolutely everywhere
there are armed guards that are required
to escort foreign visitors everywhere
you go because it is a contested region
because there have been militant attacks
in the past
despite all this gwara is a key part of
the china-pakistan economic Corridor
also known as cpec the crown jewel of
President XI jinping's Belton Road
initiative
we will leave norstone unturned in
ensuring that cpec and all the projects
under its umbrella are materialized in
time and in full
so far just one third of all cpec
projects have been completed in quada
none of them have been and the promised
improvements for local people like job
creation and better infrastructure have
not materialized
so what has China got to gain from
developing this seemingly obscure City
on the Pakistani Coast
we have seen this movie before an
outside power comes into Pakistan it
spends heavily on big infrastructure
projects China's not the first to do it
right after Pakistan became independent
in the late 1940s early 50s the U.S was
sending advisors into Pakistan to help
plants economy U.S was doing
infrastructure projects there too those
early projects helped the U.S gain
Pakistan as an ally against the Soviet
Union during the Cold War the U.S has
provided about 80 billion dollars in Aid
to Pakistan since its independence but
overall the result is disappointing
one of the recent attempts was in the
late 2000s as part of the U.S effort to
combat terrorism in Afghanistan the
number one item on that Aid package was
to build these high visibility
infrastructure projects so they're
they're literally projects that the
United States tried to do or Pakistan
proposed to the United States in the
2000s during that period that have
become belt and road projects
China is stepping into a gap which has
been left by retreating ambition from
the U.S
candy
the Belton Road initiative is China's
president XI jinping's signature foreign
policy initiative launched in 2013 it
comprises an Overland belt stretching
through China central Asia into Europe
and a maritime Road stretching around
southeast Asia through the India ocean
and up past East Africa so a benign way
of characterizing China's belt and Road
initiative would be infrastructure for
influence so when Xi Jinping announced
the Belton Road initiative shortly
afterwards China designated Pakistan as
its showcase Flagship project so the
China Pakistan economic quarter was
going to be the biggest and most
important showcase for the success of
the Belton Road
Pakistan is in great need of
infrastructure development they wanted
to create a railway a highway roads all
kinds of economic development that is
intended to help Pakistan and it's meant
to provide jobs 2.3 million jobs for
pakistanis it's meant to provide a 2.5
boost to GDP growth and China would gain
economically as well
cpec was intended to reduce oil and gas
roots from the Middle East by thousands
of miles a way to cut Overland into
western China instead of going around
southeast Asia by ship
projects in Pakistan also provide
Chinese state-owned companies with an
additional Market Chinese workers are
brought to Pakistan to build
infrastructure and then take wages home
cpec is also strategically significant
for China and Pakistan China wants to
strengthen this relationship to counter
their shared rival India
CPAC is both an instrument of Chinese
power as well as a test of Chinese power
if it succeeds China will be
demonstrating that it's able to do what
great Powers have not been able to do in
Pakistan including the United States
which is why guada is so important it's
in Pakistan's Balochistan Province an
area with serious electricity and water
shortages
the largestan province is actually
populated by people who are of Baloch
origin there are different ethnicity
they speak a different language from the
majority in power in in Islamabad and
they feel as the poorest province in
Pakistan they have not sufficiently
benefited from some of the economic
achievements that the rest of Pakistan
has had that area is quite contested by
The baluchistan Liberation Army the
people who feel that even Pakistani
people have encroached into their
territory so quite a number of people
are still staging attacks and they
attacked the biggest International Hotel
in guadar shot up the lobby and killed I
think five people
but this unsettled city is where the
china-pakistan economic Corridor is
supposed to lead to authorities plan to
develop gwada into an international Port
City
quad our Port has an interesting history
and an interesting location too it's
located in baluchistan it's about 120
kilometers from Iran Pakistan purchased
this territory from Oman I think in the
1950s and so for a long time Pakistan
has had on its agenda trying to develop
this area since the 70s it's wanted to
build a port in guadar actually approach
the United States in the 1970s and tried
to convince the Nixon Administration to
pay for report even offered Naval access
if the United States was willing to pay
for that
the U.S rejected Pakistan's offer
concerned that the port would not be
commercially viable and would cause
geopolitical tension but in the early
2000s a Chinese company was awarded the
contract to build the port and they
completed phase one of construction in
2006. the port was then managed by a
Singaporean government entity
in 2013 a Chinese Port operator took
over from the singaporeans
in 2015 China announced that it will
expand the port as part of the cpec
initiative but five years later little
has happened
when you look out at the Port you can
see it has only three births and all of
them were empty
and the only ship that was in the port
at the time was a Pakistan Naval frigate
and so it indicated to me that the port
is not particularly operational for
commercial purposes and a number of
analysts have talked about the Strategic
importance in a military sense if
eventually China were able to use the
port of guadar as a military base
you know no one would be surprised if
China did use it in that way I don't
think in the short term like it is set
up in Djibouti where it has a permanent
base I think it's more likely to use it
as almost like a sort of forward-based
resupply option
um something I can use when it wants to
other projects like building Pakistan's
largest airport in guada and two special
economic zones have been delayed a 19
kilometer Highway linking the port with
the macron Coastal Highway in
Balochistan is under construction too
most of the people who live there and
work there already are fishermen they
rely on access to the Sea the way that
the highway Express Highway from the
port was originally proposed would have
cut off their sea access and so that was
a real point of contention with the
community there have been some proposals
to allow them an underpass it's still a
little bit unclear how that is finally
going to be resolved even if those
projects are eventually built there are
serious questions about who will work
there
there is a problem with Manpower of
course in guadar it's a very small City
and so one proposal has been well we'll
just ship Chinese workers in from China
and build lots of fancy housing for them
the First chinese-built Community in
Pakistan a 500 million dollar
development spanning over 10 million
square feet with over 60 open spaces and
that kind of proposal is what makes a
lot of the Pakistani local people quite
upset
Aguada based journalist expressed
concerns to Bloomberg over projects like
this the journalists spoke anonymously
for fear of persecution from the
Pakistan government these projects are
creating jobs but they're not really
creating jobs for the local people of
guadal they're not against economic
Prosperity but they're against the
development that leaves them behind
Pakistan doesn't have the money to build
these projects it's gone to the IMF for
its 13th bailout since the 1980s by
engaging in cpec projects the government
of Pakistan has incurred more debts from
China not only posing challenges for
Pakistan but possibly the International
Community if Pakistan eventually
defaults on its debts
but cpec is still set to go on even if
most current projects haven't been
completed the two countries have
recently signed new projects worth 11
billion dollars Pakistan's prime
minister said the country's economic
future is linked with China
[Music]
it's hard to imagine how the
china-pakistan economic Corridor is
going to be the game changer that the
Pakistan government would like it to be
we're not seeing the economic growth or
benefit from the projects that were set
out we're supposed to have seen by now
we're not seeing the job creation
project delays accumulating debts
commercial viability these problems of
cpec are also typical of Belton Road
projects around the world
for China though it's never the narrow
accounting perspective that matters it's
the bigger strategic benefits as China's
dollars continue to flow as China's
concrete continues to pour China's
influence continues to increase
access the financial World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up on quick take
in August 2020 while Europe was on the
cusp of a devastating second wave of
covid-19 and the U.S was struggling to
find beds for its sickest patients with
the virus this was happening in Russia
communities
but the rest of the world wasn't so sure
a vaccine so quickly and from a country
notorious for propaganda and deception
the issue is not about the science it's
about the approach that was used by the
Russian government critics and observers
are now left wondering is the Kremlin
playing vaccine Politics as part of a
campaign to undercut Western powers and
their technology or is this a case of
solid signs being tainted by allegations
of Russian hacking poisonings and
interference in Democratic elections
then you may have heard this term
challenge trial come up the idea was
that by deliberately exposing people to
the virus you could help speed up the
development of a vaccine every day
sooner that you develop a vaccine saves
10 000 lives I would do whatever it took
to develop a vaccine one day sooner this
is the infamous trolley problem in
bioethics which is should you sacrifice
one person to save five five people we
are rolling the dice that something
terrible might happen to people in these
trials
all this and more on quick take
foreign
[Music]
while Europe was on the cusp of a
devastating second wave of covid-19 and
the U.S was struggling to find beds for
its sickest patients with the virus this
was happening in Russia
communities
but the rest of the world wasn't so sure
Russia has become the first country to
give regulatory approval to a covid-19
vaccine but there are Myriad questions
and concerns already a vaccine so
quickly and from a country notorious for
propaganda and deception
[Music]
the issue is not about the science of
the vaccine it's about the approach that
was used by the Russian government in
terms of approving and starting to use
the vaccine before the phase 3 clinical
trial data was in
starting to use the vaccine starting to
try to export the vaccine and like
launching this entire propaganda
campaign actually works against the
product
after first facing scrutiny on whether
Russia's vaccines actually work now the
question has become whether they can
meet worldwide demand
critics and observers are now left
wondering is the Kremlin playing vaccine
Politics as part of a campaign to
undercut Western powers and their
technology
or is this a case of solid signs being
tainted by allegations of Russian
hacking poisonings and interference in
Democratic elections
Russia is scrambling to bring covid-19
under control Russia is battling a surge
in covid cases the virus came late to
Russia but it is definitely here now
Russia reported its first covid-19 cases
in January in Siberia and Russia's Far
East
by July officials reported almost 840
000 cases and more than 30 000 excessive
deaths
Global Health experts however have
questioned the accuracy of Russia's data
deeming the number of covert related
fatalities too low given inflection
rates
Russia acted very swiftly to impose
restrictions it was one of the first
countries to enact a total ban on the
entry of Chinese citizens and by late
March it had imposed a shutdown of its
borders and a series of lockdowns across
the country
meanwhile in Moscow the gammalay
Research Institute of epidemiology and
microbiology named after pioneering
Russian vaccine researcher Nikolai
gamalea got to work
they called the project Sputnik V
[Music]
Sputnik V is a reference to a a very
important date in in Soviet history
which was the launch of the the world's
first satellite Sputnik in 1957 and that
marked the the start of the space race
between Soviet Union and the United
States and naming it after that it's
clear that Russia was positioning itself
as a player in energy or political
struggle the first artificial Earth
satellite a world stirring event
by May the gamalet Institute had already
started testing their vaccine on the
census director as well as key
scientific staff a move which seemed to
place Russia ahead of other countries in
the vaccine race The Institute supplied
vaccines for use against the Ebola
outbreak in Guinea in 2017 to 2018. the
covid-19 vaccine that they developed was
based on technology they had earlier
applied in an experimental inoculation
against the deadly Middle East
Respiratory Syndrome or or merse and
that's what allowed Russia to go ahead
relatively quickly in developing a
covid-19 vaccine yes
but on August 11 when President Putin
announced that Sputnik had been
registered as the world's first covid-19
vaccine it hadn't started vital phase 3
trials prompting worry among the
scientific community and mockery from
the Trump Administration
I was extraordinarily surprised to see
that announcement in August I'm not
surprised that they were working on it
not surprised they started the clinical
trials but very surprised and a little
bit disturbed to see them starting to
use it before they had the data for
putting it was clearly very important to
be first in the world to release and
approve of action
and so the entire State propaganda
apparatus worked over time to present
this as a huge victory for Russian
science for the Russian farming industry
and basically as as proof of Russian
superiority in in areas where the
country has long been written off
isn't it premature to for Russia to have
approved this vaccine before phase three
trials are substantially underway
you know not at all at first we were
criticized but then we saw that Britain
announced that they may follow the
issued usfda said that they may want to
register before phase three
the suspicion that this is a propaganda
to rather than actually a way to to
fight for the 19 was obviously there and
it was expectable that reaction the
Putin government has done a lot of ugly
things to earn the the suspicion and
distrust of especially Western Nation so
obviously there was a certain handicap
to overcome and that could not be done
with you know premature funfair It could
only be counteracted with scientific
proof and and scientific proof was
eventually delivered
on February 2nd in the esteemed medical
journal the Lancet vaccine experts
professors Polly boy and Ian Jones
reported that Sputnik V appeared safe
with an efficacy rate of 91.6 percent
this was really a chance for for Russia
to dispel a lot of the skepticism
surrounding the vaccine and you know
whether it was actually good at
combating covert 19.
I think it's fair to say that demand
increased as a result of that
breakthrough in Europe there has
definitely been a change of sentiment
there are shortages of the vaccine in
Europe so you know now the EU is is
looking at a request to approve the use
of Sputnik V in addition to that several
European countries France Germany Spain
and Italy may also manufacture it so
it's definitely fair to say that there
was a change of heart
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Sputnik is very similar to both the
AstraZeneca vaccine and the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine in that it's an
adenovirus vectored vaccine and what
that means is that they're using a
common cold virus to deliver a little
bit of the covet virus to your own cells
and sort of Tricks your cells into
making just a little bit of the covid
virus and with that little bit which is
the spike protein your body is able to
mount an immune response so you develop
T cells you develop antibodies that all
respond to covid-19 if you should get
infected in the future
Sputnik V is also double vectored which
means that it uses a slightly different
version of the vaccine in the second
dose so protection against covid-19
could last longer
I don't necessarily think that in terms
of the vaccine itself and how it works
in the body it exhibits any advantages
over the MRNA system now vaccines like
Sputnik like AstraZeneca and like the
Johnson Johnson vaccine that are all
adenovirus Vector vaccines are much more
stable in warmer temperatures and so
that makes this cool chain much easier
that means the storage and the
distribution is much easier and so all
of that is a real positive strength the
AstraZeneca and Johnson and Johnson
shots have in rare cases been connected
to blood clots Russian officials claim
that Sputnik though developed in the
same way hasn't caused similar side
effects
all of this combined with a relatively
low production cost of 10 a dose makes
Sputnik v a viable option for developing
countries that are struggling to either
obtain or distribute inoculations
but there are questions about how much
politics Will impact the vaccine's
distribution we do not do politics and
obviously vaccine is our effort to save
people and it should not be politicized
Russia clearly has been using the
vaccine to picnic v as a way to to
bolster its Global Ambitions in Latin
America for example Argentina has
already had deliveries of two and a half
million doses it it's ordered a total of
20 million Mexico is another big buyer
they've they've asked for 24 million
doses
Russia hasn't uh asked any countries to
pay a premium however it's not offering
any discounts for poorer countries so in
Latin America or Africa the price is the
same as uh anywhere else and that's
approximately ten dollars a shot and we
know that some Western manufacturers are
are providing uh discounts for for
developing countries
of a Russia's Farm industry wasn't
prepared for the level of demand for
Sputnik V the rdif Russia's Sovereign
wealth fund who are financing the
vaccine had to strike production deals
around the world to support the global
supply for Sputnik fee abroad
[Music]
there are definitely still problems in
ramping up production Russia's total
production of Sputnik the since the
pandemic started is less than the number
of
vaccine shots administered every two
weeks to the U.S population it is now
promising to to produce much larger
quantities particularly in India it has
a very ambitious Target of 700 million
two-dose sets which is hoping to get
manufactured outside Russia this year
closer to home there's been a lack of
enthusiasm for the vaccine with a recent
poll revealing that 62 percent of
respondents wouldn't take Sputnik fee
despite ordering mass inoculations in
January Putin himself didn't get
vaccinated until seven months after the
August announcement
the Kremlin said he was focusing on
other inoculations it was not made
public which of the Russian vaccines he
received
in a way that the traditional Russian
mistrust of authority has made it easier
for the government because the demand
for the vaccine is not as high as it
would have been elsewhere if Russia you
can get it if you want it uh but many
just don't want to and perhaps even
Putin's own slowness and getting
vaccinated is indicative of uh you know
how cautious Russians are about this
whole thing Russia has been hit
especially hard by the pandemic with at
least 250 000 epidemic link deaths
Russian officials said
but the country could now hold a
powerful weapon in the fight against the
virus
I think the Sputnik vaccine will be a
very powerful tool I think we still have
a few questions that need to be answered
I still think we want to see the the
final data at the end of May when the
phase three trial is due to end and all
of the safety data so yes a few small
bits of data that I would like to see
but I think the Sputnik vaccine will
absolutely be a very powerful tool in
the global vaccine campaign as well as
many other vaccines that are both being
developed right now or being used in
other countries we just need to combine
that sort of manufacturing and
distribution with that solid
clinical evaluation and I think that we
are doing that it's made a huge
difference to to Russia's image
definitely a a very good tool of soft
diplomacy which has shown that Russia
has a capacity to to play a an important
role in combating this pandemic
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
United Kingdom has given approval to a
trial that will expose healthy
volunteers to covert 19. infection is
guaranteed with a so-called challenge
trial challenge trials challenge trial
as the pandemic progressed over the last
year you may have heard this term
challenge trial come up the idea was
that by deliberately exposing people to
the virus you could help speed up the
development of a vaccine and it turns
out a lot of people were up for this you
know everybody feels terrible right now
here's something that may help the world
be a little bit better
um so I was like great that sounds good
to me um let me sign up right now
ultimately challenge trials did not end
up being used to develop the vaccines
that are now in circulation but now
researchers in the UK are turning to the
challenge method saying it will allow
them to test the long-term effectiveness
of the vaccines and learn more about the
disease overall it's restarted a
controversy in the scientific community
over the safety efficacy and morality of
the practice I spoke to some very smart
people on both sides of the argument in
an attempt to answer a question with big
implications for Humanity's future
okay so we're here to talk about human
challenge trials but I guess first let's
talk about typical vaccine trials how do
typical vaccine trials work yeah so once
a vaccine candidate has been studied in
animals and in the laboratory it moves
into human studies the idea is that once
you are vaccinated with either a placebo
or the actual candidate you're exposed
in society to the pathogen and we want
to see that most of the infections and
disease occurred in people with the
placebo to determine that the vaccine is
actually protective and efficacious
so with a human challenge study we
deliberately in fact uh humans human
volunteers and look at essentially what
happens to them you say I've got the
viral agent covid whatever it is and I'm
going to give it to people this is Art
Kaplan he's a researcher at NYU who's
pretty firmly in the Pro challenge trial
column well historically vaccines are
tested in large trials usually you're
talking 30 40 50 60 000 or more subjects
you could spend
six seven eight years trying to get data
challenge study basically is a way to
speed up the trial process you may be
able to get answers as quickly as
exposing 500 600 people maybe over a
period of six months to a year so our
human challenge trials new or have they
been done before
I've been challenged and not you
scientists have been doing them for
quite a long time decades looking at
various diseases malaria cholera
influenza are some of them well to read
did it as a matter of fact with his
malaria experiments in Cuba they
deliberately let mosquitoes bite them to
get malaria to test antidotes assumingly
again they don't want to kill you
although people have died in challenge
studies we have a tradition in space
Medicine of saying gee I wonder how long
people can survive extreme gravitational
forces let's put them in a centrifuge
until they pass out so there are many
areas of medicine Health Care even
Public Health where we do expose people
to risk deliberately in order to learn
[Music]
this is the infamous trolley problem in
bioethics which is should you sacrifice
one person to save five five people this
is Liza Dawson the chief of bioethics at
the Walter Reed Army Institute of
research she's not really opposed to
challenge trials but where covet is
concerned she's basically in the
anti-column one of the issues is that we
have less ability to predict what will
happen to people as a consequence of
covet infection something like 10 to 20
percent or depending on the numbers have
long-term consequences of covet
infection that's not to be sneezed at
and people of all ages seem to be
susceptible to longer term consequences
of covid we are rolling the dice that
something terrible might happen or
something you know fairly bad might
happen to people in these trials well I
do understand the critics and some of
their points of view you know it's never
easy to defend deliberately giving
someone something that makes them sick
that violates sort of a core Norm of
medical ethics Do no harm but I'm not
really buying into the uh it causes more
harm to do a challenge study it feels
psychologically different to give
somebody a disease as opposed to saying
gee I don't know how you got it maybe it
was on the subway here maybe you should
have worn a mask or maybe a new variant
appeared we may feel you know
psychologically we didn't do it nature
did it nonetheless at the cemetery they
don't care
you're relying on nature to infect you
but it's not like people aren't exposed
I'm not sure that that's significantly
morally better than just saying I'll
give you the disease and we'll get a
faster answer
and there are a lot of volunteers who
feel the same way the organization one
day sooner which advocates for people's
right to participate in challenge trials
says it's had almost 40 000 people
contact them offering to take part if
such a trial were to be conducted two of
those volunteers are Lena Jeweler a
recent graduate of Johns Hopkins and
Gabrielle kleinwalks a PhD student in
Colorado safe to say they're both in the
Pro column
So speaking personally why would you be
willing to be part of a challenge trial
I
person who does human subjects research
and a person who likes to participate in
human challenge research so one of the
cool things about being a student at
Hopkins is that you have access to
participate in this like really cool
research and I've always found that
fascinating
um you know just as a person to
participate to say okay I'm contributing
to this science that may you know help
someone else down the road and then the
challenge aspect of it I was really
swayed by this like argument of like we
can like this is so much more efficient
this is so much more effective I would
say the very first place my mind went
was so I'm Jewish and in our
philosophical traditions it said that to
save a single life it's as if you've
saved an entire world
in the argument for child trials the
original argument back in March
um it was estimated that developing a
vaccine every day sooner that you
develop a vaccine saves 10 000 lives
and I thought
that that's amazing I would do whatever
it took to develop a vaccine one day
sooner which is why why the organization
is called that we all know what it means
to donate your time we all know what it
means to donate your money right but
this was an opportunity I felt to to
donate Health to try to share some of my
health with others
so there are reasonable arguments on
either side of the ethics debate and a
lot of people are willing to take the
risk but some offer a different kind of
criticism of challenge trials that they
wouldn't actually accomplish their goal
of speeding up vaccine development
that's the big beef put forward by
Charles Vare a Canadian bioethicist
he says the current UK study is the
perfect example of just how long
challenge trials can take what they're
doing so they've spent a number of
months developing the challenge strain
so making sure they've got a stable
strain where they haven't introduced
mutations through the manufacturing
process the second step is what they're
just embarking on now it's actually
figuring out the protocol for how
they're going to administer this virus
and so you're just beginning that
process now with incremental steps of
increasing dose of virus each of those
steps is going to take at least a month
and so we're many months away from them
at the point where they can even test
test vaccine The Advocates of challenge
Studies by and large haven't talked
about all this Preparatory work that
needs to be done even from the first
article that was published about this
they sort of talked as if you know sort
of next week we could just start doing
this right you just pump our room full
of covid-19 and then yeah everybody
right and of course these studies are
are much more uh complicated uh than
that and then there's the fact that we
got the current slate of covid-19
vaccines in record time without using
challenge trials the reason why we got a
vaccine so quickly was because of a
decade's worth of work on related
coronaviruses that cause SARS and that
caused MERS and I think we had the
Genome of Asar as cov2 the the novel
coronavirus published on January 10th I
think of 2020 three days later we had
our first uh candidate vaccine 63 days
later That vaccine was tested for the
first time in human beings by September
of last year we had six large phase
three trials planning to involve 280
000 people the the Monumental size of
the achievement here it would be
difficult to overstate well that's
traditional vaccine development with new
technology and it just highlights my
point the challenge studies are just are
just the wrong technology for rapidly
moving pandemic
but some still see challenge trials
playing a crucial role in the pandemic
ironically precisely because we now have
working vaccines as soon as things start
to look very promising it we basically
are in a situation where those people
who are in a large-scale trial let's
just use covid are going to start to say
wait a minute I don't want to be in the
placebo group anymore I want to drop out
and you can't finish the study ethically
you've got to let those people know
you're in the placebo group you can be
pretty certain that nearly everybody
will drop out because
you're running the placebo group are
very likely so the
underway now of covid vaccines are
falling apart because people are
dropping out of them left and right and
so we're not going to get answers that
we might want to things like how long
does this vaccine last in terms of
protection or do we know whether it's
protecting us against new variants of
the virus that appeared some also see
challenge trials as a path to developing
new vaccines that improve on the
existing ones obviously at this point
we've got approved vaccines in the U.S
and and maybe eight or nine total
globally but there's still a lot of
benefit to these sorts of Trials we can
expand the total pool of how many
different types of vaccines we have
available and that's important because a
lot of the vaccine candidates we have
now like the MRNA vaccines they're hard
to transport they take two doses all of
these things that if we continue to try
new vaccines we can find better vaccines
that are easier to distribute and that
has a lot of equity implication we can
get those to rural areas different
countries with less infrastructure so so
that's kind of like the big draw here
predicting the future is more of an art
than a science especially when it comes
to Global crises almost no one would
have guessed that we'd have several
working vaccines for a coronavirus
within a year so it's impossible to say
exactly what role challenge trials will
play moving forward but if there's
anything that we've learned from the
pandemic it's that the question of which
path is the more ethical one often
doesn't have an obvious answer
the other thing about challenge trials
I'll say because I don't want to
dismissive I'm not trying to dismiss
their importance is
if we get to a safer way to do challenge
trials then I think then I'm all in
favor of using them once they're safer
communities broadly would need to
understand what that's about and and
basically endorse it which is part of
the recommendations from The Who and
others but if if they're safer such that
we're not asking people to take those
risks I think they could be a really
important tool in the toolbox and just
as we do them now in malaria trials
they're a tool in the toolbox but
they're not the whole story
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring just to see what's
moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
1995 Catalan Caraco had hit a low point
a biochemist at the University of
Pennsylvania she devoted her entire
career to Turning mRNA one of the most
important building blocks of life into a
whole new field of medicine but it just
wasn't happening
everybody argued that the RNA is so
transient and degrade and it will never
be it never be a medicine I knew that it
can be used for everything and you know
kind of a Cassandra feeling that I can
see the future and nobody believes me
caricos Grant applications were rejected
she was demoted endured a cancer scare
but she stuck with it
spent weekends and holidays during
research and experiments and in 2005
carrico and her colleague Drew Weissman
published a breakthrough study
confirming the therapeutic use of mRNA
research which would underpin the
success of mRNA covert vaccines today
when the first covid-19 vaccine was
approved I was extremely excited I
thought it was a changed moment for mRNA
what we've been seeing in animals was
real it works in people and that's the
most important thing
mRNA has gone from a rejected idea to a
powerful weapon helping to end the
pandemic and applications of this
technology could provide a cure for
diseases Beyond covert
[Music]
messenger RNA or mRNA is a genetic
material that copies instructions from
our DNA
our cells use these instructions to make
proteins which carry out different
functions in the human body mrnas are
responsible for everything our body does
from breathing air to eating food to
walking to sleeping to thinking covert
vaccines from Pfizer biotech and madana
are based on this mRNA mechanism
unlike traditional vaccines using dead
or weakened viruses mRNA vaccines use
the genetic information of the virus
scientists make an mRNA that codes for
the spike protein of SARS cov2 the virus
that caused covert 19.
then the MRNA is put inside a lipid
coating and injected into the human body
the cell reads the MRNA and starts to
make harmless Spike proteins of its own
which triggers the immune system to
produce antibodies against the virus
the way that mRNA vaccines work are
similar to really all vaccines
what they're doing is they're presenting
a protein or proteins from a pathogen
and they're causing our bodies to make
an immune response against those
proteins or protein when you make a an
inactivated virus vaccine you have to
isolate the virus you have to grow it up
in eggs you have to figure out how to
grow it in eggs you have to purify it
and activate it and formulate it
with mRNA you only need the sequence you
don't need the virus so it's a very
simple vaccine to make
this means that making mRNA vaccines is
faster than making traditional ones
but the journey for mRNA to break into
mainstream medicine has been long and
challenging
mRNA was first discovered in 1961 but it
wasn't until 1984 that scientists were
able to recreate it in the lab
in the 1990s a scientist knew more about
the makeup of human DNA gene therapy
became popular inserting a gene into a
patient's cells to treat or prevent
disease
but most researchers gave little thought
to using mRNA as a vaccine or a drug
despite its close relationship with DNA
well I argued that the messenger RNA is
more like a conventional drug you can
apply
and then if you see beneficial effect
you can reapply and then the healing is
done and other than a gene therapy where
you are delivering the Gene and and you
cannot control but many rejected caracos
idea arguing mRNA therapies didn't look
feasible
the immune system is hyper Vigilant
against foreign RNA entering the body
and so the injected lab made RNA caused
inflammation which destroyed it before
it could start to trigger an immune
response and even worse that
inflammation could be life-threatening
in 1997 carico met Drew Weissman a
respected immunologist and they started
to collaborate that the big Discovery
was we figured out by modifying the
nucleoside so RNA has four letters that
code for a protein each letter is a
nucleoside or a base
we modified those bases
and that reduced and got rid of the
inflammation
when we altered you reading and we
how do we really we found that not only
we have RNA which is not only monogenic
but we had very high level of protein
production the amount of protein made
from the RNA increases about a thousand
fold
you get rid of inflammation and you
increase potency in the same step so it
was like um a dream come through they
published the key research and filed a
patent which was later licensed to
moderna and biotech the companies making
mRNA covert vaccines today
carico also started to work for biotech
in 2013.
but there was another hurdle how to
deliver mRNA to targeted cells
mRNA is notoriously fragile and enzymes
in the human body can break it down so
you really need to have it protected
from the enzymes and other kinds of
things in the body you could call them
the bad guy so to speak and if you don't
then the therapy won't work at all it
would be non-existent as early as the
1970s chemical engineer Robert Langer
and his colleague Judah folkman proved
that it's possible to deliver molecules
like RNA inside tiny particles without
destroying them
the nanoparticles langa used were made
of polymers not lipids as used in
today's mRNA covert vaccines
so we were trying to put DNA and RNA
into tiny particles and deliver them I I
failed the first 200 times when I did it
and by the way that was also widely
criticized so I got my first nine grants
turned down I couldn't get a job and uh
you know a faculty job and a chemical
engineering department which was my area
but today Langer is a renowned scientist
with over 900 issue patents in 2010 he
co-founded moderna and still sits on its
board
after Decades of development the main
biological roadblocks were cleared but
mRNA technology had never been used
outside of clinical trials until
recently
in the last few minutes we've heard that
the first coronavirus vaccine has been
approved for use in the UK this has been
manufactured by the U.S pharmaceutical
company Pfizer and it's partner biontech
and here is the first person in line to
get it
thank you
in the following months mRNA vaccines
from both Pfizer biotech and moderna
were cleared in multiple countries
taking less than a year from the lab
into people's arms these are the fastest
vaccines that have ever been developed
both with a 95 efficacy rate
but some people are concerned that these
vaccines are hastily made
the speed of making the vaccine the the
10 months that it took there's very good
reasons that people need to understand
why that happened it was an emergency it
was a pandemic all of the clinical
trials were done at the same time all of
the testing was done together no corners
were cut there was no safety issues that
were ignored everything was done exactly
the same as every other vaccine in
December 2020 carico and Wiseman were
given the covert vaccines they had
contributed to
and the people were waiting the
healthcare workers in the in line there
to get their vaccine and you know they
clapped and then then I cried
about 3.2 billion doses of mRNA covert
vaccines are expected to be given in
2021
and now mRNA may also be used to help
fight future pandemics and diseases that
current medicines struggle to treat the
MRNA is just an instruction
for the cell to make the protein we can
Target in the messenger RNA to certain
orders certain cell types bone marrow
and and then can perform different kind
of treatment there are many different
applications for messenger RNA I mean
and you know at moderna they're working
on heart disease they're working on
personalized cancer vaccines they're
working on rare diseases
I think the next big act for RNA are
probably going to be more vaccines
last summer we started working on a pan
coronavirus vaccine so there have been
three coronavirus epidemics and
pandemics in the past 20 years
you have to assume there's going to be
more can we make a vaccine that prevents
against all of those bat coronaviruses
that have the potential to infect people
and start another epidemic or pandemic I
think the the pan influenza and pan
coronavirus are going to be the most
exciting RNA vaccines to come out in the
future Mi has been proven now now as a
really impressive and Powerful new
technology and and the application of
mRNA course of course very straight
approach is to develop mRNA vaccines
against other infectious diseases and we
are already doing that yeah we have
started that early on for developing
influenza based mRNA vaccines they are
developing Mi vaccines against
tuberculosis against HIV
biotech has also been studying the
technology in cancer for two decades and
has a cancer vaccine in Phase 2 clinical
trials they're hoping the cancer field
might see its first messenger RNA drug
approvals in two or three years
there's no guarantee that other mRNA
vaccines and drugs will succeed like
they have with covert 19. but carico
remains undaunted by the challenge
that's the most important thing to
accomplish something and meanwhile to be
happy as long as I was in the lab I had
fun it is just such a joy even if things
didn't work out how I expected
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're going to see the future
not everyone is trying to win a
popularity contest case in point this
guy I don't think that popularity is
his air time so to speak is only a tool
to achieve what his greatest aspiration
is which is to have a positive impact in
the world you should look at you know
what was your goal how are you trying to
uplift nutrition and survival and
literacy he is influential a because of
his vast fortune and the way he made it
by creating a new segment of the
computer Market but also that he's since
then chosen to deploy the money he's
made to try to completely alter the
landscape of World Health this year his
net worth reached as high as a hundred
twenty billion dollars these two have
donated more money to charitable causes
than anyone ever he's a
multi-dimensional uh individual he has
great depths in so many different areas
I guess you you call them a polymath
[Music]
William Henry Gates III was born in
Seattle Washington in 1955. he was a
terrible child there Bill senior gave a
whole interview to the Wall Street
Journal about just how difficult he was
how much trouble he gave his mother just
you know yelling screaming Tantrums
things like that at the ripe age of 13
the problem child wrote his first
software program a tic-tac-toe game on
the teletype Model 33 ASR teleprinter
eight years later he dropped out of
Harvard to start a computer software
company with his best friend Paul Allen
called Microsoft
in co-founding Microsoft what Bill Gates
and Paul Allen did was essentially
create the personal computer software
Market that's since then been worth
hundreds of billions of dollars
the Jeff rakes he's known bill for quite
some time now I was at Microsoft from
1981 to 2008 and Bill was completely
committed to the vision that we could
help put a computer on every desk and in
every home running great software and
that's the impact that he wanted to have
and he was completely focused in on that
now such determination does require a
strong personality and it's safe to say
that his subordinates could probably
relate to his parents at that point oh
he was very tough manager people were
had these sort of terrifying Bill Gates
reviews of their products and features
and if you didn't like what you said he
would uh you know he was known for
responding with the word well that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
but the good news is you won't hold the
record for long
at Seattle's Bill Gates with 4.2 billion
dollars is second richest person in the
country what is this it's Microsoft
Excel now hold still I'm about to
perform a miracle my spreadsheet doesn't
do that
Microsoft became such a juggernaut that
the following decade they were sued for
being a monopoly because if you look at
that point in the year 2000 Microsoft is
in serious Anti-Trust trouble and with
the view of Bill at that time was
terrible and people viewed him as a
sharp elbowed monopolist essentially
not that he cared about what the world
thought of him but it was around this
time that bill decided to start
listening to his parents
I do remember in the early days of
Microsoft his mother pressing young Bill
to get involved with the United Way and
philanthropy and Bill's response was you
know Mom I'm you know I'm trying to
build this company I I don't really have
time for that
and I think over time what he learned is
in the same way that he could leverage
his intellectual energy on behalf of
Microsoft he could do it on behalf of of
philanthropy while in the midst of this
antitrust suit bill and his wife Melinda
donated 16 billion dollars worth of
stock to charity in 1999. the following
year he poured 5.1 billion dollars in
cash to create the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation it
instead of saved lives and um you know
increased uh immunizations in the
developing world that's much more the
popular view of a bill at this point
that sort of philanthropist and not the
monopolist
so you can avoid lots of diseases if
you've been properly vaccinated today
the foundation is the world's largest
charity its fingerprint is on almost
every Global Health Initiative of the
last 20 years and has spent over 40
billion dollars on global development
and public health programs yes they
deploy Financial Resources but they also
use their voice the networks of
influence and support that they have so
in many ways it represents one of the
key Concepts that we learned in software
it's about Leverage What Bill wants what
Melinda wants with the foundation is to
be able to make those financial
investments and leverage them to have
the greatest possible impact by using
this approach to philanthropy the
foundation provided seed money to the
global fund to fight AIDS tuberculosis
and malaria their implementation of
immunizations in the developing world
has contributed to a dramatic drop in
the overall child mortality rate since
1990. Bill also made it his personal
mission to eradicate polio from the
planet something he has come very close
to achieving
then of course there's Bill's noblest
pursuit of all I want to talk to you
today
about toilets many people would say well
well why get involved in in toilets and
how does that matter but that you know
actually kind of diving into that
explains a bit about how Bill thinks
about things but if you want to reduce
the disease burden you're going to have
to improve sanitation if you're going to
improve sanitation you're going to have
to invent a new way to go about it one
that doesn't require all of the water
that we use today so it's a great
example of how he thinks in terms of the
broader systems and looks for
technological innovations that can
really make a a difference
this push to improve sanitation
worldwide has led to the invention of
the omniprocessor a low-cost human waste
treatment plant where the beta version
currently in use in Dakar Senegal I am
very impressed with this solution we're
seeing here and it generates electricity
it generates clean water in the area of
climate change Gates has embraced the
often unpopular solution of nuclear
energy as an alternative to fossil fuels
the energy has to come from somewhere
you're giving up all coal all natural
gas all oil
that is a good example of both the fact
that he isn't concerned about public
opinion or popularity but but grounded
in what he believes to be the data and
the fact
a Gates company called Terra power was
very close to building the world's first
nuclear reactor fueled by actual nuclear
waste in China but progress was stopped
in its tracks when Trump launched a
trade war against China in 2018.
no sooner was this Vision put on hold
then did Gates have a more urgent
calling this is going to be era defining
and no one was in a better place to say
I told you so the most urgent invention
in the world right now
is a vaccine that prevents you from
getting covered 19. the fact that he
areas makes him unique in being able to
take on the current pandemic he has now
spent 20 years learning about funding
programs talking to Leading researchers
on things like viruses things like
vaccines some of the programs in the
Seattle area including the Seattle flu
study that caught some of the first
coveted cases here are things that have
been funded out of the foundation so far
Gates has chipped in a total of 300
million dollars in counting in the fight
against coronavirus they're focused on
detection isolation and treatment of the
virus and finding a vaccine
this chapter in Bill's life has yet to
be written and could have the highest
Stakes he's had to face yet his
intellectual intensity sometimes carries
over to Big expectations but at the end
of the day the person he's tough Assad
is himself if he doesn't figure out
something that he thinks he shouldn't
figure it out he'll be disappointed in
himself it drives him it motivates him
it gives him a sense of urgency to
really make a difference and I think
that's one of his greatest attributes
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on quick take
the hyperloop for years we've been
seeing these futuristic utopian
renderings of some cross between a
spaceship and a monorail
but lately the hyperloop is becoming
much more real companies all around the
world have been developing and testing
the technology needed to propel
passengers at speeds of over 1 000
kilometers per hour but for many speed
is only the first step to unlocking the
full transformational effects of a new
mode of transportation
foreign
only about 500 human beings have ever
left the bounds of Earth's atmosphere
but thanks to a set of ambitious private
companies betting on the promise of
space tourism that long-awaited future
could be here sooner than we think
technology had gotten to a point where a
private sector was going to make a
business out of this there are multiple
companies that want to get to where they
fly people into space the first time
people are going up into space and not
sent there by superpower like the United
States or Russia or China well that's
like really significant
[Music]
all this and more on quick take
there's a good chance you've heard the
name by now this is the hyperloop system
it can take people hundreds of miles and
minutes the hyperloop a series of tubes
that would transport people in Pods at
ultra high speeds over long distances
there's a remarkable new form of
transportation that can whisk people
from City to city in a Flash 29 minutes
from New York to DC 30 minutes from LA
to San Francisco
for years we've been seeing these
futuristic utopian renderings of some
cross between a spaceship and a monorail
but lately the hyperloop is becoming
much more real
it was surreal to be even sitting inside
a hyperloop and just even more
incredible to actually be like riding
down a track in something that was
nothing more than a crazy idea six years
before
companies all around the world have been
developing and testing the technology
needed to propel passengers at speeds of
over 1 000 kilometers per hour
but for many speed is only the first
step to unlocking the full
transformational effects of a new mode
of transportation fast is what we just
take for granted in the hyperloop world
it's the network effects that really
deliver the benefit and that opens up a
completely different scale of Economic
Opportunity
[Music]
we've got Planes Trains Automobiles and
boats or getting around Earth
but what if there was a fifth mode and
uh I have a name for it name for it
which is called the hyperloop the
hyperloop hyperloop yeah
in 2013 while Riding High on the growing
success of Tesla and SpaceX entrepreneur
Elon Musk released a white paper
outlining the basic framework of the
technology he called hyperloop the basic
idea goes a little something like this
tube reduces the air pressure to a near
vacuum-like environment a hyperloop pod
is then suspended in the tube usually by
magnetic levitation the whole pod can
then be propelled forward because
there's no traditional friction sources
like air resistance or rolling friction
that would push back against the Pod the
hyperloop is able to move at incredibly
high speeds and do so fairly efficiently
foreign despite its futuristic name
however the general concept behind
hyperloop is actually pretty old
in fact New York City's first attempt at
an underground public transit system in
the 1870s was based on a similar
principle the pneumatic transit system
was short-lived however only stretching
one block and Topping out at a rather
leisurely 10 miles per hour
while Elon would make some 21st century
improvements to this concept and bestow
a very 21st century name he wouldn't end
up pursuing the technology itself and
instead electing to focus his efforts on
something a little bit deeper literally
digging the requisite tunnels via his
boring company
it would take another billionaire
industrialist who dabbles in space
flight
no way not that one a yeah that's the
one after Richard Branson would make a
large investment in the company
hyperloop 1 it would be renamed to
Virgin hyperloop what we've always been
trying to do as a company is show that
this technology could work that it could
be made safe and that ultimately it's
something that's happening in the next
couple of years not the next 20 years
[Music]
Josh geigel is the co-founder and CEO of
Virgin hyperloop
familiar Tech startup story he's seen
the project go from a garage to a
large-scale testing facility outside of
Las Vegas so we started building the
first kind of hyperloop system in 2016
we've done a lot of work about a 500
test that we've done on that over the
last five years and what we realized
that we need to do is take that
technology show that it can be
commercial so drive the cost down
improve the efficiency improve the
performance but the key thing is you
know is actually making it approachable
and safe for individuals
in order to do that Josh along with
virgin's head of Passenger experience
Sarah Lucian bravely volunteered to take
the inaugural ride what her and I were
realizing is like we're the first two
people sitting in a hyper Loop the only
type of people that have gone through
this environment are in space suits and
there we are in just like normal clothes
because of the system the safety of what
we designed three two one launch and
then once we started going uh he felt a
bit of acceleration we accelerated a
little bit harder than we would in
commercial be like a sports car
yeah we got to about 108 miles an hour
on that test and it's a short run it's
about 500 yards or so and came to a stop
the test lasting only about 20 seconds
and covering only a quarter of a mile at
just over 100 miles per hour is a long
way away from a true functioning
hyperloop but as for Optics it's a
crucial step for the future of funding
the number one question we got from
investors or from Project proponents or
just people in general was like is a
hyperloop safe and what better way to
show something is safe than by actually
getting people on it
investors and governments that would
likely be fronting some of the
construction costs for an unproven
technology it's no easy task
first and foremost is the question of
safety most people don't know how an
airplane works but yet they get on an
airplane they get on an airplane because
you know it's faster than driving and
most importantly they've probably gotten
off of one before they've seen someone
get off of one before
and so what we set out to do was
actually show that hyperloop could be
safe with two normal people not
astronauts not Adrenaline Junkies or
test pilots or anything like that two
normal people getting on a hyperloop and
then most importantly those two people
getting off
but beyond safety concerns constructing
hyperloops will undoubtedly require a
significant capital investment to the
estimated tune of around 60 million US
dollars per kilometer of track so a
track from San Francisco to Los Angeles
for example is likely to come with a
price tag over 10 billion dollars and
before large governments are willing to
come in and front those costs investors
who are funding hyperloop development
must accept it as a long-term mixture of
technology and infrastructure investing
investors that are used to short returns
because you're developing apps or
something to that effect you know those
aren't the investors that really get
excited about hyperloop what you start
to see is the people that are looking at
platform Technologies right so this idea
that because this Smartphone existed
Uber could exist right so who are like
the Vanderbilts of this century and
that's the part where you're going to
get a lot more no's than yeses but
there's people that have the ability
that the fortitude to stick it out to
see the game-changing platform here
those are the people that we're looking
for and since we've done that passenger
test there has been a lot of interest
that's really oh this is a lot sooner
than I thought
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
envisioning the Ripple effects of what
hyperloop could achieve though is fairly
challenging at this stage of development
it's fast yes but for point-to-point
travel traditional maglev trains can
move pretty fast as well
and outside of China South Korea and
Japan even those haven't seen much
adoption elsewhere due to the high costs
and questionable profitability
the Shanghai line in China for example
loses around 100 million dollars every
year
hyperloop companies however believe they
can offer something different than
traditional railway lines
my name is Alan James
and as far as I know I'm the only guy on
the planet who's written the government
level business case for
300 kmh conventional High-Speed Rail 500
kmh maglev and 1000 kmh hyperloop
[Music]
it's fundamentally about moving people
from where they are to where they want
to go when they want to make those
Journeys and doing it in much smaller
numbers so pod designs for hyperloop
range from 12 to 28 seats typically why
are they small it's because small
enables the network to operate flexibly
and a great example of that is the
East-West strategic route across the
north of England from Liverpool to
Manchester to Leeds so to get from
Liverpool via Manchester to Leeds by
train is just short of two hours today
it'll probably take you two hours
driving as well in average traffic
conditions net result is those three
city regions remain three separate
entities Liverpool Manchester Leeds
there's very little commuting traffic
between those urban areas
hyperloop absolutely changes that from
the ground up
Liverpool to Manchester is a five or six
minute Journey Manchester to Leeds is
also a five or six minute Journey what
that effectively does is create a single
super City economy
in this Vision the hyperloop acts a
little more like a highway where pods
have fixed destinations and don't need
to stop along the way meaning you can
travel in a hyperloop network from say
Liverpool to Leeds while the Pod behind
you travels from Liverpool to Manchester
with that Metro hyperloop network is
connected to other networks from the
same location you could travel from
Liverpool to Paris or Liverpool to
Amsterdam all without making a single
stop for passengers for business
for leisure that is utterly
transformational
for high value Freight and Logistics
it's equally transformational
but critically if you do a hyperloop
network at scale
you begin to deliver
massively significant carbon savings too
a multi-regional hyperloop network could
become a replacement for both short haul
passenger and cargo flights and
traditional ground transportation both
of which are significant carbon
producers
one hyperloop connected Distribution Hub
perhaps at an airport that is
predominantly used for International Air
Freight replacing maybe 10 12 15
distributed Road hubs it takes a lot of
polluting and inefficient truck haulage
off the roads that itself means roads
gain extra capacity
hyperloops will still need to use
electricity to both move pods and
maintain the near vacuum environment in
the tube proponents of the technology
believe that this can be done by using
renewable sources including a
combination of solar panels and Battery
Technology that could be used along the
hyperloop itself
but even with all multipliers of time
and carbon emission savings that a
hyperloop network May provide the
investment Capital required to actually
build such a network becomes even more
economically and politically daunting
committing doesn't mean spending
billions on day one
committing means
how do we phase it
[Music]
one company in the Netherlands is
working to develop that technology and
perhaps more importantly the
International Coalition needed to make
the hyperloop network a reality
[Music]
so we are here in Europe's first
full-scale high blood test facility
where we can already prove every
conceptual technology of the hyperloop
this is Tim hauter a co-founder and CEO
of heart hyperloop headquartered in the
city of delft
and while this testing tube might not
seem as large as others inside is a key
technology to create the on and off ramp
type infrastructure of a hyperloop
network that is a lane switch that's
something we can already test here you
can actually see it here
then the track is diverging from one
track into two that makes it possible to
eventually split up the iCloud track in
two sections and in that sense you can
create a complete High Loop network but
in the end will make it possible to
travel for example over overhaula
continent and take Europe for example
with the same ease as you can now travel
with the metro in a city
the nice thing about this magnetic
levitation system that we've developed
is that there's absolutely zero moving
components in the track
so for example if you have to do a lane
switch
all you do is that the tube basically
splits up
and statically the tracks also split up
and whenever the vehicle enters a switch
it either pulls itself to the right with
its magnets or it pulls itself to the
left with its magnets
Lane switching on traditional rail
requires the physical movement of the
rail
even modern magnetic levitation tracks
use Lane switching techniques in order
to transfer trains from one track to
another and this is a very crucial
element because this is the thing that
limits the capacity and in the end the
usefulness of the real Network because
the moment that a track is switching
that means that at that moment you are
creating an unsafe environment for the
trains behind it so you need a lot of
space between Trains being a hyperloop
because you have no moving components in
the track all the vehicles can be much
closer to each other you can achieve a
very high frequency and basically have
vehicles moving and merging in and out
of the network very much like a highway
for now though Hart's physical testing
has been limited by the size of their
tube because the test track is only 30
meters long they haven't tested this
Lane switch at speeds greater than 20
kilometers per hour however the company
is working to build a new test site
where it plans to increase that testing
speed to 300 kilometers per hour we are
now in a phase where we have proven most
of the most important Technologies in
The Test Facilities that we already have
and we have also demonstrated the
viability and the feasibility of a
network if you look at all the
subsystems that it consists of most of
those are proven systems already
demonstrated in lab conditions so we
don't really believe that the technology
itself is going to be the biggest
challenge
because for all hyperloop companies out
there actually building a hyperloop
system requires more than just a good
product we're talking about the safety
aspects we're talking about integration
into the environment we're talking about
the social aspects do people feel
comfortable traveling in such a system
so it's about all these different
aspects and the complexity is really
getting all the different stakeholders
that are relevant and that the needs to
contribute to bring this to Market
to get them all
following the same roadmap
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
in order to help build this Coalition of
private and public interest in hyperloop
development heart in 2018 partnered with
other hyperlib companies from Europe and
Canada the goal was to Define establish
and standardize the framework to
regulate hyperloop systems right now we
are working with all the hyperloop
developers together in setting up the
first let's say a structure for the for
starting the standards drafting one of
the most important goals for heart is
interoperability which is essentially
making sure the different systems can
communicate with each other
interoperability is so important because
what we want to achieve is actually have
this seamless travel experience so you
don't want to end up for example going
from Madrid to Paris and then switching
because you need to use a different
technology to get for example to
Amsterdam the idea being that as
companies around Europe create the first
commercial hyperloop tracks between
individual cities one day those can all
be connected to a larger Network
everyone that believes that hyperloop is
a future transport system also realizes
that there is a need to have this
network because that's where hyperloop
thrives hyperloop is is such a huge
project it's definitely not something
that that you can do in your own or as a
single company so you need to do it with
a lot of other companies you need to
have the governments I think in that
sense the biggest challenge that we've
encountered is to really get all the
required parties together to take the
steps in development and in commercial
implementation
foreign
[Music]
's Next plan is to build the European
hyperloop Center an open testing
facility which will include a 2.6
kilometer test track and the company
hopes to test travel speeds there at up
to 700 kilometers per hour
virgin hyperloop is also racing to
construct the first commercial hyperloop
route with projects in various states of
development in India Saudi Arabia and
the United States
recently the company announced plans to
build a hyperloop certification Center
in West Virginia which will include a
six mile long test track
proving the technology here will be
crucial if hyperloop networks can find a
home among infrastructure Investments
that the Biden Administration hopes to
make the idea that there's multiple
hyperloop companies I think is a
redeeming aspect in the business people
really want to see something happen so
having multiple people move forward
is is good for that I was struck
when Josh and Sarah wrote the Pod two or
three of the major Outlets used the
phrase we now have a new mode of
transport and although all of that
technology had existed before those two
human beings wrote it yeah it was the
moment at which those two human beings
traveled that short distance down the
tube but in popular imagination
hyperloop became a mode of Transport the
metaphor I use with my team is that you
know the Wright brothers were first but
none of us fly on Wright brothers
Airlines anymore if you don't continue
to innovate you're not going to be
around and so we'll continue to be at
the Forefront of building our blue
back in 2013 Elon had an idea
I think the difference now in 2021 is
some brilliant Engineers have spent real
time grinding out the details and I
thoroughly expect the next three to five
years to be decisive
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the great sci-fi art of the mid-20th
century teased a vision of the future
with one distinct element in common a
life for humans in outer space whether
vacationing on an exotic new planet or
commuting to the moon for business space
travel seemed like it was just around
the corner
yet here we are a half century later and
only about 500 human beings have ever
left the bounds of Earth's atmosphere
but thanks to a set of ambitious private
companies betting on the promise of
space tourism that long-awaited future
could be here sooner than we think
[Music]
for most of the history of space flight
governments have been the prime force
behind nearly every aspect from planning
to funding to crew selection
but as early as the 1980s proposals for
commercial space tourism began to emerge
along with innovative solutions for
getting people there such as the wild
concept of sticking a 74-person
passenger cabin in the cargo bay of a
NASA space shuttle although various
non-astronauts have been selected for
Missions over the years true space
tourism didn't happen until 2001. when
an entrepreneur named Dennis Tito
coughed up an estimated 20 million
dollars to hitch a ride with the Russian
Federal Space Agency for a week-long
vacation aboard the International Space
Station 20 years later we're seeing a
new contender in this final frontier of
Tourism
private companies it's becoming a
private Enterprise
situation still very high risk with a
high reward potential reward but you
know government is really out of the
business of flying people now and it's
it's really going to be companies like
Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos and Richard
Branson that that do that heavy lifting
commercial space tourism is usually
about taking the non-astronaut the
private citizen into an orbital or
sub-orbital of light so you get a short
amount of microgravity experience and
you can float and take some photos and
then you come back this was something
that technology had gotten to a point
where the private sector was going to
make a business out of this
there are multiple companies that want
to get to the place where they fly
people into space
the first of these is blue origin
founded in 2000 by Jeff Bezos using the
autonomous rocket system new Shepard a
tribute to the first American in space
blue origin plans to launch up to six
passengers at a time offering a rarefied
treat of 62 mile high views and a
momentary experience of weightlessness
booking officially kicked off in May
2021 with the very first seat to be
auctioned off for charity meanwhile
Richard Branson's Virgin Galactic has
also been pursuing a viable form of
suborbital Tourism aiming for a launch
in 2022 once Sir Richard himself has
taken a flight I'm hoping to be able to
go to space I'd love to be able to
coincide it with the moon landing and go
to space
so I've got the whip on the team and
we'll see how he goes
claims to have lined up over 600 seat
reservations so far including Justin
Bieber and Leonardo DiCaprio virgin has
projected that the final cost of the
ticket will be at least 250 thousand
dollars or roughly fifty thousand
dollars for each of the five minutes or
so of weightlessness that you'll get to
experience although costly both
companies offerings aim to make
sub-orbital flight a regular form of
Adventure travel eventually driving down
costs at scale to expand the customer
base beyond the orbit of celebrities and
billionaires the third major Contender
is Elon musk's SpaceX which has set its
sights even higher on orbital flights
which are a whole nother level of
complexity and energy and danger when
you go suborbital if you're just going
to go up above the Von Carmen line which
is 100 kilometers or about 62 miles you
only need to get up to maybe 5 000 miles
an hour to get up there and you go
basically straight up and then straight
back down you don't have the re-entry
heating that you would see coming in
from an orbital so when you go orbital I
don't care if you're a baseball or a
battleship you've got to go 17
500 miles per hour not just five
thousand miles an hour the energy is
involved Are Much Greater by doing that
SpaceX has gone another level up and
that's what they're doing with the
inspiration for visit inspiration4.com
for your chance
to go to space
inspiration 4 is the first planned all
civilian Mission into orbit slated to
launch in late 2021 the crew will bring
their own set of diverse perspectives
and backgrounds and experiences to test
how a group of different people namely
people who aren't professional
astronauts could fare in space
until now astronauts have had to be
physically perfect and this mission is
changing that and so I feel incredibly
honored to to be representing those who
aren't physically perfect
at age 10 I was diagnosed with bone
cancer and I was treated at St Jude
Children's Research Hospital and I spent
a year there undergoing intense chemo
and also surgery that ultimately saved
my leg I now work at St Jude as a PA a
physician assistant and I work with
Leukemia and Lymphoma patients the kids
we work with are are so brave and they
are very excited to watch me go to space
because this is showing them that you
know they they're capable of doing this
as well Haley along with three other
crew members will spend three days in
space orbiting the Earth every 90
minutes before landing back off the
coast of Florida well when you think
about access the first the astronauts
for the United States came from the test
pilot side and and so women weren't
allowed to be a part of that we have
somebody in their 20s somebody in their
30s somebody in the 40s and somebody in
their 50s and so there can be access in
all kinds of way whether you're talking
about age whether you're talking about
gender what do you talking about race
and ethnicity and all of those things
the first time you know people are going
up into space and not sent there by
superpower like the United States or
Russia or China well that's like really
significant
um and you know you you've gotta you
know be very thoughtful about it the
whole game plan right now is to make
space like really affordable and you
know accessible for everybody so you can
have fishing buddies go into space
someday but the first is special
um and so with that we wanted to have
you know a cruise selection process that
could make space available to Everyday
People
getting to space is only the first step
for space tourism the next challenge is
what to do and where to stay when you
get there
Axiom space is planning to launch the
first segment of a new commercial space
station in 2024. their two billion
dollar project called ax station will
become the first free-flying private
International Space Station
or to use a more consumer-friendly term
a space Hotel
Axiom isn't the only company out to make
your space stay a little more
comfortable big low Aerospace has been
building what they call expandable
habitat technology like their b330 an
inflatable pod module that expands once
in orbit there's even one attached to
the National Space Station right now
they've been testing it and you take it
up and it's rather small and then you
inflate it and it seems to be working
very very well this is likely to be the
first kind of tourist
uh hotel that you're going to see up in
space first of all it's easy to carry
instead of this giant tin can with all
of that the Inflatables are lighter uh
you can just blow them up and they they
get a nice big size for about you know
half the less than half the weight
probably
but even as space missions become
accessible to civilians the risks of
going to space are incredibly high and
you could die a thousand ways that we
can think of in a thousand other ways
that we can't think of this is Michelle
Hanlon she's a space lawyer at the
Mississippi school of law focused on
protecting humans in outer space now I'm
not an attorney for any of the space
tourists so I haven't been privy to
their private contracts but I can tell
you that the FAA requires certain
waivers to be in those contracts so for
example the FAA says well we're not
going to make you make your spacecraft
to a certain safety level we are going
to make you spacecraft operator make
sure that you inform your space tourists
of all of that hazards that you know of
that I'd imagine a very long waiver of
all the ways you can die in space
and you have to understand that there's
health risks and you have to indemnify
the US government if you are launching
from the United States so those are
things that we know a space tourist has
to sign and has to wait so now let's go
back and think about our space flight
participants the FAA calls space
tourists space flight participants they
don't call them astronauts why is that
important if you're not an astronaut
there's no obligation to rescue you if
something goes wrong it's a lot of money
to set up a rescue launch if it can even
be done it's something really important
to think about and that difference as we
as we cross this threshold from having
astronauts in space to having real
people like me in space
and when we are able to make it to space
reliably enough there's still a host of
other legal and ethical issues to
consider before space tourism can truly
take off
there are so many gaps in space law that
we are going to have to put in a lot of
sort of basement ideas and so for
example the outer space treaty is a
treaty that offers principles and
guidelines for State activities for the
activities of national governments
doesn't talk about private entities
doesn't talk about humans in space so
now if something goes wrong so let's
think about all the times hotels on
Earth are sued right so slip and Falls
you step on something on in the bathroom
you see the hotel and it becomes a
private lawsuit because of the vagaries
of international law if something
happens in space well boy you can sue
the state that launched your spacecraft
you can sue the company that brought you
there you can sue the hotel you can sue
the individual you can sue every
government related to that because the
way the the outer space treaty in the
outer space regime have set this up is
that anything that happens in space
first has to go through a diplomatic
channel before you've got a channel
before you think about suing in a court
of law and so every single slip fall in
a haste in a space hotel is a diplomatic
Nightmare and so we really need to
figure that out before we before we
start sending a lot of people there you
think about human rights in space here
we don't think about a human right to
oxygen because it's kind of all around
us and free it's not in a space Hotel so
what happens if something happens in the
oxygen depletes who gets the oxygen
first and then of course let's not even
think about the labor how do you treat
your labor in a space hotel where that
person it may be there for two or three
years without committing back to Earth
so a lot of things to think about
space habitats are more likely in the
near future to focus on Research
missions and be a home for experiments
that can't happen as easily back on
Earth uh space hotels I I think they
Garner a lot of headlines on a lot of
news but at the same time that's not the
first thing that you're going to see
happen they don't offer the compelling
business case I think that you'll see
from a place that wants to manufacture
Pharmaceuticals or a new type of Crystal
or some type of filament or Fiber Optic
Cables and other things that you can do
in microgravity the things that are
actually you know a high value
uh finished good when you get that back
to Earth and you sell it for a very very
huge profit margin that's what's likely
to happen in space as opposed to having
a a real estate platform that you sell
to a tourist by a space Hotel it's
really interesting and it will probably
happen but it's not likely to be at the
Forefront of space Commerce
even if space hotels are right around
the corner don't get too excited about
booking a trip in one it's not a cheap
ticket to ride to space and and it's
going to be you know Millionaires and
billionaires and and that sort but at
the same time you know the point was
made that in the early days of Airline
trips that was also a completely
unaffordable ticket for most people
those people who flew were people of
means and over time it becomes
affordable to the masses and I think
that's the goal for all the
entrepreneurs in space as well to get
those costs down to a point where it's
not 10 million or 5 million dollar or
three hundred thousand dollar ride into
suborbital space when it becomes more
like buying a first class ticket to go
to Europe from the United States so that
that's the goal and you know the
question is can can we get to that point
given the immense operating costs of
getting to space it may be years if ever
until space tourism becomes a profitable
Venture for any of these companies
Virgin Galactic the only publicly traded
company of the three has had a
particularly Rocky year initially riding
on the momentum of a SPAC deal but more
recently beset by launch delays and
major funders including Branson himself
selling large quantities of their stock
at the company Space is really really
really hard and it's an absolute cliche
but it's one that happens to be very
true it's just really hard to do that's
also the reason that you've seen the
delays that you know virgin had talked
about flying years and years ago and it
became such a crazy point that Richard
Branson actually stopped talking about
it when he was asked because it was
never going to be when he predicted but
it's not insurmountable and you know
investors have stepped up because this
is something that is doable foreign
despite the astronomical dangers and
costs of getting to space it may
ultimately follow the course of other
once fanciful modes of travel
Wright brothers having you know what was
by modern standards a very unimpressive
first flight you know at Kitty Hawk I
mean you know you had like less than 20
years later you had your first Airborne
ambulances being used to to save lives
fundamentally the world is a more
interesting place when people can go and
dance Among the Stars and such The Lure
of space is in a it's in our DNA it's
that that exploration bug we are an
exploratory species and we want to go
out there and see what's out there that
Vision that I had in 1969 of seeing
normal human beings traveling to space
it's finally beginning to happen when
you get a bunch of people up there and
they can all see it for themselves
that'll create even yet another
revolution in how we treat our planet
and the way we think about it
so while 2001 came and went without
quite looking like Stanley Kubrick's
ultimate space fantasy 2021 might
finally be the year we're catching up
access the financial World On Demand
foreign economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
have you ever been cruising on a highway
and wondered where the heck are all
those trucks going
[Music]
it's world of logistics that makes
virtually everything in our modern lives
possible
[Music]
not only do we take it for granted we're
completely oblivious to its
environmental cost
but thanks to a handful of companies
there is a hidden Revolution happening
that as it turns out is perfectly suited
to delivering a cleaner future
[Music]
for years online ordering and Rapid home
delivery have been booming
and thanks to the pandemic this trend
has evolved into a way of life
but what actually happens when I click
that tempting button to buy let's say an
old school real hardcover book
for Mighty Amazon which tends to capture
the Lion's Share of all Book Sales
they're trucked along with other books
to one of several Amazon inbound
fulfillment centers now the book is in
Amazon's massive fulfillment Network
copies then Journey along the so-called
middle Mile and can be redistributed to
any of the hundreds of smaller
warehouses or nodes closer to customers
and major population centers
the last step is the so-called Last Mile
how it gets to a buyer's home the book
might be sent to an Amazon delivery
station and put in the back of a
Mercedes Sprinter van and dropped off by
Amazon itself at the customer's front
door
this system while it's a Marvel of
modern day Logistics still relies mostly
on traditional combustion engine
vehicles for middle and last mile
delivery
as demand for Rush delivery Rises so
does the number of gas guzzling trucks
hustling between warehouses
environmentally it's one of the biggest
issues there is and you know the quicker
that the globe can sort of decarbonize
Transportation the better it's going to
be so if you look at total greenhouse
gas emissions in the U.S about 28
percent of that is transportation and of
that chunk of the 28 about a quarter of
it come from medium and heavy duty
trucks so middle Mile and sort of
long-haul Trucking if you really want to
move the needle on carbon emissions this
is a really good place to look
so how do we solve this growing
emissions problem and still satisfy our
addiction to same-day delivery as it
turns out the size shape and predictable
limited range of these vehicles makes
them the perfect candidate for a
solution
I'm Dakota semler I'm the CEO and
co-founder of exos trucks so we are a
manufacturer of commercial electric
vehicles we manufacture trucks that are
in the class 5 size all the way up to
Class 8 Regional Hall tractors and those
are things like the UPS or FedEx step
bands that you see delivering packages
every day
we actually started this because we were
Fleet operators ourselves we had a fleet
of medium duty vehicles and we saw how
challenging it was becoming to operate
diesel vehicles the technology exists to
convert Last Mile fleets from diesel to
Electric batteries and and the prices of
those batteries have fallen dramatically
in the last 10 years and any routes that
are around 200 miles or less are really
ready to make that transition
so exos is trying to perfect the frame
of the car they call it the chassis so
this is everything sort of underpinning
the car the electric motors the battery
pack all the battery software and
Cooling and technology and kind of the
brains of the car if you will and then
the business model is basically to sell
that and let the end consumer dictate
what goes on top
our platform we call the x-platform UPS
is using an x-platform with a parcel
delivery van body on top of it Loomis
who operates an armored car Fleet uses
the same exact X platform but with an
armored body on top of it
exos is currently making their modular
battery packs here in Los Angeles and
the packs can be customized for specific
applications but while one big problem
vehicle cost is improving as battery
prices continue to fall there's still
another major hurdle at the other end
the best way to describe the current
state of charting infrastructure in the
US is anemic these companies don't want
to build Chargers unless they're
electric vehicles people don't want to
buy electric vehicles unless there's
Chargers
that's a big problem for the personal EV
space where range anxiety is often cited
as a roadblock to mass adoption
but when it comes to delivery there's a
much simpler solution
when you think about Last Mile Vehicles
they're not operating in different bases
of operation they actually return to the
same Depot every single night where they
do their charging exos actually has a
division helping fleets install that
charging infrastructure these fleets
will actually bring their vehicles back
to the yard they charge them overnight
and then by the time the morning rolls
around for their next shift those
vehicles are fully charged ready to go
with the infrastructure that's on site
with pilot programs up and running with
delivery Giants UPS FedEx and Amazon
exos is quickly becoming a major
contender in the electrification game
enormous part of this puzzle which may
end up eliminating more than just
gasoline so I'm going I'm the co-founder
and CEO of Gothic I've got that we do
autonomous vehicles for the middle mile
segment of the supply chain again middle
mile is One Step Back From Last Mile
Trucking that goes from one Factory or
Warehouse to another the middle mileage
is evolving at a rapid pace and with the
pandemic the middle mile segment of the
supply chain was put into high gear
the prominence and the significance of
the middle mile is only gonna grow in
the coming years
so characters are a really interesting
company what they're doing is trying to
both make middle mile delivery
autonomous and electric so they're
trying to move the ball in two ways here
and what's really interesting with them
is they focus specifically on certain
sector of users namely large companies
that have very fixed routes just as the
predictable routes of shipping and
delivery make electrification easier
they make autonomy a lot easier too
if your trucks are going the same way
every single time like gothics that's a
much easier puzzle for an AI to navigate
so what they do
they find the route they need to run
and they agonize over it for four to six
weeks just mapping it inside and out
figuring out where all the trouble spots
might be and and coding their vehicles
to deal with it and often it's not
they're not taking the most director out
they're taking the safest route they're
taking the route that's most predictable
in terms of traffic
there's a common understanding in the
industry that unpredictable left turns
and doing multiple Lane changes are some
of the most trickiest problems in the AV
space with middle mile frankly you can
avoid all of that you can take three
right turns to make a left turn you know
a bag of potatoes uh won't care
's ultimate goal is to provide a cheaper
cleaner alternative to the middle mile
of today by saving money on gas and
maintenance by electric motors and
saving money on well drivers by going
autonomous
they've already sold some major players
on their vision and scoring Walmart as a
customer owes well for the future
startups like Gothic and exos are
betting that the delivery industry is
ready for a full-on high-tech refit
in a sector where only about one percent
of vehicles have been electrified
that's a lot of potential for change
you know the usual suspects are where
you're gonna
see adoption come first you know the
larger more stable companies so Walmart
Amazon UPS FedEx Etc I think you'll see
them experimenting with it more and and
the more routes that they can get it to
make sense on the faster adoption is
going to be
and as the technology matures and
batteries continue to get cheaper
there's another huge category of
vehicles that's right for this kind of
an upgrade
so the Biden Administration has been
super aggressive about a pledge to
Electrify the entire Federal vehicle
Fleet which is just under 700 000
Vehicles what's interesting is the
federal Fleet is both really old and
really inefficient the average age of
these cars and trucks about 14 years and
the average cost is about a dollar a
mile when you add up Fuel and
maintenance and depreciation which are
the three big ones it's a good place to
look if you're looking to to get carbon
out of the transportation system
[Music]
while the most exciting and flashy
developments in the world of electric
vehicles are usually around personal EVS
the more impactful transition is
happening behind the scenes
so the next time you order something
online
and it effortlessly appears in your
doorstep
your package might have made at least
some of its hidden Journey without
consuming an ounce of gasoline
[Music]
foreign
thank you I was born in Iran
I've witnessed ballistic missiles coming
down
[Music]
that made me think that okay what are
the things that I would like to change
what are the things that I would like to
impact and at the end of the day I think
you need to be a responsible for using
any technology in a positive fashion
if there's anyone out there that could
steer the thrust of technology away from
our own demise and toward the betterment
of humanity this could be the guy my
name is Ali hajimiri I am an educator
and an engineer and an inventor
this very young age I was really curious
to find out how things work any kind of
toy I had I you know within a couple of
days it was ripped apart and opened uh
and turned torn into pieces and you know
my parents were not a huge fan of that
but throughout the process I tried to
then build things myself at some point I
tried to make a laser when I was I think
like 10 or 11 and I didn't succeed but
Hajime made up for that failure in his
adult life
today he holds more than 90 issued
patents and along with his tenure at
Caltech carries a reputation of making
ideas that would otherwise sound like
science fiction a reality things that I
work on or some of the inventions if you
will uh that have been involved in they
expand a large gamut lens less cameras
lenses projectors and 3D cameras radar
on a chip self-healing circuits handheld
diagnostic devices Wireless power
transfer space-based solar power they
may appear kind of seemingly unrelated
to each other but they all rely on this
underlying concept of the phase the
raise the phase the race is basically a
large number of small elements working
together
hashimiri's inspiration for phased away
technology comes from an unlikely place
ants as a child I took a big jar of
glass jar and you know I was digging
through an ant and tail and then I took
a whole bunch of ants and just dumped
them in that jar and within a couple of
days they started building the whole
nest because it was really amazing
because it showed how you can achieve
very complex things through interactions
of simple units the face the race is
basically the army of ants
now instead of ants carrying dirt
imagine millions of tiny signals working
in concert to send energy wirelessly
this phased array system is the basis
for hajimiri's latest and most ambitious
project collecting solar power in outer
space and beaming it down to earth
we are in the wireless power transfer
laboratory and we are looking at a setup
for demonstration and testing of a
wireless power transfer here you have a
small version of what would be
collecting power we are basically
creating a beam and focusing of the
energy in this location and what you can
see is that the energy is being
transferred wirelessly and this would be
the unit building block of making the
space-based generator power station this
is an extremely important thing because
first of all it gives access globally to
energy and power it doesn't introduce
any greenhouse gases or any of that sort
in in the process of making of the
energy but the idea of sending power to
Earth from space has some pretty high
profile detractors space solar power
okay the stupidest thing ever
[Laughter]
Skeptics like Elon Musk believe that
after multiple power conversions and the
cost of launches and the sheer scale of
such a project makes it far too
expensive and inefficient forever
trapping it within the confines of
Science Fiction and if anybody should
think it should like stay still a power
it should be me all right I got a I got
a rocket company and a solid company
but this is of listen to a man who has
made his living defying conventional
wisdom he believes that the greatest
Innovations come from an active
imagination
a lot of us are inspired by science
fiction I think science fiction is
essential to the way of thinking about
making useful and interesting things so
you start with a concept that doesn't
exist that could have been articulated
in science fiction and you try to see
what can you do about that can you do it
in an entirety can you do a variation of
that and that process that's part of the
creative process right I mean
engineering is the discipline of
creativity the key question is that how
can you make it in such a way that it's
feasible and also economical and to do
that you have to take a lot of different
kinds of Technologies and bring them
together like an army of ants all
working together at the unlikely
intersection of Science Fiction and
reality
you know nothing is done in isolation no
one person really in today and I think
ever was doing things by themselves you
know if you want to go fast
go alone if you want to go far take your
friends
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jacob Kingston has three wives and 20
children he grew up poor in Utah had
sort of A Hard Scrabble life and was
drawn to a very flashy businessman from
Los Angeles who drove fast cars flew
around in private jets and took
vacations on Yachts Jacob Kingston was
seduced by that lifestyle and that
ultimately led to him leading a much
Fuller life of crime
then
this lady does not deserve to be taken
advantage of especially at your age with
your own grandchild yeah
my grandma is having to sue them I'm
testifying against them nobody's talking
they're one floor below right now I get
afraid to go on the elevator it's sad
that it had to devolve to this it's a
Family Feud a Family Feud
here's a family that on paper you would
think has the wealth that so many people
seek yet at the end of the day it seemed
to sort of rip everybody apart
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
a Utah polygamous family the focus of a
federal raid today that this is the work
of the Lord Utah's Kingston Clan or the
order
it's also called that a breakaway Mormon
group
the order
isn't really well known if you're not a
part of it or if you're not in law
enforcement or if you're not involved in
some type of uh I guess you could call
it the polygamist underworld one of the
unique things about the Kingston Clan
compared to other polygamous groups is
that they do live
right in the middle of suburban Utah and
the way they do this is by not
attracting any attention
they had something like a hundred
businesses including a casino a rifle
manufacturer and the biodiesel fuel plan
the Jacob Kingston set up Jacob Kingston
has three wives and 20 children he grew
up poor in Utah had sort of A Hard
Scrabble life and was drawn to a very
flashy businessman from Los Angeles who
drove fast cars flew around in private
jets and took vacations on Yachts Jacob
Kingston was seduced by that lifestyle
and that ultimately led to him leading a
much Fuller life of crime
[Music]
my name is Jesse Hyde I'm a magazine
writer based in Utah
my name is David voriakis I'm a legal
reporter at Bloomberg News and we wrote
the polygamous accused of scamming the
U.S out of 500 million dollars
Jacob Kingston is part of the Davis
County cooperative Society also known as
the order and in the order the men are
given numbers there's a hierarchy and
they are expected to tie their earnings
into the church and the leaders of the
church have a very strong hand in how
they lead their lives the choices they
make the wives they choose the jobs they
hold
one of their early leaders taught a
principle that's very common in Mormon
fundamentalism called bleeding the Beast
because polygamy is illegal in the U.S
there's a belief that the federal
government really is the enemy
and so with many of these groups there's
nothing wrong with figuring out ways to
quote unquote bleed the Beast or fleece
the government
the Kingstons over the years have been
investigated for
tax fraud child welfare fraud one of the
more common things that former members
told me
they would do and they were encouraged
to do by their leaders
is a mother would go in and claim that
she was a single mom with seven kids
to qualify for different benefits When
in fact she could have been the third or
fourth wife of a husband over the past
few years members of the Kingston Family
who ran a different company called
Washakie Renewable Energy have pleaded
guilty to dozens of charges including
fraud money laundering and obstruction
Jacob Kingston from what I understand
actually had the idea to build
this biodiesel production plant he
recognized that there was a huge
opportunity the federal government was
really pushing renewable energy
alternative fuels and there were big tax
credits you could get
prior to Jacob
they had sort of focused on businesses
like pawn shops
um or you know commercial property
that's kind of
shabbier
Jacob was taking them into the big
leagues where you know he's standing
courtside at halftime at a Utah Jazz
game presenting a big check to a charity
so this really was a matter of moving
from the Shadows
into the public Arena
you could almost think of like The
Godfather or any sort of Mafia movie
where over time you know you want to go
into legitimate business you don't want
to live in the shadows anymore
after Jacob Kingston got his PhD in
engineering he then set up a plant in
Northern Utah on his father's Ranch what
they did was produce biodiesel fuel
which takes animal fat or used cooking
oil and through a chemical process
converts it into a type of fuel that
works in trucks and in manufacturing
facilities
the pure version of that fuel is known
as B100 and what they then did was apply
for tax credits that are administered by
both the Environmental Protection Agency
and the Internal Revenue Service those
tax credits were a dollar a gallon for
the fuel that they produced that was
B100 or what's called b99 a slightly
diluted version and they also got credit
for a renewable identification number or
a Rin Rin and that was a dollar a gallon
as well and those are sort of a unique
number that can be traded between
companies Washakie Renewable Energy a
proud partner of the tour of Utah is
leading the Intermountain West to a
future where our air is clear clean and
healthy it did start as a legitimate
business Kingston found that he could
not compete because of the limitations
on his location
and the difficulties in producing the
material so he began to cut Corners in
cheat the way other people in the
industry did as well
[Music]
in 2011 washiki had run into some
troubles the biodiesel they were
creating called b99
was being rejected it wasn't pure enough
and so he was looking for someone to buy
it and so he had sent a Salesman out
to people who were involved in this
business who might buy it and that's how
he came across
Lev durman and that was the beginning of
what initially was a really profitable
Enterprise for both of them
Lev durman who called himself the lion
was a man who you could say a self-made
immigrant who created an oil and gas
Empire in Southern California
and in his adult life he was constantly
under investigation and we talked to one
of his associates who said that the
first time he met Lev
he was struck by a guy who was almost
like wearing a costume of a mobster he's
wearing blue alligator shoes a blue
alligator belt you know he had an office
in Rodeo Drive and it was like hey let's
go down here for a meal
you know My Chauffeur will take us and
you know it's like a block away but hey
if I can get into my Rolls-Royce and
take you a block and the restaurant's
shut down just for me
um that's going to create
this appearance that I am
um I don't know like an organized crime
boss
and so he sort of carried himself that
way
it's a question of how much of that was
just for appearance and how much of that
was real
[Music]
when they first met Liv German flew his
private jet to Utah to meet Jacob
Kingston and his wife Sally durman then
flew them to Seattle
to meet a friend of his he wined him and
dined them the Kingstons had never been
wined and dined before they'd never been
on a private jet they went to a seafood
store and
Lev durman bought the entire contents of
the seafood store to bring home for the
Kingstons
over time Jacob Kingston was dazzled by
Lev Germans fast living lifestyle they
bought very expensive sports cars like a
1.8 million dollar Bugatti for Lev
durman they bought Waterfront house in
California for Lev German they bought a
three million dollar house in Utah for
Jacob Kingston they took trips together
he started dressing in a flashier way
started wearing cologne he started
cutting his hair differently it really
started to change him he got a taste for
the High Life
and he wanted that and in pursuing that
he was sort of breaking an unspoken
order rule and that rule is to not draw
attention
if you start wearing flashy suits and
driving
fancy cars and having a luxury suite at
Utah Jazz games
being public with your company
sponsoring different things you're going
to draw attention and so Jacob had a
dilemma
do we keep operating the way my uncles
have run the family by staying in the
shadows
or do we go big do we try to make a lot
of money
and for whatever reason he chose the
latter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the EPA did not enforce its standards
stringently and what fraudsters soon
learn is that if they were able to
produce documentation that showed that
they had produced biodiesel fuel that
the government accepted that
documentation and they got you know
their credits eventually the government
got more sophisticated at rooting out
the fraudsters but there were several
years particularly in the early years
Jacob Kingston and Lev durman
perpetrating their fraud that the
government was not able to keep up with
the fraudsters
so there was one particular fraud where
the Kingston's and left durman used A
supplier in Florida and Houston who
shipped b-99 on a barge and sent it to
the east coast of Panama and that
generated phony paperwork and then they
trucked it over to the West Coast of
Panama and they put it on a different
boat and shipped it up to Los Angeles
where levderman's company said that he
was shipping it to Utah for processing
at Kingston biodiesel fuel plant the
washaki plant
I talked to a guy who worked for Jacob
and he told me that they filled up an
entire rail car with water
as long as they had the documents to
show that they were moving what looked
like biodiesel
the inspections were so LAX to basically
like non-existent but that was enough to
fool the government and cash in on these
tax credits
the largest and most dramatic example
were two checks combined totaled more
than 160 million dollars that was
ultimately their biggest payday
there were other claims that they put in
that were
disallowed as the government eventually
caught on fully to their fraud Jacob
Kingston and his family were arrested as
they boarded a plane in Salt Lake City
headed for turkey
anything you'd like to say and there's
my client's not going to have any
a lot of the initial questions that
prosecutors were starting to ask kind of
tipped their hand that this wasn't going
to just be
a case about washki renewable energy
this was going to be a case about the
order and all of their businesses and
this would put everything they had built
at risk so in a way
you know Jacob took this big gamble for
the family
you know let's go big time let's step
out of the Shadows let's make a lot of
money
and and at the end he paid the ultimate
price yeah that's right the Kingston
Clan has their fingers in all kinds of
businesses oil Lubes grocery stores uh
hardware stores private investigator
firms biodiesel and that biodiesel
allegedly helped pay for that four
million dollar mansion in Sandy where
one of those warrants was served today
the prosecutors were helped at trial by
the cooperation of five people who had
pleaded guilty and testified under
cooperation agreements
they included Jacob Kingston and his
younger brother Isaiah
prosecutors showed at trial that they
made
nearly 500 million dollars and that the
claims accelerated at the end of the
fraud
he then sent through a very complex
Financial path tens of millions of
dollars to live German
now to an eyewitness news investigation
and the strange alliance between a
suspected mobster here in LA and a
polygamous clan in Utah Liv durman was
convicted in March of 2020
after a six-week trial of conspiracy
money laundering and fraud charges
German's lawyer complained that the
jurors panicked and reached a quick
decision only because they were scared
about covid-19 and they wanted to get
out of there I've known my client for
decades and I'm I'm confident that when
he tells me he did nothing wrong that
he's telling the truth the second phase
of Lev durman's criminal trial will be a
forfeiture proceeding that begins later
this year in which the government is
trying to recover assets that they say
were the product of money laundering
both live durman and Jacob Kingston are
in jail around Salt Lake City
neither has been sentenced
Lev durman faces life in prison
Jacob Kingston also faces many years in
prison but as a result of his
cooperation
and the successful conviction of Lev
German it's likely that he would get far
less time than he ultimately could face
for the crimes he admitted in pleading
guilty
the Kingston fraud was the largest
biodiesel fuel fraud in U.S history more
than 30 cases no one had been accused of
the level of fraud that they engaged in
that they admitted engaging in
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
World On Demand
foreign hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
at bloomberg.com webinars
this is The Awful Truth
there's always someone in the family
that's pushing it
this lady
does not deserve to be taken advantage
of especially at your age with your own
grandchild yeah my grandma is having to
sue them I'm testifying against them
nobody's talking they're one floor below
right now I get afraid to go in the
elevator it's sad that it had to devolve
to this it's like a soap operator very
sad thing it's a Family Feud a Family
Feud here's a family that on paper you
would think has the wealth that so many
people seek yet at the end of the day it
seemed to sort of rip everybody apart
my name is Tom Schoenberg I'm a senior
reporter here at Bloomberg News cover
Financial enforcement I was approached
by someone close to the schonstein
family and asked whether or not I would
be interested in writing about Beverly
Schottenstein and this case that she had
against JP Morgan and it was immediately
clear that there was a great story here
to be told
so I started just you know assembling
all sorts of documents that the family
made available to me that included a
diary that Beverly had begun writing
when she started having suspicions about
what was actually going on with her
money
Beverly obtained her wealth from the
Schottenstein kind of retail Empire that
has at times included Big Lots Value
City American Eagle Outfitters DSW Shoes
Beverly's husband died and at which
point they sold off their portion of the
company bringing them an enormous amount
of wealth at around 1990. estimates of
her wealth were around 90 million
dollars she for many years had that pool
of money being managed by outside
advisors her Grandsons in the late 2000s
had both graduated and were becoming
financial advisors she gave them a
little bit to work with and over time
her grandson Evan became the trustee of
her entire estate
managing sort of family money uh is not
a conflict in fact some ways in wealth
management it's kind of how you get your
start it's kind of the seed that you
need to sort of get going in the
business but Beverly started having
suspicions that something was wrong
probably in around 2016.
well there were
separately without everyone talking
about their own experiences it was hard
to really put it together
had written a check to her caretaker
Dawn that bounced so she went down to
her local Chase branch to sort of find
out what was going on she wasn't getting
paper statements in the mail so she
asked them to print out a number of her
statements having to do with her
checking account and her credit card
account so we went to the bank and asked
for the statements and she got a whole
year and going through all of them Page
by Page by Page and it was there she saw
all sorts of charges that she said she
didn't authorize or didn't know about I
was becoming very very suspicious I was
starting to look in the money part and
that's what bothered me more when I saw
that money was going and I was not a big
spender
around the same time Dawn she starts
noticing Beverly's son who lived in the
condominium below her came up with Evan
with a shredder and started grabbing
papers in her office area including some
with JP Morgan letterhead and just sat
started sitting at the kitchen table
just shredding documents over and over
yeah they came in one morning they used
to do it the back through the back door
and they brought this Shredder inside
and then they went in the draws in the
office and took out all the papers and
they started doing it I was very
suspicious because I know you don't go
around and getting destroying papers
Beverly said that they had done this
many times before that's when she said
to me you know Don I'm gonna write my
feelings in this black book diary and
it's a diary and she started writing
each day she would write a little at a
time
around the holidays of 2018 the package
had arrived a FedEx package and in it
were materials about a venture capital
fund based out of the Cayman Islands
dawn and some other family members take
a look at this and they see that Beverly
is signed up for this fund to the tune
over 5 million dollars over the course
of several years and that was really the
beginning of it
um that was sort of the tip of the
iceberg when it became obvious that
something was going on that my
grandmother really wasn't aware of this
fund
you know Beverly started to panic she
got really upset and called you know JP
Morgan's headquarters in New York and
asked for Jamie Diamond she said she was
told someone would call her back but she
says that that never happened she wrote
a letter to Evan and Avi and in there
she she laid out a number of things that
were concerning her on authorized
trading the checking account she had
about a million dollars worth of Jewelry
in a safe deposit box and that her son
Bobby had the key to that box and that
that jewelry had gone missing all this
was kind of packaged in this you know
five-page handwritten amendment to a
will and trust there's such an evolving
narrative about why the jewelry was
taken the only truth we really know is
that the jewelry is gone but why it
happened there have been a lot of
different stories you just don't take
your mother's uh
wonderful things and hand it out and
they email that note to JP Morgan to
seize all activity on her account and it
ended up setting off a firestorm after
that as soon as they got this email that
there was a seasoned assist and that she
wanted to send her money and change
brokerage firms they were actually
vacationing one floor below downstairs
they're there right now the next day
Beverly's in her her place a
granddaughter still in in her place
visiting Dawn is there and up comes
Bobby kind of barging through the door
and he's screaming about what was sent
to the JP Morgan they're now
investigating now and he's Furious takes
his mother and sort of puts her into a
chair gets pen and paper and she says
physically forced her to write a
retraction letter they were pushing me
around it was a scary time I was really
afraid too I had to take her to the
doctor
and she did an x-ray
because she was in so much pain the
locks had to be changed the phone number
had to be changed I really thought we
were going to have to hire guards to be
outside just for protection oh it was
terrible horrible scene
Beverly brought her case before the
financial industry regulatory
authorities usually known as finra it
took several months of hearings she sees
all sorts of transactions that's going
on hundreds of them that she claims that
she never knew about never authorized
but yet we're logged in JP Morgan's
files as having been direct requests
from her that included the sale of a
large amount of Apple stock worth
several million dollars as well as all
her stock in Big Lots you know over the
course of their time with JP Morgan Evan
and Avi were making all sorts of trading
on her account that was generating
millions of dollars in commissions for
themselves in the bank yet she was not
sort of getting any of the type of gains
that you would expect sort of an 80
million dollar account in a bullish
Market to be able to get they issued a
ruling entirely in her favor finding
that her grandsons as well as JP Morgan
they were liable for violating their
fiduciary duty misrepresenting
themselves and they also found that the
bank and her grandson Evan were liable
for elder abuse Evan and Avi they were
fired from JP Morgan they issued an
award of about 19 million dollars I
reached out for comment in JPMorgan
emphasized that Evan and Avi were no
longer with the firm and that their
actions do not represent the sort of
values of the of the bank I reached out
to Evan and Avi heard back from their
lawyer saying that you know they
disagree with you know the law and the
facts that finra kind of used to decide
the case against them and are seeing if
they can have it withdrawn
her son Bobby wrote her a letter said
his sons weren't criminals and he also
admits to taking her jewelry and he says
he needed it to pay off some bad
business debts he had
they never once came up to say I'm sorry
if there had been an apology and some
acceptance and and and asking for
forgiveness from my grandmother I don't
think we'd be in the position that we
are now since the piece came out we've
you know we've received dozens of
messages from people many of whom are
telling their own sort of personal Tales
of uh you know kind of financial
advisors gone bad or family members who
got control of an estate and abused uh
you know those Within
seems that it's it's really resonated
with a lot of people like
keep you know hearing a lot of feedback
about Beverly and how you know a lot of
people feel she did the right thing
you're never too old to stand up for
yourself and try to write an injustice
she was adamant that she wanted to stand
up for herself but at the end of the day
they did wrong
it's a painful life lesson
you know Beverly taught them that you
don't mess with Grandma
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
foreign
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
Singapore is one of the world's biggest
oil trading centers and kingdom is a
homegrown oil traders in Singapore
has also always been very secretive it's
helped by its founder okay Lynn his son
and his daughter
so very little is actually known about
him young and we've also got this
Fallout from the Singapore oil Trader
investigation started in April after hin
Liang filed for bankruptcy protection it
was revealed that Lim had asked the
company to hide nearly a billion dollars
in losses from speculating oil Futures
over the years
so we all started when we heard that
major Banks were pulling financing from
the oil Trader in Leong and at first we
were shocked to hear this information
henryong is such a big name in the Asian
oil trading industry and why were the
banks unwilling to finance and long any
further
all the answers only came to us much
later
[Music]
my name is Alfred Tang I'm a senior
reporter with Bloomberg News I am Serene
cheong I'm a reporter at Bloomberg
Serene and I and other colleagues in
Singapore office wrote a story about the
collapse of King Leong one of the
biggest independent oil traders in the
world
so how long is in the business
of what we call
apply shipping fuel to all the vessels
that come into the Singapore ports for
refueling it's actually owned and
founded by Lim un kyun also known as OK
Lim
okaylin was born in fujian province of
China he immigrated to Singapore in
1950s from the associates who've known
okay for decades Oakley was described as
a Loki humble aggressive oil Traders and
always honest to his origin okiling
likes dining in a singapore-based chain
restaurant which serves his homeland
food
he is also known as a king poker player
[Music]
he started off as a one-man one truck
business he would buy fuel from oil
Majors parcel it up into smaller volumes
and resell it to taxi companies to bus
companies as well as to fishing boats
okay limbs business later developed to
involve a lot more of these tank trucks
and later on it also developed to
include an entire fleet of vessels that
will actually work as an integrated
Supply system to allow him to buy float
and sell fuel to customers around the
region
and long actually developed alongside
the Singapore oil trading Hub and has
more and more boats came to Singapore to
Dock and refuel helion grew because it
was opportunistically at the right place
at the right time
so different from Stock Market trading
where information are basically
available publicly oil traders in the
world read on the information private to
a small group and find the business
opportunity our understanding of okay
Lynn is that he is a Trader with a very
big appetite for risk he's also one that
thrives in the very opaque and secretive
Market of oil trading in Asia
so for example at any one point in the
Asian market no one Trader would
actually know exactly how much Supply
and how much demand there is at any
given time OK Lim would reach deep into
his resources and leverage on his
relationships with his counterparts to
actually figure out what exactly was
happening in the market and therefore to
make bold decisions to dominate the
market and create a trading position
that's beneficial for himself once they
purchased the enough physical stockpiles
in the market and create
disruptions in a certain time of period
and a certain area it did squeeze the
market and pushed the prices higher in
that case Hing Liang and okilim can
always sell the inventories and sell the
products to end users or another
merchants for perfect this strategy was
one of the source of his success for
decades but not for this time
[Music]
in April of 2020 my colleague and I had
heard that Banks were pulling financing
and credit lines away from him Leong and
as we know financing credit lines and
liquidity are the lifeblood of trading
so we knew that something big was
brewing but we just didn't know what it
was yet and it was only in the coming
weeks that more information and the
answers were unveiled
covid-19 brought the global economy to a
screeching halt and one industry hit
particularly hard was oil in the USA the
price of oil has collapsed to a record
low as demand dries up and storage runs
out the price of a barrel of West Texas
intermediate which is the Benchmark for
U.S oil today traded as low as minus
forty dollars a barrel it's the first
time the price has turned negative in
history according to the documents we've
seen Kingdom barely hates the physical
stockpiles its purchases so all of its
physical stockpiles are purely exposed
to the market fluctuations
because the oil Benchmark price is
slumped on coronavirus outbreaks in the
world the value of physical stockpiles
of King Leon reduced we know from our
sources that Oakley made opposition bets
on the oil prices because he believed
China will soon put the coronavirus in
control and the demand will recover very
quickly
so operating was right in the first half
of his prediction China did contain the
outbreaks of coronavirus but what okay
Lim didn't see is the outbreak turn into
a pandemic and create larger demand
destructions
and Banks starts coming after him asking
him to replay the unpaid debts dozens of
commercial and investment banks in
Singapore has a combined exposure of 3.5
billion US dollars to hang Leong of
which HSBC had the biggest exposure of
600 million another Banks such as DBS
and ABN had more than 200 million
exposure to Henry
so from speaking to our sources and from
documents that we obtained we came to
realize that hin Leong had actually not
made any profits for a couple of years
and that some of the oil that him young
had used for collaterals were actually
already resold to other customers it was
shocking to see that the company had
actually hit 800 million in losses
the growth model of Singapore the
southeast East Asia and China has been
changed through these years and that
could be part of the reason why hingdon
didn't make any perfect
many countries stopped seeking
replacement of traditional food sale
energy replacing them with memorable
energy such as solar the coronavirus
outbreak is just a trigger always
collapse
the founder of homegrown oil trading
firm hin Liang trading has been charged
with amatement of forgery for the
purpose of cheating Lim un Quinn
allegedly asked an employee to forge a
document to state that Kim Leong had
transferred more than one million
barrels of gas oil to China aviation oil
Corporation this document was allegedly
used to secure almost 77 million dollars
in trade funds from a financial
institution if found guilty Lim could be
jailed for up to 10 years and fined
and lims is one of the most secretive
family business in Singapore multiple
attempts
to hingyang and Ling's family for
comments went unsuccessful
so after the helion at the
Banks found themselves with hundreds of
millions of dollars of losses we're
seeing that the oil industry in Asia is
going through somewhat of an evolution
where smaller companies are finding it
harder to get credit lines and financing
and even bigger companies more reputable
companies are also finding that credit
lines are being shrunken
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
industry experts be alive and on-demand
webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're running a small business
you borrow some money you're paying it
back maybe you've fallen behind maybe
you haven't
and then one day out of the blue
you can't get any of your money out of
the bank your accounts are locked up
they've been seized without any notice
to you
this is happening to small business
people across America every day
and it's enabled by an obscure document
called a confession of judgment
we just kept getting worse there was no
money left
I was ready to take my life to clear
everybody else
I'm Zach miter I'm a reporter at
Bloomberg News I'm Zeke Fox I'm a
reporter for Bloomberg News and Business
Week Magazine and we're the ones who
wrote sign here to lose everything
this is an extraordinary period for
America's economy
foreign
triple digit swings in the stock market
major financial institutions have
teetered on the edge of collapse and
some have failed
after the financial crisis a decade ago
a lot of small businesses needed loans
and they couldn't always get them from
traditional Banks
instead people who stepped in were
called cash advance companies
these guys call businesses across the
country and they're offering quick money
to say that if you're in a tight spot
they can get you 50 100 Grand overnight
the loans are very expensive with
interest rates as high as 300 or 500
percent annualized that's 20 times as
much as you'd pay on a credit card
the merchant cash advance industry has
attracted all sorts of characters
because of the potential to make a quick
profit so there are cash advance Brokers
with convictions for drug smuggling
stock fraud if you go and talk to
someone in the Shady Side of Wall Street
the odds are they either work in cash
advance or they've considered it
one of the biggest companies in the cash
advance space is Yellowstone capital and
it was actually founded by this guy
David glass
I didn't get to where I am today by
losing my clients money
glass actually served as the inspiration
for the classic stock scam movie Boiler
Room you call me when the stock doubles
all right
glass heard about this cash advance boom
and started Yellowstone and it quickly
grew to be one of the biggest cash
advance brokerages
they're lending to small businesses
picture like a plumber or an electrician
or a shopkeeper
but they realized quickly that some
businesses were taking loans and then
just stealing the money essentially like
they had no intention of paying it back
so a lawyer working for Yellowstone and
some other cash advance companies had an
idea that they could revive this age-old
practice called confessions of judgment
foreign
of judgment is something that the
borrower signs as a condition of getting
the loan it basically means they give up
their right to be heard in court
so later on if they miss a payment or
even if the lender wants to claim they
missed the payment it doesn't have to be
true the lender can go to court with
this confession of judgment which gives
them the power to raid the borrower's
bank account
confessions of judgment aren't even
valid in many states but New York state
law allows this practice
the borrowers are all across the country
Cleveland or Topeka Kansas or Los
Angeles but typically they're all
required to sign a confession of
judgment that's valid in a New York
Court
when you stop and think about it it's
crazy that a borrower would admit in
advance to not paying back a loan when
they haven't even received the money yet
it was so illogical I really wanted to
know more
we thought about now maybe we should do
a story but we didn't have a sense of
the scale like is this something that's
used a lot
and we ultimately found like more than
25
000 of these judgments filed in the last
couple years
they were being used to go after
borrowers all over the country
and Yellowstone was filing these things
at a rate of like several a day
this system has no safeguards we found
lots of borrowers who said that
confessions of judgment were filed
against them when it was not warranted
or the cash advance company seized more
money than they were owed we found
after talking to borrowers that a lot of
them had had their lives turned upside
down by confessions of judgment
my name is Jerry Bush Jr
um basically was a plumber for about 30
years
Bush ran a plumbing business with his
father near Roanoke Virginia and the
company got a lot of jobs but he had
cash flow problems and he started taking
these cash advances a confession
judgment that was a party contract that
you had to sign and they have very high
interest rates but we needed money so we
kept taking more and more of these loans
in order to get the money to pay the
loans he already had it got to be so bad
that he was paying back eighteen
thousand dollars a day at one point so I
had to close doors because there was no
way I could make the payments
the way these contracts work the cash
advance companies shouldn't be able to
go after someone to collect if their
business fails
but because Jerry had signed these
confessions of judgment the cash advance
companies went after him they've got my
father's retirement money they took on
my son's account which he was 17 but
they said my name was on account so they
took out his savings
I kept getting calls one funny company
told me he said you had two ways out
winning lottery or um die
I took the chance and I was I'm ready to
take my life to clear everybody else
he took a lot of pain pills walked out
into the woods near his house and
recorded a video in which he said
goodbye to his son and wife
they found him and took him to the
hospital
I'm surviving every day
My Hope Is that they will stop these
confession judgments
I write to senders Congress almost every
week and I'm just hoping we can get some
laws passed
[Music]
after we follow the story in November of
2018 we got quite a lot of response from
government officials
on the federal level members of Congress
in both Chambers have filed legislation
to end the practice of confession of
judgment Nationwide
in New York the state attorney general
has opened an investigation
and among the companies they're looking
at are Yellowstone capital
this is a story that needed a light
shown on it actively by the Press
if we hadn't published it when we did
you wouldn't see the official reaction
that you see now
but while that's going on people are
still having confessions of judgment
filed against them every day
you look up Yellowstone Capital you can
see there are salesmen on Instagram
posting pictures of their Lamborghinis
diamond watches fancy vacations
um so they seem to be doing great
even if confessions of judgment go away
there are all kinds of other abusive
practices in the cash advance industry
from Brokers signing customers up for
loans they don't really want to lenders
trying to collect money they were never
owed so you're probably going to be
hearing more about this industry for
years to come
foreign
[Music]
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
access the financial World On Demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and Industry experts be alive and
on-demand webinars only from Bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit